SO -- SO
AGAIN OUT OF ALL TEN RECAP AT
WELCOME TODAY'S THAT'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WITH THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
ON EDUCATION FINANCE IN THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
THIS HEARING IS ON REFORMING OUR
COLLEGE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
WORLD CLASS CAL GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH IS.
PHENOMENAL EFFORT TO PAY FOR
TUITION FOR LOWER INCOME.
FAMILIES A CALIFORNIA GO TO
COLLEGE BUT WE KNOW THE COST OF
COLLEGE IS MUCH MORE THAN
TUITION TODAY.
ITS HOUSING UNITS BOOKS IN
TRANSPORTATION AND FOOD AND
WE'RE SQUEEZING OUT.
THOUSANDS OF THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WHO WHO NEED A COLLEGE
EDUCATION AND THEIR AVERAGE DEBT
NOW IS NORTH OF TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND SO ONE THING THAT WE
WANT TO LOOK AT TODAY IS HOW CAN
WE MODERNIZE AND RE VAMP ARE CAL
GRANT.
PROGRAM THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM AND SERVE --
MORE STUDENTS WHO JUST MISS OUT
WHO JUST WHO JUST LOOK OUTSIDE
THE CRACKS.
BUT ALSO LOOK AT THIS NOTION OF
DEATH TALK ABOUT FREE COLLEGE
THAT WE THINK THAT WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON DEBT FREE COLLEGE
STUDENTS AND PARENTS HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO STEP UP A LITTLE
BIT AS MUCH AS THEY CAN AFFORD.
BUT STUDENTS SHOULD NOT BE
SADDLED WITH --
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
DEBT AND AN IMPACT THEIR ABILITY
TO MOVE ON WITH THEIR LIVES AND
A COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY IS A KEY
ISSUE WE ALSO KNOW THAT WE NEED
TO GET MORE PEOPLE IN COLLEGE WE
HAVE OTHER HEARINGS ABOUT.
THE DEGREE GAP WE NEED TO
MILLION MORE COLLEGE GRADUATES.
CALIFORNIA'S WE NEED TO GET
PEOPLE OFF OF THE SIDELINES IT
INTO INTO COLLEGE YOU KNOW
SPECIALLY WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS --
THE LACK OF FINANCIAL. FOR THAT
THE NON TUITION COSTS HE KEEPS
THEM ON THE SIDELINES AND THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE --
BEING DENIED ARE THE SAME
STUDENTS WERE TRYING TO GET IN
HIGHER EDUCATION THE FIRST IN
THE FIRST PLACE SO.
WITH A LOT OF WORK IN THIS LAST
COUPLE YEARS AND TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO LOOK AT SOME POTENTIAL
SOLUTIONS TO INCLUDE.
IN THE BUDGET AS WELL AS
LEGISLATION AND SO LOOK FORWARD
TO TODAY'S HERE MISTER MEDINA.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY --
IS GREAT TO SEE SO MANY STUDENTS
AND STAKEHOLDERS HERE THIS
MORNING --
AS I SAID AT A PRESS CONFERENCE
WERE.
ON THE STEPS OF THE WE'VE HEARD
THE VOICES OF THE STUDENTS AND
THE LAST YEAR.
THAT.
ARE STUDENT AID --
AS IT IS SET UP NOW DOES NOT
MEET AS SENATOR AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY.
AS STATED THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
TO GO TO COLLEGE AS WE TALK
ABOUT THE GAP.
THE GAP THE EDUCATIONAL GAP
CERTAINLY MY AREA OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE.
THE THE AREA OF THE STATE WITH
THE BIGGEST --
ACHIEVEMENT GAP WITH THE BIGGEST
WITH THE LOWEST COLLEGE GOING
RATE SO WE WANT.
TO TODAY BEGAN.
TO TAKE AWAY AND COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS WE'VE HEARD THE
PROBLEMS OVER THE LAST YEAR.
A WEEK WE UNDERSTAND THE ISSUES
AND TODAY AS WE COME INTO THIS
HEARING WE WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU.
OF WHAT WE CAN DO.
WHAT WHAT SOLUTIONS THERE ARE TO
THE PROBLEMS TO FIX?
AN OVERLY COMPLEX --
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE NOW WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO HAVE ONE THAT
THAT MEETS THE STUDENTS NEEDS
AND IS AT THE SAME TIME --
I HOPE MORE USER FRIENDLY MORE
STUDENT FRIENDLY.
SO AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THE SHORT COMINGS FORWARD
TO THE PANELISTS.
AND THE PRESENTERS TO OFFER
SOLUTIONS.
THAT WE CAN USE THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY AND I CAN USE AN
A. B. THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THE CAL
GRANT REFORM BILL OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND I LOOK.
TO OTHER MEMBERS.
ON THE DíAS IF THEY WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT WE WILL WE
WILL START TODAY'S HEARING WILL
BRING UP THE FIRST PANEL.
FOCUSED ON MOVING BEYOND THE
CURRENT CAL GRANT MODEL WE HAVE
THE STATE COMMISSION THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION.
AND TAKE AS THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS.
JOINING US TODAY [inaudible]
YES.
I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN HERE FOR THE
LAST. THREE YEARS RIGHT SO WE
KEEP TALKING ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
SO HOPEFULLY WE'RE GOING TO PUT
IT ALL TOGETHER AND NICE PACKAGE
TO TO MOVE FORWARD SO WE'RE
GONNA START WITH OUR CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTED FOR THE STUDENT
COMMISSION.
MISTER DAVID ALBRIGHT.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIRS
AND MEMBERS I'M DAVID O'BRIEN
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT A
COMMISSION.
I WANT TO FIRST THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US TO PARTICIPATE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMISSION.
WHICH SERVES OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA STUDENTS I'M
HONORED TO BE HERE TO DISCUSS --
HOW ARE FINANCIALLY TO SOME CAN
BE REFORMED AND MODERNIZED TO
BEST MEET THE NEEDS OF TODAY'S
STUDENTS --
I DO WANT TO START BY --
ECHOING --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARTES COMMENT
ABOUT --
FINDING.
I CAN TELL YOU FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE THAT IT IS I'VE BEEN
TO MULTI STATE CONFERENCES AND
THANKS TO THE LONG STANDING
COMMITMENT OF LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS SUCH AS YOURSELVES.
CALIFORNIA DOES ENJOY --
WHAT BY ALMOST ANY MEASURE COULD
BE CALLED THE MOST GENEROUS AND
PROGRESSIVE STATE FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY --
IN PARTICULAR BY PROTECTING THE
GUARANTEES OF THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM THROUGH MULTIPLE
ECONOMIC RECESSIONS AND BUDGET
SHORTFALLS.
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS MADE CLEAR
THAT SUPPORTING STUDENTS IS ONE
OF THE STATE'S TOP PRIORITIES.
BUT AS YOU WILL HEAR FROM MYSELF
AND MOST OF THE PANELS HERE
TODAY -- ARE
FINANCIALLY SYSTEM DOES STILL
HAVE QUITE A WAYS TO GO BEFORE
WE CAN MEET THE GOAL OF MAKING A
HIGHER EDUCATION ACCESSIBLE FOR
ALL CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS.
THIS NOVEMBER WORKING FROM THE
REPORT THAT THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION PREPARED ON OUR
BEHALF AND IN RESPONSE TO A
REQUEST FROM THE LEGISLATURE THE
STUDENT A COMMISSION ADOPTED A
SERIES OF FOUR PRINCIPLES THAT
WE HOPE WILL SERVICE GUIDEPOSTS
FOR THIS FINANCIALLY REFORM
DISCUSSION.
IN ADOPTING THESE PRINCIPLES THE
COMMISSION RECOGNIZE THE VARYING
PRIORITIES OF THE DIVERSE GROUP
OF STAKEHOLDERS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM TODAY.
THE HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS IN
INSTITUTIONS RESEARCH AND
ADVOCACY GROUPS SUCH AS THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND
SUCCESS AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
WE HOPE THAT THESE PRINCIPLES
WILL HELP BOTH THE LEGISLATURE
THE ADMINISTRATION AS WE
CONSIDER WHAT A BROAD OVERHAUL
OF OUR FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
COULD LOOK LIKE.
SO THE FIRST PRINCIPLE ARE
COMMISSION ADOPTED WAS TO REMOVE
OR REDUCE ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS
TO THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM.
AS YOU KNOW CAL GRANT IS
AVAILABLE AS AN ENTITLEMENT TO
STUDENTS WHO RECENTLY GRADUATED
FROM HIGH SCHOOL OR WHO TRANSFER
FROM A COMMUNITY COLLEGE BEFORE
TURNING AGE.
TWENTY EIGHT HOWEVER CALIFORNIA
NOW HAS MORE STUDENTS THAN EVER
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS
ATTENDING COLLEGE A LITTLE BIT
LATER IN LIFE.
SIMILARLY WE HAVE A GREAT NUMBER
OF TRANSFER STUDENTS WHO ARE
OLDER THAN TWENTY EIGHT
INCLUDING ADULT LEARNERS LOOKING
TO ACQUIRE NEW SKILLS OR
KNOWLEDGE IN AN EVER CHANGING
ECONOMY. FOR THESE STUDENTS THE
CAL GRANT IS NOT AVAILABLE AS AN
ENTITLEMENT THEY HAVE TO APPLY
FOR ONE OF JUST UNDER TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND AVAILABLE COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT AWARDS.
FROM A POOL OF OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS SO THAT' MORE THAN A
QUARTER OF A MILLION STUDENTS
WHO HAVE SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
NEED.
AND QUALIFY FOR CAL GRANT THAT
AREN'T BEING SERVED BY THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM.
AS PART OF REMOVING BARRIERS TO
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WISH TO CONSIDER
WE CONSIDER THE REQUIREMENT THAT
YOU CAN BE A RECENT HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE IN ORDER TO RECEIVE AN
ENTITLEMENT CAL GRANT.
DOES THIS TIME LIMIT ADEQUATELY
SERVE THE STUDENTS OF TODAY MANY
OF WHOM HAVE VALID REASONS FOR
TAKING A BIT LONGER AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL TO BEGIN COLLEGE.
ON THAT SAME NOTE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER AND I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN LEGISLATION
INTRODUCED UP ON THIS FRONT
RAISING OR REPEALING THE AGE
LIMIT ON THE TRANSFER
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAMS SO THAT
TRANSFER STUDENTS.
CAN RECEIVE AN ENTITLEMENT NO
MATTER THEIR AGE.
THE COMMISSION SECOND GUIDING
PRINCIPLE FOR FINANCIALLY TO
FORM IS AS ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
MCCARTY MEDINA REFERENCED
CONSIDERING THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE STUDENTS FACE.
AS YOU'RE OF COURSE AWARE THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS LARGELY
GEARED TOWARDS HELPING STUDENTS
AFFORD TUITION WHICH IS REALLY
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT COSTS FOR
TYPICAL STUDENT.
JUST TO GIVE.
ONE EXAMPLE THAT'S NOT PURELY
HYPOTHETICAL IN A LITTLE BIT
PARTS OF THE SACRAMENTO STATE
MYSELF BUT FOR A STUDENT
ATTENDING SACRAMENTO STATE THAT
CAN EXPECT TO PAY A LITTLE BIT
OVER SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TUITION AND FEES.
BUT WHEN YOU ADD BOOKS AND
SUPPLIES ROOM AND BOARD
TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER
ESSENTIAL COSTS THE TYPICAL FULL
TIME STUDENT LIVING ON THEIR OWN
GOING TO SACRAMENTO STATE WOLD
SEE A TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE.
EASILY EXCEEDING TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS STUDENTS CAN
RECEIVE CAL GRANT AID TO HELP
WITH THESE NOT TUITION COSTS IN
THE FORM OF OUR CAL GRANT BE
ACCESS AWARD.
WITHOUT A WORD IS LESS THAN
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
YEAR AND HAS NOT KEPT PACE WITH
INFLATION SINCE IT WAS FIRST
ENACTED IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES.
IF IT HAD IT WOULD BE WORTH MORE
THAN SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS TODAY.
SO WHILE THE COMMISSION HAS NOT
ENDORSED A SPECIFIC APPROACH FOR
ADDRESSING THIS PRINCIPLE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER AND
THERE'S BEEN LEGISLATION AGAIN
INTRODUCED ON THIS FRONT AS WELL.
A NEW MODEL FOR THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM THAT SEEKS TO HELP
STUDENTS OF FOR THEIR TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE.
SO THIS MIGHT ENTAIL OVERHAULING
THE PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS TOTAL AID PACKAGE WHICH
INCLUDES FEDERAL AID ANY AMOUNT
THE STUDENTS PARENTS OR FAMILY
CAN CONTRIBUTE AND SOME
REASONABLE EXPECTATION OF EITHER
LOANS ARE WORKING COME ON THE
STUDENTS BEHALF.
IS SUFFICIENT TO A FOR THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE.
THE COMMISSION'S FINAL TO
PRINCIPLES RELATE TO SPECIFIC
COMPONENTS OF THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM THAT A STATE FINANCIAL
AID LEADERS WE ARE PRIORITIZED.
THE FIRST HAS TO DO WITH CAL
GRANTS FOR STUDENTS ATTENDING
PRIVATE NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS
SO PRIVATE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES ARE CRUCIAL TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION ECOSYSTEM AS WE
LIKE TO CALL IT SOMETIMES.
SCHOOLS IN THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES EDUCATE OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS
INCLUDING NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND UNDERGRADUATES EVERY
YEAR.
HOWEVER THESE STUDENTS CAL GRANT
AWARDS ARE NOT LINKED TO TUITION
BUTTER INSTEAD SAID A FLAT RATE
CURRENTLY A LITTLE OVER NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR A
FULL TIME STUDENT.
ON FORTY THIS AWARD HAS NEVER
BEEN INCREASED AND HAS EVEN BEEN
REDUCED ONCE ALREADY --
AND IS THUS LOST A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF ITS VALUE IN RECENT
YEARS MAKING IT EVER MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THE STUDENTS TO A
FOR THEIR EDUCATION. TO ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS ARE ALL SEGMENTS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY THE STUDENT A
COMMISSION HAS ADOPTED THE
PRINCIPLE THAT REFORMING OUR
STATE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM.
SHOULD INCLUDE RESTORING AN
ANNUAL JUST INSTITUTIONS SO THAT
THAT AWARD --
EITHER INCREASES OR AT LEAST NO
NO NO LONGER DECLINED IN VALUE
YEAR OVER YEAR.
FINALLY THE COMMISSION HAS
ENDORSED THE PRINCIPLE THAT
STUDENTS TAKING SUMMER COURSE
WORK SHOULD NOT BE PENALIZED BY
HAVING THEIR CAL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY REDUCED.
ANOTHER ISSUE ON WHICH OUR
STUDENT LEADERS HAVE THAT IN
PARTICULAR --
TAKEN LEAD AND FOR INTRODUCING
LEGISLATION ON THIS FRONT
ALREADY.
CURRENTLY STUDENTS OF YEARS THE
CAL GRANT AWARD DURING THE
SUMMER OR REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
ELIGIBILITY THEY WILL HAVE LATER
ON AND MAY ACTUALLY RUN OUT OF
CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY ENTIRELY
BEFORE THEY'VE COMPLETED THEIR
SENIOR YEAR.
MANY STUDENTS NEED TO TAKE
SUMMER COURSES IN ORDER TO
GRADUATE IN A TIMELY MANNER AND
AVOID HAVING TO COME BACK FOR A
FIFTH OR SIXTH YEAR.
SO THESE ARE THE PRINCIPLES OF
FINANCIAL AID REFORM THE THROUGH
NAY COMMISSION HAS ADOPTED --
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO CLOSE BY
POINTING OUT THAT AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA REFERENCED THE
COMMISSION IS A VERY MUCH AWARE
HOW COMPLEX OUR STATE
FINANCIALLY SYSTEM IS.
AND TO THAT END WE ARE
OPTIMISTIC THAT WORKING WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS --
OUR PARTNERS AND STUDENTS THE
LEGISLATURE THE MINISTRATION CAN
ENACT A COMPREHENSIVE FINANCIAL
AID OVERHAUL BUT SIMPLIFIES AND
STREAMLINES THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM FOR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES WELL SEEKING TO BETTER
DRESS THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE.
SO THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA STUDENT
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO PURSUE
THE DREAM OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR HAVING HERE
TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
BOB SORRY MAN THE SENIOR FELLOW
WITH THE CENTURY FOUNDATION.
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY AT GERMAN
MEDINA MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND SUBCOMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR INVITING THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION TO PRESENT SOLUTIONS
TODAY -- I'M
ROBERT SHERMAN DIRECTOR OF THE
HIGHER EDUCATION PROGRAM AT
CENTURY.
AS MISTER O'BRIEN INDICATED LAST
YEAR FOR USE FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM UNDER CONTRACT FOR THE
STATE NAY COMMISSION WE FOUND A
SYSTEM THAT DOES AN EXCELLENT
JOB COMPARED TO OTHER STATES.
BUT WE ALSO SAW ENORMOUS
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO DO
BETTER.
AFTER OUR SIXTIES CONTRACT ENDED
AS A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTED TO REDUCING INEQUALITY
WE DECIDED TO INDEPENDENTLY
CONSIDER CONTINUE THE WORK THAT
WE HAD BEGUN.
I'D LIKE TO START BY TELLING YOU
ABOUT A NEW STUDY THAT CAME OUT
IN DECEMBER THAT --
IN BEYOND THE TIMELINE OF OUR
OUR REPORT THIS WAS WHAT IS
KNOWN AS A RANDOMIZED TRIAL OR
THE GOLD STANDARD OF OF SOCIAL
SCIENCE RESEARCH THESE TYPES OF
STUDIES.
ARE SO RIGOROUS THAT THEY
FREQUENTLY FIND ONLY SMALL
IMPACTS FROM THE INTERVENTIONS
THAT THEY TEST TEST IF ANY
IMPACTS AT ALL.
THIS RESEARCH THOUGH FOUND VERY
LARGE EFFECTS INDICATING THAT
THE INTERVENTION HAD A LOT OF
POWER TO AFFECT THE BEHAVIOR OF
LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND STUDENTS.
HERE'S WHAT THEY DID.
THE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN SENT
LETTERS TO LOW INCOME HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO ACCORDING TO
THE HIGH SCHOOL RECORDS WOULD
LIKELY QUALIFY FOR ADMISSION BUT
THIS WAS WELL BEFORE THE
TIMELINE FOR ACTUALLY APPLYING.
AS PART OF THIS LETTER THEY TOLD
THE STUDENTS THAT IF THEY WERE
ACCEPTED THEY WOULD BE
GUARANTEED A FULL TUITION
SCHOLARSHIP.
COMPARED TO THE CONTROL GROUP
THESE LOW INCOME STUDENTS WHO
GOT THE TUITION SCHOLARSHIP
MESSAGE WERE MORE THAN TWICE AS
LIKELY TO APPLY TO THE
UNIVERSITY AND TWICE AS LIKELY
TO ENROLL.
THAT IS A VERY LARGE AFFECT FOR
A STUDY LIKE THIS THE KICKER ON
THIS STORY IS THAT THE FINANCIAL
AID FUNDING WAS ACTUALLY NO
DIFFERENT BETWEEN THE TREATMENT
GROUP.
AND THE AND THE CONTROL GROUP
BUT IT WAS FAR MORE EFFECTIVE
FOR THE TREATMENT GROUP LIKELY
FOR TWO REASONS. ONE IS THAT IT
WAS PERSONALIZED IT WAS SPECIFIC
TO THE STUDENT RATHER THAN THE
GENERAL STATEMENTS THAT WE
USUALLY MAKE ABOUT FINANCIAL AID.
ALSO IT WAS VERY GEN IS TOTALLY
COVERED AND PEOPLE WORRY ABOUT
TUITION.
NOW THOSE OF US IN THIS HEARING
KNOW THAT THE COLLEGE COSTS THAT
ARE THE BIGGEST BARRIERS TO
CALIFORNIA'S LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ACTUALLY SUCCEEDING IN COLLEGE
ARE FREQUENTLY NOT JUST THOSE
TUITION COSTS BUT INSTEAD.
OTHER EXPENSES AND WE MUST NOT
LOSE SIGHT OF THAT WHILE WE ALSO
AT THE SAME TIME RECOGNIZE THAT
WE NEED THAT THAT A WAY OF
HOOKING STUDENTS IS TO LET THEM
KNOW THAT THEIR TO THAT TUITION
ITSELF.
IS NOT A PROBLEM.
SO -- THAT
POWERFUL MOTIVATOR FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES IS CRITICAL AND
IT'S THE MOST POWERFUL WHEN IT
IS DELIVERED IN A TARGETED WAY
WHICH IS COMPLETELY CONSISTENT
WITH A NEED BASED SYSTEM THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS.
THAT'S WHY WHAT WE'RE
RECOMMENDING IS EIGHT TUITION
PLUS APPROACH TO REFORMING CAL
GRANTS IT WOULD HAVE TO PARTS
THAT CONTINUE TO BE BASED ON
NEED.
A CAL GRANT TUITION SCHOLARSHIP
AND CAL GRANT PLUS SCHOLARSHIPS.
THE CAL GRANT TUITION
SCHOLARSHIPS WOULD BE LIKE THE
CAL GRANTS WE HAVE NOW BUT WITH
EXPANDED ELIGIBILITY THAT
ELIMINATES THE GPA TIME OUT OF
HIGH SCHOOL AND AGE RESTRICTIONS.
THE PROGRAM SHOULD BE DESIGNED
TO INCORPORATE THOSE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE ELIGIBLE INCLUDING
THOSE WHO ARE GETTING PARTIAL
TUITION COVERAGE AND OF THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION STUDENTS WHO QUALIFY
BASED ON NEED WOULD GET CAL
GRANT PLUS SCHOLARSHIPS TO
ADDRESS REMAINING GAPS AFTER
CONSIDERING A FAMILIES EFC TELL
GRANTS AND A WORK EXPECTATION.
WELL THE TUITION SCHOLARSHIP
PROVIDED BY C. SACK WOULD BE AT
A FIXED LEVEL.
THE CAL GRANT PLUS SCHOLARSHIP
WOULD BE MORE IN THE HANDS OF
THE SEGMENTS AND THE CAMPUSES TO
MAKE FINAL ALLOCATIONS BASED ON
LOCAL AND STUDENTS SPECIFIC
FACTORS.
THE FUND IN FOR THESE
SCHOLARSHIPS WOULD COME FROM A
COMBINATION OF EXISTING
INSTITUTIONAL A DOLLARS AND NEW
STATE PROVIDED RESOURCES.
WE LAY OUT MORE DETAILS ABOUT
THIS OF THIS APPROACH AND THREE
BRIEFS ON OUR WEBSITE AND
ATTACHED TO MY WRITTEN TO MATT
TESTIMONY TODAY.
DISCUSSING HOW TOTAL COSTS
SHOULD BE ESTIMATED HOW THE EFC
CAN BE SET AND HOW FUNDS WOULD
BE ALLOCATED TO COLLEGES AND TO
STUDENTS IN A TUITION PLUS CAL
GRANT SYSTEM.
LAST FALL IN A LETTER TO SEE SEC
CHANCELLOR WHITE AND PRESIDENT A
POLITICIAN NOW IT CSU AND AND UC
LAID OUT AN IMPORTANT SET OF
PRINCIPLES THAT ARE WORTH
CONSIDERING. ONE WAS BUILT ON
SUCCESS AND DO NO FAULT DO NO
HARM WE AGREE WHICH IS WHY OUR
PROPOSALS BUILD ON CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT CAL GRANT SYSTEM.
SECOND MAINTAIN CAL GRANTS CORE
FOCUS ON TUITION COVERAGE WE
AGREE THAT'S THE REASON FAR
RECOMMENDATION FOR A CAL GRANT
TUITION SCHOLARSHIP AND CAL
GRANT PLUS SCHOLARSHIP FOR THE
OTHER EXPENSES.
THIRD EXPAND THE REACH OF CAL
GRANTS ELIMINATING THAT GPA AND
OTHER RESTRICTIONS WOULD
ACCOMPLISH EXACTLY THAT.
SUMMER PAL IS ONE OF THEIR
PRINCIPLES WE PROBABLY AN AREA
THAT DOES MAKE SENSE TO ADDRESS.
AND FIFTH THEY SAID MAINTAIN THE
CAMPUS FOCUS ON THE TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE.
THAT IS A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
GOAL AND WHERE --
BUT IT BUT MORE FUNDING IS
NEEDED TO ACHIEVE THAT
ESPECIALLY AT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND THAT IS THE GOAL OF
THE CAL GRANT PLUS COMPONENT OF
OUR RECOMMENDATION WHICH WOULD
FUND OF THAT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
WHILE MAINTAINING.
THE CAMPUS LEVEL DISCRETION TO
DEPART FROM C. SACK FORMULAS
THAT MIGHT BE ADOPTED AT A
STATEWIDE LEVEL.
WE APPRECIATE HE TIME AND
ATTENTION THAT THE COMMITTEE AND
SUBCOMMITTEE ARE PUTTING INTO
THE ISSUE OF COLLEGE ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I'LL HAVE SOME FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS FOR YOU IN A SEC --
NOW RUNNING GO TO DEBBIE COCHRAN
WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS TO GET.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR MCCARTY
INTERMENT ENOUGH I'M MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I AM SO
APPRECIATIVE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE WITH YOU BUT ALSO FOR
YOUR INTEREST AND DEEP INTEREST
IN THIS TOPIC --
I'M DEBBIE COCHRAN EXECUTIVE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
FOR TO GUESS --
YOU FOR OVER A DECADE ART
ANALYSES HAVE SHOWN THAT DESPITE
DESPITE THE STATE'S FOCUS ON
KEEPING IN TUITION LOW AT PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND HAVING FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAMS.
THAT COULD EASILY COVER TUITION --
THERE ARE REASONS TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT COLLEGE --
FOR WITHOUT BELIEVER IN ALL THE
POINTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE BY
MICHAEL PANELISTS ALREADY --
YOU KNOW BECAUSE THE CALL TOTAL
COSTS OF COLLEGE INCLUDES A
WHOLE RANGE OF COSTS BEYOND
TUITION BOOKS AND SUPPLIES
TEXTBOOKS.
TRANSPORTATION REMEMBER WARD --
BUT OUR AID POLICIES REMAIN
SKEWED TOWARDS TUITION COSTS --
AND THIS IS LEAD TO FAR LESS
SUPPORT FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS AT LOWER TUITION
COLLEGES AND FAR LESS SUPPORT
MEANS PART GREAT GREATER
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES --
ACROSS ALL PUBLIC COLLEGES IN
CALIFORNIA OUR RESEARCH HAS
SHOWN THAT STUDENTS FROM
FAMILIES WITH THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A FAMILY INCOME ARE LAST.
IN HOUSEHOLD INCOME HAVE TO
SPEND ABOUT HALF OR MORE OF
THEIR TOTAL FAMILY INCOME JUST
TO PAY FOR COLLEGE COSTS AFTER
ALL GRANTED IS ALREADY TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT --
THIS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THIS GROUP
THIS THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
FAMILY INCOME UNLESS GROUP.
INCLUDES MORE THAN HALF OF
LATINO STUDENTS THREE AND FIVE
NATIVE AMERICAN STUDENTS AND
NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF BLACK
STUDENTS.
SAID THIS IS THIS IS IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THESE
UNTENABLE COLLEGE COSTS ARE NOT
JUST CONTRIBUTING TO THE STATE'S
COMPLETION CHALLENGES BUT ALSO
THE EQUITY GAPS THAT WE SEE.
IN WHO GETS TO AND THROUGH
COLLEGE AND WE ALSO SEE THAT
AMONGST THOSE WHO DO COMPLETE
IT'S THE LOWER INCOME STUDENTS
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS WHO
ARE MORE LIKELY TO GRADUATE WITH
BURDENSOME AT THE WE SEE THESE
TRENDS.
BECAUSE TOO MANY CALIFORNIANS
ARE BEING LEFT OUT OF STATE.
THAT'S WHY WE AS IN OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE FOR YEARS
SUPPORTED COLLEEN'S CALLS FOR
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF CAL
GRANTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN
INCREASES TO THE CAL GRANT THAT
COVERS NON TUITION COSTS.
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WE'VE
ALSO JOINED THE CALLS TO
ENCOURAGE THE STATE TO THINK
BIGGER I'M BEYOND WHAT LEVEL OF
INCREMENTAL INCREASE THE STATE
CAN MAKE IN ANY GIVEN YEAR.
AND INSTEAD TO FOCUS ON WHAT
STUDENTS NEED.
AT THIS POINT WE FEEL LIKE THERE
IS AN EMERGING CONSENSUS ON WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE I'M EVEN WHILE
DIFFERENCES ON HOW TO GET THERE
REMAIN.
IN BRIEF THAT CONSENSUS IS THAT
THE STATE SHOULD TAKES TO
STUDENTS TOTAL COSTS OF COLLEGE
INTO ACCOUNT RATHER THAN JUST
THEIR TUITION COSTS.
AND EXPECT THAT STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES CAN CONTRIBUTE --
WHAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
REASONABLE GIVEN THEIR OWN
FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES THE REST
WOULD BE COVERED BY FINANCIAL
AID FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID
COLLEGE FINANCIALLY AND STATE
FINANCIAL AID.
ON THIS IS AN APPROACH SUGGESTED
BY T. BECAUSE IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
BY THE LA --
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN BY THE
CENTURY FOUNDATIONS TO NAY
COMMISSION AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AND IT'S REFLECTED IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES PROPOSE FREE
MARKET INTRODUCED BY SENATOR
LEVI.
TWENTY NINETEEN WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS FRAMEWORK SHOULD SERVE AS A
NORTH STAR FOR THE STATE AS IT
FIGURES OUT HOW TO SORT THROUGH
IMPORTANT POLICY QUESTIONS THAT
NEED FURTHER ATTENTION.
SOME OF THE SAME TYPES OF
QUESTIONS THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN
MENTIONED.
I'M IN OCTOBER WE HOSTED A
CONFERENCE TO BEGIN EXPLORING
SOME OF THESE QUESTIONS AND WE
COMMISSION SEVERAL PAPERS
DESIGNED TO MOVE THE
CONVERSATION FORWARD.
WE PUBLISH A COMPENDIUM OF THOSE
PAPERS WHICH YOU SHOULD HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU.
I'M EARLIER THIS MONTH WE KICKED
OFF A WORKING GROUP AIMED AT
BETTER UNDERSTANDING IN
ARTICULATING AREAS OF AGREEMENT
AND DISAGREEMENT ON SOME OF
THESE POLICY DETAILS TO INFORM
THE STATEWIDE DEBATES. TO PRINT
THE INSTANCE IN OUR FIRST
MEETING ARE WE DISCUSSED HOW TO
DEAL WITH WIDELY DIVERGENT
ESTIMATES OF WHAT COLLEGE COSTS
WITHIN A PARTICULAR REGION THINK
TWO SIDE BY SIDE.
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE VERY DIFFERENT
ESTIMATES OF WHAT HOUSING SHOULD
COST FOR INSTANCE AND THERE'S
JUST SOME GENERAL AGREEMENT THAT
GREATER STATE INVOLVEMENT IN
THESE ESTIMATES SETTING INCH
WOULD BE WARRANTED.
I'M WE ALSO I'D HAD DISCUSSED
THE IDEA OF MAKING REACH C. CALC
CALCULATION --
THIS IS THE EXPECTED FAMILY
CONTRIBUTION CALCULATION FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE AID.
I'M WANTED GROUP GENERALLY AGREE
THAT ESE WAS NOT PERFECT AND
THERE WERE SOME REASONS TO
CONSIDER REGIONAL ADJUSTMENTS
THERE WERE ALSO SOME CONCERNS
ABOUT THE COMPLEXITY OF ADDINGA
SECOND STATE SPECIFIC
CALCULATION.
AND A GENERAL RECOGNITION THAT
LOW INCOME STUDENTS WOULD BE
UNLIKELY TO BENEFIT FROM SUCH AN
ADJUSTMENT --
BUT THERE ARE OTHER QUESTIONS
THAT ALSO WEREN'T GREATER
ATTENTION AND THEY'VE GOTTEN TO
DATE AND WE INTEND TO EXPLORE
THEM WITH OUR WORKING GROUP IN
SUBSEQUENT MEETINGS SO SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS ARE --
YOU KNOW ELIMINATING ALL STUDENT
ELIGIBILITY BARRIERS MAY NOT BE
FEASIBLE.
SO WHICH ONES ARE MOST IMPORTANT
TO REDUCE OR ELIMINATE AND HOW
DO WE ORDER THEM.
ARE THEIR REFORMS THAT THE
COLLEGES THEMSELVES NEED TO
PURSUE TO MAXIMIZE THE IMPACT OF
NEW INVESTMENTS.
HOW SHOULD THE STATE BE THINKING
ABOUT PRIVATE COLLEGES WHICH AS
MISTER BRIAN MENTIONED ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION
LANDSCAPE BUT DON'T NECESSARILY
FIT WELL INTO A TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE MODEL?
ALSO HOW SHOULD LARGE SCALE
REFORMS BE PHASED IN TO ENSURE
THAT THEIR OPERATIONALLY
FEASIBLE AND THAT THE MOST
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS ARE
PRIORITIZE AT EACH STEP.
WE SEE THAT THESE IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS THAT WARRANT SOME
FOCUS.
AND YET IT'S ALSO TRUE THAT THE
STATE CANNOT WAIT UNTIL ALL THE
WE HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS --
TO ACT.
CURRENTLY FEWER THAN HALF OF
STUDENTS TO APPLY FOR CAL GRANTS
AND MEET THE ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA RECEIVE GRANTS AND MOST
WHO ARE TURNED AWAY HAVEN'T EFC
AND EXPECTED FAMILY CONTRIBUTION
OF ZERO EVEN THOSE HE GETS
GRANTS COVER JUST STRUGGLE TO
COVER THEIR COSTS.
I'M IN THAT LETTER FROM YOU SEE
PRESENT ALL THE TIME AND CSU
CHANCELLOR.
WHITE THAT MISTER SIMON
REFERENCED --
THOSE LEADERS POINTED TO THE
NEED HOW GRANT ELIGIBILITY BEARS
AN INCREASE THE CAL GRANT BE
ACCESS AWARD IN THOSE ARE IN
LINE WITH RECOMMENDATIONS WE'VE
MADE.
THE CALIFORNIANS FOR CALL OF
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY OF MADE
AND THE CALIFORNIA HIGHER
EDUCATION BASIC NEEDS ALLIANCE
HAVE MADE.
MAKING A SIZEABLE DOWN PAYMENT
TOWARDS THESE ENDS THIS YEAR
WITH THE TIMELINE FOR ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN FUTURE YEARS.
IS THE LEAST OF THE STATE CAN
DEAR WHAT TO CAPITALIZE ON THE
MOMENTUM AND RELATIVE CONSENSUS
ON A POLICY ISSUE.
THAT'S SO CRITICAL TO THE
STATE'S FUTURE.
NOT BROADER REFORM IS ABSOLUTELY
WARRANTED --
BUT AT A TIME WHEN THERE'S SO
MUCH AGREEMENT ON WHAT OUR NORTH
STAR SHOULD BE THE WORST OUTCOME
AT THIS POINT WOULD BE FOR THE
STATE TO FAIL TO MAKE PROGRESS
TOWARDS IT.
BECAUSE WE SPENT SO MUCH TIME
STUDYING THE ROADMAP.
SO WHETHER THROUGH BROADENING
THE REGION SCOPE OF CAL GRANTS
UNDER THE PROGRAM'S CURRENT
STRUCTURE OR SORTING OUT THE
DETAILS OF WHAT A NEW STRUCTURE
COULD LOOK LIKE THE STATE CANNOT
AFFORD TO WAIT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU --
NOW ENTERTAIN QUESTIONS I DID
WANT TO RECOGNIZE OUR DOUBLE
COMMITTEE HERE FROM THE HIRED
COMMITTEE WE HAVE SOMEONE
MEMBERS.
GABRIEL --
DOCTOR CHOICE MEMBER BLOOM AND
MISTER LEVINE AND THEN FROM OUR
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS MARTUCCI Là MON
AND GALLAGHER SO WELCOME
EVERYBODY THIS MORNING --
QUESTIONS FOR THIS PANEL.
ALL START OUT THEN.
YEAH.
I WANT TO JUST YOU YOU ALL KIND
OF PLENTY OF REMEDIES THAT WE
COULD FOCUS ON THE GAPS OF
STUDENTS TONIGHT I THINK THIS IS
AMAZING JUST TO POINT OUT AGAIN.
THE PEOPLE GET LOST TO FIND A WE
DO HAVE THIS AMAZING CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
WE DO HAVE --
THESE ELIGIBILITY LIMITS AND SO
YOU COULD BE A STUDENT WHO MAKES
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
YOUR FAMILY AND HAS A GPA.
OF TWO POINT NINE AND YOU WOULD
GET NO CAL GRANT AID FOR YOU CAN
MAKE A THOUSAND DOLLARS LESS
THAN A GPA OF TWO POINT.
FOUR AND GET THAT THEY KEPT THE
CAL GRANT BE AWARD AND SO WE
JUST HAVE THIS.
WITH THE CALL THE DONUT HOLE
WHATEVER THESE THESE GAPS OF
PEOPLE ARE JUST MISSING OUT --
THEN WE HAVE STUDENTS WHO
GRADUATE JUST A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF DEBT.
AND WE HAVE CITIES DON'T GET ON
ALL BECAUSE THE COMPETITIVE
PIECES SO I GUESS MY POINT IS AS
WE HAVE ALL OF THESE.
PIECES THAT WE CAN TACKLE WE
JUST WE WE HAVE A NICE ROAD MAP.
BUT I THINK IT'S UP TO US TO OUR
BUDGET COMMITTEE PROCESS IS
SOMEWHAT PRIORITIZE.
AND SO WE DON'T HAVE UNLIMITED
RESOURCES.
MAYBE ASK THE PANEL WHAT DO YOU
THINK ARE THE MOST --
APPROPRIATE PLACES TO START NOT
JUST THE LOW HANGING FRUIT AS
FAR AS COST.
BUT YOU KNOW ANY OF THE GLASS --
PROBLEMS THAT WE SHOULD BE
ADDRESSING RIGHT AWAY.
SO WHOEVER WANTS TO BEGIN.
I'M OF START THANK YOU --
FOR STARTING OUT WITH AN EASY
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CHRISSY ABOUT --
ONE FROM THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSIONS PERSPECTIVE I THINK
THAT IF THE STATE WERE TO START
OUT BY PUTTING WILL --
WHAT I BELIEVE THE
ADMINISTRATION IT'S BECAUSE LIKE
TO CALL A DOWN PAYMENT?
ON SOME SORT OF OVER ARCHING
FINANCIALLY --
FORM I THINK.
IT WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO FIND A
BALANCE BETWEEN.
SORT OF THE WHAT WE INTERNALLY
CALL THE DEPTH VERSES BREATH
CONVERSATION OR YOU KNOW MAY
BOTH ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THERE
ARE.
A LOT OF STUDENTS THAT ARE LEFT
OUT OF THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE DON'T GET ANY COVER
AND IT ALL BECAUSE THE
ELIGIBILITY BEARS THAT ARE IN
PLACE.
BUT ALSO THAT THERE ARE QUITE A
LOT OF STUDENTS IN THE PROGRAM
THAT DON'T GET ENOUGH AID
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH THE CAL
GRANT BE ACCESS WERE NOT HAVING
GONE UP --
OR YOU KNOW OR OTHER PLACES LIKE
THE THE SO SO CALLED DOUGHNUT
HOLE THAT YOU MENTIONED.
SO I THINK THAT FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WITHOUT SORT OF
SAYING ONE POLICY ONE BILLS
BETTER THAN THE OTHER I THINK.
WE WOULD JUST --
TO LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO CONSIDER THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF STUDENTS IN BOTH GROUPS IT'S
IT'S WE WOULD SAY IT'S PROBABLY
NOT ENOUGH TO JUST EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY AND GET MORE
STUDENTS IN THE PROGRAM.
BUT IT'S ALSO NOT ENOUGH TO JUST
INCREASE THE OUR PROGRAM BECAUSE
THAT STILL IS A LOT OF STUDENTS
LEFT OUT SO SOME TYPE OF
BALANCED APPROACH IN THAT COULD
BE -- IT'S
NOT A SYSTEMIC REFORM THAT COULD
BE FOR EXAMPLE INCREASING THE
NUMBER OF COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT
AWARDS WHILE ALSO INCREASING THE
CAL GRANT.
BE ACCESS AWARD.
THAT WOULD BE ONE APPROACH THAT
WOULD BOTH DO BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS AT ONCE BUT THAT DOESN'T
GET TO THE SYSTEMIC ISSUES OF
THE HEART THE PROGRAM THAT YOU
REFERENCE AND THAT THE OTHER
PAYMENTS OF REFERENCE SO --
THAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT --
YOU KNOW I THINK THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY NEEDS TO BE HEALTHY
MORE STUDENTS GET FINANCIAL AID --
YOU KNOW I THINK THERE'S A BUT
THERE IS AN IMPORTANT MESSAGE
THAT COMES ALONG SIDE OF THAT
RECEIPT OF A GRANT AND WE CAN DO
MORE TO CAPITALIZE ON THE
MESSAGE THAT WE THAT WE SEND
WHEN WE SEND A STUDENT AWARD
LETTER SAYING THAT THEY GET A
CAL GRANT.
IN FACT SOME OF THE PAPERS --
IN THE COMPENDIUM THAT I SHARED
WITH YOU --
TALK ABOUT WAYS THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE THE COMMUNICATIONS OF
CAL GRANT AND I THINK THERE'S
REALLY THERE'S REAL GAINS WE
COULD BE MAKING BY THINKING
ABOUT THAT AND THE UNIVERSITY OF
MICHIGAN REFERENCE.
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN --
RESEARCH EMPHASIZES THAT --
SO I THINK THAT THAT IS I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT THE MESSAGING
PEACE BUT IT ALSO WE HAVE TO GET
MORE STUDENTS INTO THE DOOR --
WE HAVE TO GET TWO MORE STUDENTS
INTO THE DOOR WITH FINANCIAL AID --
THERE ARE SO MANY STUDENTS --
AT THE PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS AS
WELL AS NONPROFIT THAT ARE BEING
LEFT OUT CURRENTLY --
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
YOU KNOW WHICH RECEIVE A VERY OF
CAL GRANT SPENDING DESPITE AND
ROLLING THE VAST MAJORITY OF
UNDERGRADUATES IN THE STATE --
THERE'S ACTUALLY ADDITIONAL
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE AS ADD ONS TO THE CAL
GRANT RIGHT THERE'S THAT THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FUNDED
PROGRAMS THERE.
AND SO THE MORE STUDENTS WE
ACTUALLY GET IN THE DOOR WITH
CAL GRANTS.
THE MORE OPPORTUNITY THEY HAVE
TO ALSO LEVERAGE THAT OTHER
FINANCIAL AID SO I WOULD SAY
THAT HAS TO BE A KEY PRIORITY
BUT I WOULD ALSO ECHO THE
COMMENTS ABOUT THE CAL GRANT THE
AXIS AWARD --
NEEDING TO INCREASE AS WELL.
DO YOU HAVE A THOUGHTLESSNESS
RETIREMENT SURE.
ODD SO I I'VE BIRD WATCHING THIS
PROCESS AND BEING A PART OF THE
LAST OF IT FOR THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS I SEE KIND OF A MAYBE
IT'S SORT OF A CHICKEN AND EGG
KIND OF PROBLEM WHERE.
WE CAN IMAGINE THESE GRAND
REFORMS BUT THEY COST A LOT OF
MONEY SO WE DON'T DO ANYTHING
IMMEDIATELY --
YET THE THING WE CAN DO
IMMEDIATELY IS IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS PUTTING MORE MONEY INTO
SOMETHING SO.
I LIKE THE DIRECTION THAT THE
COMMITTEES ARE GOING WHERE THE
IDEA OF KIND OF LAYING OUT WHAT
ARE ALL OF THE THINGS WE WANT TO
DO OVER A FOUR YEAR FIVE YEAR
PERIOD --
AND THEN IDENTIFYING THE STEPS
TO GET THERE NOW FORTUNATELY WE
HAVE.
A GENERALLY GOOD STRUCTURE RIGHT
NOW BUT WITH A LOT OF GAPS SO --
BEGINNING TO FILL ONE WITH SOME
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS COMPLETELY
CONSISTENT WITH A LONG TERM --
LARGER REFORM PLAN AND LAYING
OUT THAT LONGER PLAN CAN MAKE IT
CLEARER WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN NEXT
YEAR AND THE YEAR AFTER THAT I
THINK -- IS
COCHRAN'S IDEA OF MORE MONEY IN
THE COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM
JUST GETTING MORE STUDENTS --
FUNDED --
WOULD BE AT UP THE GREAT WAY TO
A GREAT WAY TO START --
YOU COULD ALSO LOOK AT HOW MUCH
RESOURCES CAN WE AFFORD THIS
YEAR TO ADD INTO THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM AND WHICH OF THE
BARRIERS DOES THAT MAKE FOR A
GOOD FIT.
YOU KNOW IS THAT THE GPA IS THAT
THE AGES IT TIME OUT OF SCHOOL
IS IT SOMETHING ELSE --
SO I GET IT I I COULD SEE EITHER
WAY BUT BUT EITHER WAY IT WOULD
SEND IT WOULD.
BE A START TOWARD FILLING THE
GAPS OVERTIME AND ENDING UP WITH
A DEBT FREE COLLEGE SYSTEM.
SO A FOLLOW UP ON THAT I THINK I
ASK MISS COCHRAN THIS QUESTION
LAST YEAR AND AND YOU DIDN'T
LIKE IT SO.
LAST YEAR AGAIN SO THEN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HE HAS ABOUT A
HUNDRED MILLION --
TO EXPAND CAL GRANT A DIFFERENT
IDEA THAT WE HAD BUT STILL NOT
NOT A BAD ONE TO HELP BEING.
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO ARE PARENTS
AND DOING A ADD ON TO THEIR CAL
GRANT PLUS HOW YOU CALL IT --
IT SO IT IF IT GETS KIND THE
ADAGE THAT YOU WOULD YOU RATHER
HAVE MORE PEOPLE GETTING INTO
COLLEGE GETTING SOME EIGHT OR
HAVING.
THOSE WHERE THEIR GRADUATE WITH
LESS DEBT SO IF YOU HAD A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SUITCASE
RIGHT HERE WOULD YOU RATHER HELP
OUR CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS WITH
THE WITH THE THE PLUS.
WITHOUT YOU CALLED YEAH CAL
GRANT PLOW GRANT PLUS OR GIVE
MORE AWARDS TO THE PEOPLE IN THE
DOUGHNUT HOLE OR THE COMPETITIVE
WHO WHO ARE.
GETTING A CHANCE RIGHT NOW.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO?
IF WE HAD A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS -- I
ASSUME I'M NOT ALLOWED TO SPLIT
THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS LIKE.
FIFTY FIFTY OKAY I THINK I WOULD
PROBABLY DO SOME SORT OF
COMBINATION BUT I WOULD HAVE TO
SAY IN TERMS OF THAT --
YOU KNOW WHEN WE LOOK AT WHERE
STUDENTS ARE BEING LEFT BEHIND
AND WHERE SOME OF THE GREATEST
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES OUR OUR
RESEARCH CONSISTENTLY POINTS
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IS NOT TO SAY THAT THOSE ARE THE
ONLY PROBLEMS BUT WE SEE
SUBSTANTIAL PROBLEMS THERE AND I
DO THINK THAT.
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDED FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN A BIT OF A GAME
CHANGER IN TERMS OF THAT
EQUATION --
RIGHT NOW STUDENTS WHO ARE
ENROLLED IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES GETTING THE CAL GRANT
AND YOU WERE TAKING FIFTEEN
CREDITS A TERM.
CAN GET QUITE A SIZEABLE BOOST
IN THEIR CAL GRANT AWARD --
THAT'S GREAT BUT THAT'S YOUR ONE
OR 2% OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS THE WAY WE NEED TO WE
E CAN HELP MORE STUDENTS AS BY
GETTING MORE OF THEM CAL GRANTS.
I'M IN LARGE IN THE BASE THAT
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE GRAMS AND THEN
WE WILL HELP MORE STUDENTS THAT
WAY A CHEF AND LAST BEFORE I
MOVE ON TO MISTER MEDINA.
ON ON THE IN THE AGENDA THINGS
ON PAGE FIVE WERE.
WE LAY OUT ALL OF THE FINANCIAL
AID AND IT'S NOT INSIGNIFICANCE
TEN BILLION DOLLARS GOES OUT. TO
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA EVERY
YEAR.
RENDON ENOUGH. 40% OURSELVES
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE
PELL GRANT.
WE DON'T ALWAYS TALK ABOUT THE
UC AND CSU COMPONENTS AND THAT I
ASSUME IS THAT THAT THAT TUITION
THE THIRD THAT GOES BACK. TO
RETURN TO AID.
AND IT'S THEIR MONEY THEY THEY
ADMINISTERED IT SEPARATE FROM
OUR CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM THE TWO BILLION DOLLAR.
PLUS PROGRAM AN ESTIMATE
COMMISSION --
SHOULD WE BE THINKING OF THAT
DIFFERENTLY AS IN PUT IT
AGGREGATE ALL TOGETHER.
ARE WE DOING THE ****
COORDINATED I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
YOU SEE IS LIKE THE MODEL WHERE
THEY THEY PACKAGE MONEY AND SOME
OF THE MONEY A PACKAGE IS
STUDENTS CAL GRANT MONEY BUT
THAT MONEY TOO SO.
I KNOW I'M NOT SURE IF WE'RE
ALWAYS THINKING ABOUT THAT IN
THE BIG PICTURE WHAT HE SAID.
I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
COORDINATION BETWEEN THE FUNDING
THAT CAL GRANT FUNDING AND THE
THE INSTITUTIONAL AID THAT COME
FROM AND AND YOU COULD EVEN
THINK ABOUT THAT IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
INCREASE --
THAT IF THE GOVERNOR'S FUNDS FOR
STUDENTS PARENTS WHERE SOME OF
THOSE STUDENTS THOSE STUDENT
PARENTS AT UC AND CSU.
ARE.
ARE ARE OR WOULD BE CURRENTLY
ELIGIBLE FOR SOME OF THE
INSTITUTIONAL AID THAT THE
INSTITUTIONS ARE PROVIDING AND
SO IN A WAY THE LEGISLATURE IS
WE'RE LEAVING.
THE UNIVERSITIES OF SOME OF THAT
BURDEN AND THAT CAN START THE
CONVERSATION --
HOW DO WE DO A BETTER JOB OF
SHARING DATA ABOUT WHERE THE
NEEDS ARE AND HOW THEY ARE
GETTING COVERED ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER --
AND AND THAT'S THE KIND OF
PARTNERSHIP WE WE NEED BETWEEN
SAID NAY COMMISSION AND THE
SYSTEMS SO THAT WERE THINKING.
FULL COST OF ATTENDANCE AND ALSO
ALL STUDENTS --
RATHER THAN AS KIND OF A LOW A
LEVEL OF BLINDNESS NIGHT RIGHT
NOW THAT THIS DID NAY COMMISSION
HAS WHERE THEY FOR THE CAL GRANT
MONEY OVER THERE FOR REALLY GOOD
PURPOSES AND AND STUDENTS WHO.
NEED IT BUT BUT THEN WHAT'S WHAT
ELSE IS HAPPENING IS.
A LOT OF IT IS AN UNKNOWN.
DO YOU THINK IT SHOULD ALL BE
UNDER ONE UMBRELLA I DON'T I
KNOW THE UC AND CSU PROBABLY
WOULDN'T LIKE IT.
TO TAKE TO GET RID OF THAT MONEY
BUT IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SIMPLIFYING IT AND MODERNIZING
AND HAVING.
YOU KNOW ONE PORTAL THAT LOOKS
AT THE STUDENT THE NEED THE
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION IT SEEMS
SOMEONE ANY FISH AND THAT
THERE'S THERE THAT PEOPLE HAVE
TO GO TO DIFFERENT PLACES TO
FIGURE IT OUT I THINK WE NEED A
SYSTEM WHERE THE INSTEAD NAY
COMMISSION AND THE CAMPUS.
CLOSE ENOUGH FOR NATION THAT
FROM THE STUDENTS PERSPECTIVE
THEY CAN GET --
THEY CAN GET THAT SIMPLIFIED
INFORMATION BUT ESPECIALLY WITH
WHEN IT RICK WHEN IT COMES TO
THE BROADER COST OF ATTENDANCE
WE HAVE FOUND THAT THERE ARE
LOCALIZED.
ISSUES THAT WHERE IT DOES MAKE
SENSE FOR THE SEGMENTS OF THE
CAMPUSES TO HAVE SOME DISCRETION
OVER EXACTLY HOW TO HOW TO
ALLOCATE FUNDS --
AND USUALLY THOSE HAPPEN FAIRLY.
LATE IN THE PROCESS ONCE
DECISIONS AT ONCE THAT STUDENT
IS ACTUALLY MADE A DECISION OF
WHICH CAN'T WHAT CAMPUS I'M
GOING TO WHAT IS MY LIVING
SITUATION.
THEY'RE GONNA BE SITUATIONS
WHERE SOMEBODY HAVING MORE
EXPENSIVE HOUSING --
MAKES SENSE AND THEY'RE GONNA BE
SITUATIONS WHERE MAYBE THAT'S
NOT GOOD MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T BE
INCENTIVIZING THAT AND THAT'S
GOING TO BE A LOCALIZED SORT OF
THING THAT THAT NEEDS TO BE
ACCOUNTED FOR ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA.
THANK YOU --
HANDLE ON THE DEPTH VERSES
BREATH RIGHT DO WE GIVE MORE.
MORE CAL GRANTS TO MORE
INDIVIDUALS OR DO WE GIVE MORE
MONEY TO A SMALLER GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS AND BOTH HAVE COST.
AND AS WE LOOK TO TO READ --
ELIMINATING THE BARRIERS AGE
BARRIER THAT WE ELIMINATE ALSO
HAS COSTS.
AND SO IT IS UP TO I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY MYSELF AS WE WORK ON THE
BILL [inaudible] TO TO THINK
ABOUT HOW.
RIGHT OR WHICH BARRIERS ARE ARE
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT I THINK
THAT'S THE QUESTION --
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY TO
TRIED TO HELP THOSE PRIORITIZE.
I AYE I HEARD ONE SUGGESTION OF
THE LIMóN EIGHTEEN GPA --
WAS AT A SUGGESTION THAT GPA --
NOT BE --
CONSIDER AT ALL AND RIGHT
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THE IT'S KIND
OF COMPLEX.
RIGHT WHICH ONES [inaudible]
YOU.
QUALIFY FOR SO WAS A SUGGESTION
NOT TO CONSIDER GPA AT ALL --
IT SO FOR AT LEAST FOR THE
PUBLIC SEGMENTS THAT THE TO GET
SOMEBODY WHO GETS INTO UNIT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS --
MILEY ACADEMIC QUALIFY
ACADEMICALLY QUALIFIED AND SO TO
QUIBBLE OVER AT A TWO POINT NINE
VERSUS THREE POINT OH IN THE
QUESTION OF THE DAY TAKING AP
CLASSES AND ALL OF THAT IS NOT
REALLY --
NECESSARY CSU IS SIMILAR --
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE MORE --
BUT ENCOURAGING STUDENTS FROM
WHATEVER BACKGROUND AND YET
THERE'S A LOT OF STUDENTS A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE YOU ARE FIVE
YEARS TEN YEARS FIFTEEN YEARS
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL --
AND ARE MAKING A GO OF IT.
AND GIVING THEM A CLEAR ROUTE
FOR DOING SO --
AT THE START WITH A STRONG
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE IS MOST
LIKELY TO GET THEM TO THE FINISH
LINE ULTIMATELY SO IF YOU'RE
GOING TO BE TOUGH.
ON ON A KIND OF GPA I WOULD DO
IT AFTER THAT FIRST YEAR I WOULD
SAY YES YOU GET FINANCIAL AID IN
ROLE GO FULL TIME MAKE A GO OF
IT -- BUT IF
IF FROM A BUDGET STANDPOINT WERE
ALL WERE WORRIED OR FROM A
BI<c.cyan> STANDPOINT WERE WORRIED</c>
ABOUT PEOPLE SOMEHOW TAKING
ADVANTAGE OR SOMETHING THEN I'D
SAY GET TOUGH.
FOR STRONGLY ENCOURAGED GET GET
THINGS OUT OF THE WAY YOU KNOW
GET GET OUT OF THE WAY THE WHOLE
CONCEPT OF GOSH ALL HAVE.
TO MY HIGH SCHOOL WASN'T THAT
GOOD -- GET
THAT OUT OF THE WAY COMPLETELY.
AND IF YOU NEED TO GET TOUGH GET
TOUGHER.
AFTER THE FIRST SEMESTER AFTER
THE FIRST YEAR THROUGH IT WOULD.
CREATE A A SIMPLER.
ABSOLUTELY SIMPLE ARE AND IT
WOULD ELIMINATE THE ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF BACK AND FORTH RIGHT
NOW -- WITH
BETWEEN --
HIGH SCHOOLS AND THIS TO NAY
COMMISSION TRYING TO GPA RECORDS
AND EVERYTHING WHICH ALL OF THAT
STAFF TIME COULD BE USED --
ACTUALLY HELPING STUDENTS FIGURE
OUT THERE --
THE FINANCIAL AID WHERE THEY
COULD APPLY WHERE THEY COULD GO
TO COLLEGE AND PUT SOMETHING IN
LIKE YOU HAVE TO MAINTAIN A
CERTAIN GPA TO MAINTAIN YOUR
RIGHT NOT CHATTED ASKED WHICH
MOST COLLEGES HALF SO JUST BE A
MATTER OF MONITORING THAT AND
MAYBE PUTTING SOME MINIMUMS
THEIR THANK [inaudible]
YOU.
YEAH ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMA.
THANK YOU AND JUST TO FOLLOW UP
ON THAT I THINK AND THERE'S
ALWAYS THE THOUGH OF THE HARD.
DECISION MAKING THAT INVOLVES
WHAT WE WOULD IDEALLY LIKE TO
SEE VERSUS WHAT WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO DO --
AND CERTAINLY IT'S A POSITIVE
YEAR WHEN THERE'S AN INCREASE
BUT AS MAY BE PROJECTED IN THE
COMING YEARS THAT INCREASE WON'T.
MAY NOT BE THERE IF THE ECONOMY
DOESN'T A SUSTAIN ITSELF SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA JUST
TOUCHED ON THE GRADE ASPECT OF
IT.
OF ALL OF THE SUGGESTIONS YOU'VE
PROVIDED --
AGAIN CONSIDERING THAT SOME OUR
CAPACITY ISSUES AND WHICH WHICH
ACTUALLY YIELD THE GREATEST
OUTCOMES.
AND WHAT ARE THE GREATEST
OUTCOME ARE THEY TIME TO DEGREE
OR THE COMPLETION [inaudible]
QUESTION.
I THINK IT MIGHT DEPEND ON THE
SIZE OF THE INVESTMENT --
I GUESS THAT'S WHAT I WOULD HAVE
TO SAY IS CERTAINLY THE RESEARCH
IS PRETTY AS CLEAR THAT --
FINANCIAL AID DOES SUPPORT
STUDENTS AND ENROLLING IN
COLLEGE COMPLETING COLLEGE AND
SUPPORTING THEIR ABILITY TO TAKE
MORE.
COURSES PER TERM WHICH SPEAK AND
SO I'M.
I THINK IT'S IT'S HARD TO KNOW --
YOU KNOW EXACTLY HOW MUCH HOW
MUCH WE'RE TALKING MY OPPOSE A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
HUNDRED TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IT MIGHT BE A
BIT DIFFERENT ANSWER.
PICK ONE AND TELL ME THE ANSWER.
AT THE END IS TRYING TO GET A
SENSE OF WHERE I MEAN.
IF THE IF THE DECISIONS HAVE TO
BE MADE I I DON'T I'M NOT CLEAR
ON WHAT THE RECOMMENDATION IS --
AND WHAT'S THE PRIORITY IS IS IT
YOU KNOW TIME TO DEGREE IS A
COMPLETION --
WE JUST THERE WERE THERE WAS A
SUGGESTION MADE ABOUT NOT
CONSIDERING GPA IN THE FIRST
SEMESTER QUARTER BUT CONSIDERING
IT THERE AFTER --
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT OF ALL OF THE SUGGESTIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED THE
LAST HOUR OR SO.
WHICH IS GOING TO YIELD THE
GREATER OUTCOME AND I AND YOU
CAN PICK WHATEVER OUTCOME YOU
WANT I'M JUST I WANT TO KNOW
WHICH WOULD YIELD MOST TO
ACHIEVE A CERTAIN OUTCOME.
WHAT? ONE THING ARE.
BUT AT THE TIME TO THINK ABOUT
IS THAT.
DEPENDING ON HOW THE PROGRAM IS
STRUCTURED THE COULD BE A STATE
GOLD LINKED TO THAT SO FOR
EXAMPLE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
REFERENCE TO THE IDEA OF A DEBT
FREE COLLEGE GRANT PROGRAM AND
PRESUMABLY THE GOAL IS TO CREATE
A SYSTEM WHERE STUDENTS DON'T
HAVE TO RELY ON DEBT WHERE.
IF THEY CAN WORK A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OR IF THEY OR THEIR
FAMILY ARE CAPABLE OF PUTTING A
CERTAIN REASON WHAT FURTHER
EDUCATION.
THE YOU KNOW DEBT WOULD BE AN
ABSOLUTE LACK STUDENT RIGHT SO
THE MODEL THAT THE LA --
RECOMMENDED THAT THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION RECOMMENDED IN THE
REPORT --
AND THAT IS VERY SIMILAR TO THE
MODEL THAT YOU SEE USES IN THEIR
EDUCATION FINANCE MODEL --
THAT YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT
ESSENTIALLY SAYS IT PUTS A CAP
ON THE STUDENTS EXPECTED
CONTRIBUTION.
RIGHT SO RIGHT NOW --
ARE FINANCIALLY BONTA PUTS A CAP
ON THE AMOUNT OF A TO GET SO IT
DOESN'T MATTER HOW MUCH YOUR
COST OF ATTENDANCE AS YOUR CAL
GRANT IS CAPPED AT TAX DOLLARS
DEPENDING ON SEGMENT.
THE COST OF ATTENDANCE SORT OF
DEBT FREE MODEL PUTS A CAP ON
HOW MUCH THE STUDENT HAS TO PAY
OUT OF POCKET AND THEREFORE SAYS
IF YOU CAN BRING THIS AMOUNT TO
THE TABLE THE REST OF YOUR COSTS
OF TOWNS WILL BE COVERED.
WHATEVER IT IS FROM FEDERAL
STATE INSTITUTIONAL AID AND THEN
NOT MODEL WITH THE GOAL IS.
TO REDUCE STUDENT DEBT BY
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT PARTICULARLY
FOR LOW INCOME STUDENTS I THINK
BUT THINK THERE BE MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES THERE --
AND ESPECIALLY IF THE GOAL IS TO
MAKE IT SO THE STUDENTS HAVE TO
RELY ON DEATH SO THAT A STUDENT
WHO IS ABLE TO FIND SOME
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF WORK HOURS
OR HAD SOME FAMILY INCOME THEY
CAN RELY ON DEBT IS NOT
SOMETHING IN THE OF THE FIRST.
YOU KNOW FIRST DAY THINKING ALL
RIGHT I'M GOING TO COLLABORATION
WITH THE CAL STATE TO
DISSOCIATION LOOKING AT CSU
GRADUATES AND THEIR STUDENT AT
LEVELS.
AND WANT ONE OF THE STARKEST
MOUNTAINS AT FINDINGS THAT WE
HAD WAS THAT EIGHT IN TEN CSU
GRADS HAD FAMILY INCOMES UNDER
ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS --
SO IT IS THAT THAT IS VERY
CLEARLY BEING DISPROPORTIONATELY
HELD BY LOWER INCOME FAMILIES
AND STUDENTS --
THAT SIMILAR TRENDS --
WE SEE FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE DOING A
SIMILAR ANALYSIS WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION --
THAT'S FORTHCOMING OF NEXT MONTH
SO I THINK I WOULD ALSO SAY I
THINK IF YOU WANT IF THE GOALS
COMPLETIO.
I WOULD PUT THE MONEY INTO MORE
GRANTS FOR MORE STUDENTS AND I
THINK IF THE GOAL IS REDUCING
DEBT.
I WOULD PUT IN TO INCREASE THE
COVERAGE ACCESS A WORD
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIVING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
TO THE PANELISTS AND THE I
APOLOGIZE THE NEXT TWO PANELS
BECAUSE I'M NOT GOING TO BE ABLE --
TO REMAIN AND MY QUESTIONS ARE
AS MUCH TO THEM AS THEY ARE TO
USE TO THIS PANEL --
WHERE YOU'VE BEEN DESCRIPTIVE
ABOUT THE ABILITY FOR SEGMENTS
TO BE CREATIVE OR WHAT WHAT
BINDS THEM --
IN THEIR CREATIVITY BUT OF
COURSE ACCESS TO RESOURCES IS
ONE OF THEM --
BUT ALSO WHERE WE EMPHASIZE --
THE THE IMPORTANCE OF WHERE
PEOPLE GET GET AN EDUCATION AND
SO -- AS
MUCH FOR YOU IS AS THOSE WHO ARE
PAYING ATTENTION I STUDIED AT
CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE BUT I WOULD
NEVER HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GRADUATE
IN A TIMELY MANNER WITHOUT.
GOING TO TWO DIFFERENT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OR A PROFESSOR WHO LET
ME TAKE A COURSE DURING THE
SUMMER BUT REGISTER FOR IT IN
THE FALL.
SO WOULD HAVE TO PAY EXORBITANT
SUMMER FEES AND DROP IT INTO MY
FULL TIME COURSE LOAD IN IN THE
FALL AND SHE DIDN'T BAT AN
EYELASH WHEN SHE SAID ABSOLUTELY
NOT A PROBLEM.
AND SO THERE'S THERE'S A LOT OF
CREATIVITY AT EACH AND TO BE
ABLE TO GRADUATE IN --
IN A WAY THAT SIDE.
MINDFUL OF THE RESOURCE THAT WE
ALL HAVE TO PUT TO IT.
SO WHAT WHAT'S THAT LOS LEFT TO
ME WHEN I REVIEW ALL OF THE
FUNDS AND AND YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
WE'RE WE'RE PUTTING TOWARDS
DIFFERENT SEGMENTS IS THAT.
AT AND INVESTED IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IS EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT AND IT'S A HUGE
LIMITATION ON PEOPLE AND I THINK
THAT NOT ONLY DO WE MISS OUT ON
THAT BECAUSE OF THE AID THAT WE
APPLY TO IT.
BUT ALSO BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
EMPHASIS THAT THIS IS GOING TO
BE A PLACE WHERE YOU CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL AND EIGHT IS A IS A
CONDUIT TO THAT SUCCESS FOR SO
MANY STUDENTS.
TO HAVE SO MANY DIFFERENT
RESPONSIBILITIES --
D. V..
WE WE GOT HURT A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT SOME OF WHAT YOU SEE IS
DOING AND CAPPING HOW MUCH IS
STUDENTS CONTRIBUTION SUPPOSED
TO BE.
AND SO THE QUESTION WITH ALL OF
THAT LEADING UP TO IT IS WHETHER
OR NOT THERE ARE TWO TYPES OF
SEGMENTS IN OTHER SCHOOLS
WHETHER IT'S THE THREE SECONDS
OF PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA OR THE PRIVATE
SCHOOLS.
WHO ARE ABLE TO BE MORE CREATIVE?
IN THEIR APPROACH SOME OF IT
MIGHT BE ACCESS TO MONEY TO
APPLY TO IT.
BUT ALSO --
IN IN YOU KNOW THE CONCEPT OF
THE CAL GRANT PLUS --
BEING CREATIVE IN THE WAY THAT
WORKS TO WHERE THE STUDENTS HAVE
THOSE NEEDS.
DO THE PRIVATE SCHOOLS HAVE A
LEG UP -- A
BANDAGE ON THAT TYPE OF
CREATIVITY IS IT.
YOU SEE WITH ACCESS TO MORE
FUNDRAISING AMONG THE PUBLIC
SEGMENTS HOW WOULD YOU FIGURE
THAT OUT AND THEN WHAT CAN WE DO
AS LAWMAKERS.
TO REDUCE THE THE FETTERS THAT
THAT BIND THEM TO WHAT THEIR
LIMITATIONS ARE.
WELL THAT'S A VERY GOOD QUESTION --
IN TERMS OF THE PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS --
I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK FOR THE A
CC YOU WHO I KNOW IS HERE TODAY.
BUT I WOULD JUST.
GUESS THAT IT WITH THERE'D AB
PLUS SCHOOLS YOU MIGHT SEE
EIGHTY PLUS DIFFERENT APPROACHES
JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE VERY
DIFFERENT.
SCHOOLS IN TERMS OF THE FUNDS
THEY HAVE AVAILABLE THE STUDENT
POPULATION THEY SERVE --
AND SO FORTH CERTAINLY MANY OF
THEM ARE ABLE TO GET CREATIVE I
THINK THE QUESTION THAT YOU
ASKED ABOUT THE CREATIVITY AT
THE INSTITUTIONAL LEVEL GOES A
LITTLE BIT TO WHAT MR CHARMIN
WAS REFERENCING AND WHAT --
PRESENT UPON TANA CHANCELLOR
WHITE MENTION IN THEIR SET OF
PRINCIPLES FOR FINANCIALLY
REFORM WHICH IS THAT THE IDEA
THAT THE STUDENT IS.
QUOTE UNQUOTE PACKAGE TO BEING
THERE A AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL.
AND CERTAINLY THE STUDENT A
COMMISSION IS NOT PROPOSING THAT
THE STATE TAKEOVER THAT PROCESS
I THINK --
THAT IS WHERE YOU SEE INDIVIDUAL
SITUATIONS THAT THERE'S A VERY
UNIQUE I MEAN FOUR THOUSAND
STUDENTS SIR BY CAL GRANT FOR
THE THOUSAND STORIES AMONG THE
STUDENTS YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
APPROACHED BY STUDENTS WHO JUST
TO GIVE ONE EXAMPLE --
TELL ME THAT --
THAT THEIR THEIR LGBT Q. AND
THEIR PARENTS --
DON'T WANT TO SUPPORT THEM IN
COLLEGE BUT OF COURSE FASTER
REQUIRES A CALCULATION BASED ON
PARENTAL INCOME AND IN THOSE
CASES I KNOW THEY CAN GO TO
THEIR CAMPUS FINANCIAL AID
OFFICE AND GET WHAT'S CALLED A
PROFESSIONAL JUDGMENT.
OVERRIDE THAT SOMETHING THAT IS
CLEARLY MORE APPROPRIATELY
HANDLED AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL THAN.
AT THE STATE LEVEL FROM A
SACRAMENTO BASED BUREAUCRACY --
BUT I THINK THAT --
I THINK THAT IT JUST TOOK SERVE
BECAUSE THE QUESTION OF
INSTITUTIONAL LATER HOW RATHER
THAN THE STATE'S SWEEPING IT
WOULD BE MORE OF A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE AND THE
INSTITUTIONS I THINK --
A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS IS
WHAT'S CALLED FOR HERE AT THAT
SORT OF ADDRESSES WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING.
IF IF I MAY I EIGHT YOU KNOW I
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT A
CONSENSUS APPROACH AND HOW
THERE'S THIS FAIRLY SIMILAR
MODEL THAT'S NOW BEEN PROPOSED
BY SEVERAL OTHER ENTITIES AND I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DID NOT
MENTION.
THAT THAT IS ACTUALLY A CAN TO
WHAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DOES CURRENTLY THEY
HAVE WHAT THEY CALL AN EDUCATION
FINANCE MODEL THEY CALL THEIR
EFM.
AND IT DOES EXACTLY WHAT I'VE
MENTIONED IT LOOKS AT THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE WHAT'S
REASONABLE FOR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND THEN IT COVERS THE
REST THROUGH FINANCIALLY THAT
COMMUNICATES AT TO STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES CLEARLY --
NO IT'S NOT PERFECT IT WAS
PERFECT WE WOULDN'T SEE THE
DISPROPORTIONATE DEBT THAT I
THAT I JUST MENTIONED A MINUTE
AGO BUT I THINK IT DOES SPEAK TO
CREATIVITY.
AND THE CREATIVITY THAT COLLEGES
CAN ENGAGE THE MESSAGING IN
TERMS OF PACKAGING WHEN THEY
HAVE THE RESOURCES THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
FORTUNATE TO HAVE AN ENROLLMENT
OF BY STUDENT BODY THAT'S VERY
ALIGNED WITH THAT CAL GRANT
ENTITLEMENT POPULATION --
AND THEN THEY ALSO HAVE QUITE A
BIT OF INSTITUTIONAL EIGHT OF
THEIR OWN TO DOLE OUT SO --
CREATIVITY IS GREAT AND WE WANT
TO ENCOURAGE AT AND RESOURCES
SURELY HELP THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU SOMEONE EVER
GABRIEL INSTA MARTUCCI.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR
AND APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HEARD THIS IS MY FIRST
TIME SITTING ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND I APOLOGIZE.
FOR BEING LATE WAS TESTIFYING ON
ANOTHER WHAT BILL IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE SO I DIDN'T HEAR THE
BEGINNING OF OF OF YOUR
PRESENTATION BUT I'VE INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION TO EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS AND
I'M JUST CURIOUS.
YOUR ASSESSMENT OF THAT --
AND ALSO AS WE THINK ABOUT --
LONGER TERM MORE STRUCTURAL
REFORMS DOES IT MAKE SENSE BUT
POTENTIALLY TO INCREASE OF
EXPANDING THE NUMBER OF CAL
GRANTS NOW TO HELP STUDENTS THAT
ARE.
IN IN --
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER LEARNING
NOW -- IN
THE NEAR FUTURE AS WERE
CONSIDERING SOME OF THESE LONGER
TERM STRUCTURAL CHANGES.
I'D SAY THAT YES TO BOTH SO
EXPAND IT MORE COMPETITIVE
AWARDS IS FILLING REAL NEEDS
THAT WE'VE ALREADY DETERMINED A
REAL NEEDS. FOR STUDENTS WHO --
WHO HAVE EXPENSES THAT THEY
UNABLE TO COVER --
AND AND THE MORE THAT WE START
FILLING THOSE GAPS IN THE WAYS
THAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING --
THE CLOSER WILL GET TO BEING
ABLE TO HAVE SOME MORE EXPANSIVE
REFORMS WHERE PERHAPS EVEN SOME
SOME OF THAT ARE NOW COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANTS.
BECOME SOMETHING THAT IS --
AN ENTITLEMENT THAT WE CAN
COMMUNICATE AND EARLIER WAY WITH
WITH STUDENTS AND MORE EVEN MORE
EFFECTIVELY AFFECT THEIR
LIKELIHOOD OF AND THEN ROLLING
LIKELIHOOD OF ENROLLING FULL
TIME -- AND
THEN COMPLETING.
I WOULD ECHO THAT AND TO SAY
THAT -- THE
LONG TERM FOCUS IS APPRECIATED
BECAUSE THERE'S A GREAT CHART IN
THE GENDER THAT THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET POLICY CENTER PREPARE THE
SHOWS THAT THE DEMAND FOR THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROGRAM
HAS.
MORE THAN DOUBLED IN THE PAST
DECADE WHERE THE NUMBER OF
AWARDS THE STATE HAS INCREASED
ONLY SLIGHTLY SO --
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THAT TO
SOMEONE OR SPECIFICALLY --
THE THE EQUITY FOR THE DREAMER
POPULATION I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE
LEGISLATION TO EXPAND A
COMPETITIVE CALVET ELIGIBILITY
TO DREAMERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KNOWN AS IS RUNNING LEGISLATION.
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL AID TO
THAT POPULATION BECAUSE A
CURRENTLY LEFT OUT A FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID.
IS A GOOD LONG TERM FOCUS FOR
THE STATE I THINK BECAUSE OF
THAT POPULATION IS ALSO ONLY
GOING TO GROW.
THANK YOU AT THAT THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND MISTER --
MEDINA AUTHORED A BILL ON THAT A
FEW YEARS AGO AND WE DID
INCREASE THE COMPATIBLE WORDS
TWO YEARS AGO AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET HE HAS A SLIGHT INCREASE.
ONE ISSUE THAT THAT CAME UP AND
I'M SURE MR GABRIEL IN THE
DEBATE WILL TALK ABOUT THIS IS.
I I I I THINK WE SHOULD DO IT
INCREASING PET AWARDS BUT THERE
IS A REPORTFOR YEARS AGO IF MR
NEED COMMISSION WHEN THEY LOOKED
AT COMPETITIVE STUDENTS THE
COMPATIBLE --
APPLICANTS WHO DID NOT GET THE
AWARD.
AND YOU KNOW THAT THAT THAT
CLASS --
HAPPY HAPPY EMPTY SAYS THOSE YOU
KNOW FOLKS ARE GOING TO NOT GO
TO COLLEGE.
AND NOT HAVE A GOOD HIGHER
EDUCATION FULLER APPARENTLY
FOUND THAT THE STUDENTS DID GO
TO COLLEGE AND WERE SUCCESSFUL
IN SOME SOME WAY SO IT IS THERE
ANY -- DATA
THAT SHOWS THAT IT'S THAT SMART
INVESTMENT OR MORE NOT SO.
I BELIEVE YOU'RE REFERRING TO A
REPORT THAT --
WAS PREPARED ON OUR BEHALF
THROUGH US STANFORD RESEARCHER
WE WORK WITH NAMED A DEAD GRANTS --
AND NOT BEING A RESEARCHER AT MY
MY UNDERSTANDING FROM MY
COLLEAGUES TO SUMMARIZE THE
REPORT --
FOR ME IN.
AND THEY EXPLAINED LIKE I'M FIVE
METHOD WHICH I HAVE TO ASK FOR A
LOT FROM.
MY RESEARCHER COLLEAGUES --
ESSENTIALLY THE REPORT LOOKED AT
MANY YEARS OF THE COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS AT OUR
STATE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND DID
CONCLUDE THE FOR THAT POPULATION.
THERE APPEARED TO BE A
NEGLIGIBLE IMPACT ON THEIR
GRADUATION OR THEIR COME
ATTAINMENT --
WHETHER THEY RECEIVE THE
COMPETITIVE VERSUS STUDENTS WHO
WERE ELIGIBLE AND DIDN'T QUITE
MAKE INTO THAT POOL.
BUT A COUPLE OF THINGS TO NOTE
THE REPORT DID SAY THAT --
IT WASN'T NECESSARILY THE RESULT
OF THE THE STUDENTS MAY BE
NEEDING SOME ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
SERVICES ON CAMPUS BECAUSE
THEY'RE FROM.
WHAT WE USED TO CALL
NONTRADITIONAL POPULATION MAYBE
FIRST GENERATION AND THERE MAY
BE FOR SOME OF THEM LANGUAGE
BARRIERS SO THE REPORT --
DIDN'T NECESSARILY CONCLUDE THAT
IT WAS BECAUSE OF THE GRANT THAT
THERE WAS A MINIMAL.
DIFFERENCE THERE MAY BE OTHER
FACTORS AND ALSO SINCE THEN.
THE STATE OF THE LEGISLATURE THE
MINISTRATION HAVE FUNDED --
BUTTONS COCHRAN REFERENCE THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FULL
TIME COMPLETION GRANTS FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WHICH
PROVIDE THAT A CAL GRANT BE
STUDENT AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
GETTING A COMPETITIVE AWARD CAN
GET UP TO FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN ADDITIONAL A PER YEAR SO --
I THINK BAR AND WE WOULD SAY
THAT -- IT
BE REALLY GOOD TO SEE WHETHER
THOSE GRANTS AND SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SERVICES THE
COMMUNICATIVE HAVE ADDED UNDER
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY LEADERSHIP IN
THE LEGISLATURE'S COMMITMENT
HAVE HAD AN IMPACT MY GAS MY
EXTREMELY AN EDUCATED GUESS
WOULD BE THAT THEY HAVE.
THEY CAN START SEARCHING.
THANK YOU IDEA OF JUST TRYING TO
DIGEST ALL THIS INFORMATION I
WAS JUST LIKE LOOKING THROUGH
YOUR REPORT HERE AND AND THE SEA
ALL THIS WONDERFUL DATA --
SO I IDEA.
TRYING -- TO
MAKE SENSE OF IT ALL I I
APOLOGIZE IF I MIGHT ASK A
SOMETHING THAT --
MIGHT HAVE BEEN.
ADDRESS TO EARLIER ON ONE OF
THESE REPORTS --
YOU KNOW YOU.
YOU STARTED OFF BUT MISTER
O'BRIEN TALKING ABOUT --
HOW CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL AID --
PROGRAM OVER OVERALL IS THE ENVY
OF THE NATION ARE.
AND IF THERE IS A STATISTIC AND
THE STAFF REPORT THAT WAS
PRESENTED TO FOR THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING ON ON PAGE SIX THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE STUDENTS NOW
GRADUATE WITH AN AVERAGE DEBT OF
A LITTLE UNDER.
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND A HOW DOES
AT TWENTY THREE THOUSAND AVERAGE
DEBT COMPARED TO THE REST OF THE
NATION.
I WOULD ACTUALLY --
DIFFERS **** ON THAT BECAUSE
THEY KNOW TAKE IS DOES A LOT OF
GREAT WORK ON STUDENT DEBT.
THANK YOU --
AT CALIFORNIA IS WHAT WE CALL
CONSIDER WE HAVE --
FOR OVER A DECADE DONE AN
ANALYSIS STATE BY STATE OF THE
STUDENT LOAN DEBT OF COLLEGE
GRADUATES AND IN CALIFORNIA'S
CONSISTENTLY IN THE BOTTOM TEN
IN BOTH IN TERMS OF THE SHARE OF
COLLEGE GRADUATES LEAVING SCHOOL
WITH THAT AND THE AVERAGE AT
THAT THEY LEAVE WITH --
UNFORTUNATELY WE AREN'T ABLE TO
SAY ABOUT OTHER STATES IS WHAT
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO LOOK AT IT
FOR YOU SEE GRADUATES AND CSU
GRADUATES IN TERMS OF THE
DISPROPORTION AUDI OF THAT DEBT
AND THAT'S ONE OF OUR REGULAR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO OTHER STATES
TED TED RARELY ASK YOUR COLLEGES.
NOT JUST HOW MANY ARE GRADUATING
WITH DEBT BUT WHICH STUDENTS ARE
GRADUATING WITH THAT.
AND AND SO ALONG THE THAT THE
THE LINES OF WHICH STUDENTS ARE
GRADUATING WITH DEBT.
IN IN CALIFORNIA --
MEDIA WHO WHO.
HE ATE AND HOW WOULD YOU
DESCRIBE YOU KNOW WHERE THAT THE
DEBT IS CONCENTRATED THE MOST.
IT IS IN A LOT FOR EXAMPLE LIKE --
WHAT WHEN I'M TALKING WITH
CONSTITUENTS OFTEN --
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE
SURPRISED. TO TO HEAR THAT --
THAT OVER HALF OF OF OF ALL --
AT LEAST BERKELEY AND UCLA
UNDERGRADUATES HAVE THEIR ENTIRE
TUITION --
COVERED BY THE STATE --
A LOT OF MY CONSTITUENTS OR OR
OR OR SURPRISING EVEN --
YOU KNOW A QUESTION THE THAT.
THE THE THE TRUTH OF THAT --
BUT I MEAN GIVEN THE PROGRESSIVE
NATURE OF CALIFORNIA'S.
A FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM OVERALL
MAIN.
HOW WAS THAT THE AVERAGE DE
DISTRIBUTED?
TO YOU KNOW --
AMONG DIFFERENT --
INCOME LEVELS AND AMONG THE THE
DIFFERENT.
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS --
SO WE HAVE DONE AN ANALYSIS WITH
THE COUNTY STUDENT ASSOCIATION
FOR CSU GRADUATES AND WE HAVE A
ONE FOURTH COMING FOR YOU SEE
GRADUATE SECOND SPEAK MOST
CLEARLY TO THE CSU SITUATION --
AND THERE'S NO SYSTEM IDEA --
FOR FOR PRIVATE COLLEGES IN
TERMS OF WHICH STUDENTS HAVE --
DEBT AT CSU IT'S AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER IT'S ABOUT AN EIGHT AND
TEN THE LOAN THAT HAVE FAMILY
INCOMES UNDER ABOUT FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND IN FACT IT'S ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF CSU GRADUATES WITH
WITH STUDENT LOAN THAT.
HAVE FAMILY INCOMES UNDER.
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND IS OUR
STUDENTS WHO HAVE THEIR TUITION
COVERED THESE ARE STUDENTS WHO
ARE STRUGGLING TO PAY FOR THOSE
NON TUITION COSTS OF COLLEGE --
WE ALSO IN OUR REPORT LOOKED AT
BREAKDOWNS BY RACE AND ETHNICITY
AND IT WAS EIGHT IN TEN BLACK
STUDENTS THAT WERE GRADUATING
FROM CSU WHO WERE LIVING WITH
STUDENT LOAN DEBT SO HIGHLY
CONCENTRATED AMONGST LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF COLOR.
AND AND AND SO I I DID SEE THAT --
TO THAT INFORMATION BUT IN TERMS
OF THE AMOUNT OF DEBT --
IN NOT NOT JUST THE THE NUMBERS
OF STUDENTS GRADUATE WITH THAT
BUT THE THE WHO HAS THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF DEBT.
I'M INTERESTINGLY OF OF OF THE
DATA THAT WE'VE SEEN FOR
UNDERGRADUATE WE'RE LOOKING A
OF THE DEBT AMOUNTS --
FOR INDEBTED GRADUATE SEEMS TO
BE ABOUT THE SAME ACROSS INCOME
LEVELS SO THAT DOESN'T VERY
NEARLY AS MUCH AS STUDENTS
LIKELY HAD OF LEAVING SCHOOL
WITH THAT TRIP PACKED.
SO SO LOW INCOME STUDENTS WHO
WOULD HAVE.
ON AVERAGE WOULD BE --
GRADUALLY WITH ABOUT
CONSTITUENTS OR OF OUR MIDDLE
CLASS STUDENTS. FOR THOSE THOSE
WITH THAT YES.
OKAY THANK YOU THE CLIP.
IT'S STILL ABOUT ROUGHLY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE GRAND FOR UC AND CSU.
I'M THAT THAT NUMBER I BELIEVE
IS FOR ARMS GRADUATES FROM ALL
TYPES OF COLLEGES ACROSS THE
STATE OR AT LEAST PUBLIC AND
NONPROFIT COLLEGES --
AMONGST THE UC AND CSU SYSTEM
THE DEBT LOADS ARE A LITTLE BIT
LOWER OKAY THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OUR SHOW IS A BORN AND TRYING TO
ATTEND THE COLLEGE --
BUT THIS TIME WHEN --
SO MUCH MONEY SEEMS TO BE
AVAILABLE --
BECAUSE THE FIRST GENERATION
[inaudible]
IMMIGRANT.
TO WHO CAME HERE WITH A FIFTY
DOLLARS IN MY POCKET THE I GOT
MY MASTER'S DEGREE AND A PHD.
AND THEN --
HOW DO YOU KNOW AT SO FOUR IN
STUDENT AT THAT TIME --
I I I DIDN'T EXPECT THAT THE
GOVERNMENT WOULD COVER MY TO
SHOWN WHY ANY ROOM ROOM BOULDER --
A FINAL [inaudible]
UP [inaudible]
HIGHER EDUCATION.
IS A VERY COSTLY END A WE NEED
TO PROVIDE US MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
WHEN I WONDER?
I WORKED AS A BUSBOY DISHWASHER
ALL KINDS OF YOU KNOW STREET
VENDOR.
OF TO MAKE A FEW BUCKS --
TO COVER MY TUITION --
AND THAT THE PHD LEVEL OF A
LUCKILY I HAD --
SOME --
UPGRADED THE SYSTEM SHIP --
TO COVER MY AMENDED THAT WAS A
PAID THE BUT TO SCHOOL FOR MY TO
SHOWN THAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PITTSBURGH --
SO -- IN
AMONG MANY MANY QUESTIONS SOME A
MOM MAYBE ON OUR ADDRESS OF TWO
AREAS SO --
NUMBER ONE IS --
YOU MENTIONED THAT THE BEYOND
THE TREE SHOWN IT DOES COST
MONEY --
LEAVING A ROMAN WAR.
AND YOUR DIRECTIONS --
SOUNDS LIKE GO.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE AID THE ALL
THE COST ABOVE WHAT [inaudible]
THE TUITION.
DAY IN THAT THE BIG IDEA.
A TUITION FOR COLLEGE FOR
EVERYBODY HOW MR NATIONALLY THE
SOME NATIONAL ISSUE.
CAN THERE BE VERY IDEA.
HOW MUCH WILL IT COST OF FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO COVER ALL THE
STUDENTS WHO WENT WOMAN BOARD
INTO TUITION --
YEAH AND THE GRADUATE THAT WITH
THE TAX FREE DARBY REALLY IDEA --
BUT THE UNTIL WE ARE ABLE
[inaudible]
TO UP [inaudible]
COVER.
HERE ARE OF THOSE EXPENSES SO I
WONDER IF --
YEAH.
YOU.
PUT THAT INTO EQUATION.
ANTICIPATE THE STUDENTS SO
[inaudible]
NOW.
WHAT CAN EARN SOME OF THE OUR
LIVING EXPENSES SO?
SHE JUST LIKE ALL IN ALL I WORK
HARD.
AND THAT NOT I GRADUATE I
GRADUATED OUT WITHOUT --
RELATIVELY LOW --
THAT THE DID WORK --
THEY CAN WORK OF TIME AND WHAT
KIND OF BIT INCOME YOU CAN
ANTICIPATE THE STATE TO WORK A
CERTAIN NUMBER OF HOURS PER WEEK --
ETCETERA ETCETERA.
AND THEN REMAIN DOCTOR AND BE
ASSISTED. TO FOR A CERTAIN.
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF UP TO ME.
TWENTY SIX SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
ATTACKED AFTER GRADUATION --
MENDES SO PRETTY GOOD DEAL WITH
THE MORE.
ARRESTS OF THE EXPENSES SO UP
PAID [inaudible]
TO COMMON NON.
YOU WHAT I EXPECT THE SOME LEVEL.
OF A NOT ONLY PARACEL
CONTRIBUTION BUT THE INDIVIDUAL
OR US STUDENTS TO EFFORT.
TO MAKE IT.
IN THIS COUNTRY.
ARE UP TO HIGH SCHOOL IS THE
MANDATORY TESTAMENTUM MINIMUM
EDUCATION WE ARE EXPECTING.
OKAY COLLEGES IS SAW OPTION ALL.
WHAT'S THE WE ARE TRYING.
TO ENCOURAGE AND ANNOUNCES THAT
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
SO I THINK HE HAS TO BE MUTUAL.
OF CONTRIBUTION.
AND THEN I HAVE INTRODUCED A BE
ALL -- TO
ENCOURAGE PARENTS OF
GRANDPARENTS A RELATIVE SO ANY
ANY COMPANY.
ON TO GET THE TAX DEDUCTION ARE
IN CALIFORNIA.
IN OUR AREA SO FIVE TWENTY NINE
PLAN.
THAT THE INVESTMENT THE GROWTH
PORTION IS A TAX FREE ON THIS
THAT.
WE CAN DO ANYTHING ABOUT THE
FEDERAL PORTION OF TAX.
BUT THE IF I INVESTED THE I JUST
AHEAD WHEN YOU ORDER UP WHEN
CHILD IF I INVESTED THOUSAND
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR.
I WISH I CAN GET THEM.
TAX DEDUCTION AS AN
ENCOURAGEMENT [inaudible]
AND THE ANY ANY OTHER PEOPLE --
NO RELATIVES SO WHO ARE EVEN
COMPANY --
MORE FOR EXAMPLE MIKE.
IN AUSTIN AND ALSO A COMPANY MAY
INVEST IN IN THAT THE THE
EMPLOYEES SO FAMILY COLLEGE.
TUITION AND THEN GET THE TAX
CREDIT.
AND THE SHOW MUCH PEOPLE.
AROUND THAT THE FAMILY ONE PRO
EASE SO WE CAN GET THE CAN
ATTRACT.
US SOME INVESTMENT FOR THE
FUTURE.
SO RATHER THAN JUST OF FREE
GOVERNMENT GIVEAWAY CAN WE ALSO
CONSIDER.
A TO ENCOURAGE IT INCENTIVIZE.
HARRIS OF RELATIVES AND
COMPANIES TO TO MAKE UP SOME
PORTION.
SO THAT.
THEY CAN FROM THE BOOKS ARE.
BASED UPON THEIR FAMILY INCOME
CERTAIN PORTION CAN BE INVESTED
AND THEN --
GOVERNMENT THE IS SO IN --
ENCOURAGING FOR TEXTING.
THE LOOK AT THE LIST OF TAX
DEDUCTION IS NOT TAX CREDIT THE
IN ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS WOULD BE
TAXED SO INTO DOT THE IT.
OF FOR THE REMAIN TOLD THE TAX --
TO SO -- THE
INVESTMENT IN SCHOLARSHIP AND
DOT ORG PEOPLE IN THE SOCIETY
CAN CONTRIBUTE TO THAT AND THAT.
AT GET THE SOME BENEFIT.
DOCTOR CHOI --
BEFORE THE ANSWER EYES WHEN A
MAYBE SET THE STAGE A LITTLE BIT
SO -- WE WE
AGREE 1100% AND WITH THIS IS
THAT THIS TODAY'S HEARING IS A
CULMINATION OF THE LAST TWO
YEARS ON THIS ISSUE.
AND WE KNOW WE CAN'T AFFORD FREE
COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
EVERYBODY.
I DON'T THINK YOU KNOW SHOULD BE
BE SUBSIDIZING --
MY KIDS TO GO TO YOU SEE ONE DAY
THAT BE NICE BUT I'M NOT SURE WE
CAN AFFORD IT.
I KNOW --
MISTER MARTUCCI AND ARKANSAS
HERE WOULD LIKE THAT TO WITH
THEIR LITTLE KIDS IN AND MR
GABRIEL APPEAR BUT I'M NOT SURE
IF IT MAKES THE MOST SENSE --
BECAUSE WE HAVE OTHER NEEDS BUT
I THINK HERE IS DOING WHAT
YOU'RE JUST SAYING SO PARENTS
STUDENTS HAVE SKIN IN THE GAME --
FAMILY SAVE IN THE FIVE TWENTY
NINE ACCOUNTS WE'RE JUST LOOKING
AT THAT THE GAP IN THAT THE THE
COST OF COLLEGE IS DIFFERENT
THAN IT WAS WHEN YOU WENT TO
COLLEGE OR TWENTY YEARS AGO.
THE MINIMUM WAGE DOESN'T GO AS
FAR TO TO FOR STUDENTS TAKE
EARNERS EXTRA BOX TO PAY.
FOR THE COST OF COLLEGE --
THE HOUSING COSTS HAVE GONE UP
TREMENDOUSLY AND SO THOSE TWO
THINGS RIGHT THERE REALLY CHANGE
THE WHOLE ECONOMICS OF IT SO
WHAT SO WHAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON
IS HOW COULD WE DO EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING --
HAVE A A MEANS TESTED SYSTEM
HAVE PARENTS AND STUDENTS.
PARTICIPATE --
AS WELL --
BUT LOOK AT WHERE THE GAPS ARE
TO MAKE COLLEGE MORE AFFORDABLE
FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE KIND OF IN
THE MIDDLE SO MAYBE YOU COULD
JUMP IN.
TRY THAT ON THE TAX CREDIT --
ISSUE I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF
POTENTIAL FOR COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS ESPECIALLY FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS TO SEND A
MESSAGE ABOUT PLANNINGFOR
COLLEGE I'VE MONEY IN THE BANK
THEY KNOW IT.
AS THEY'RE GROWING UP I THINK
THERE'S A THERE IS A LOT OF
POTENTIAL THERE --
THE BIG QUESTION IS REACH AND
HOW DO YOU FOR A POPULATION THAT --
WHO DOES NOT HAVE JUST INCOME
AND IS --
PROBABLY --
AND IT IS HIGHLY UNLIKELY TO BE
TAKING DEDUCTIONS ON THEIR ON
THEIR TAXES --
THAT INCENTIVE IS NOT LIKELY TO
BE THE ONE THAT ENTERS THEM INTO
THE SYSTEM --
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR WHEN HE WAS --
MAYOR SAN FRANCISCO WAS --
LAUNCHED A PROGRAM OR EXPANDED A
PROGRAM THERE THAT PROVIDED --
A SEAT ABOUT OF OF SAVINGS TO
EVERY CHILD BORN IN THE CITY I
THINK THAT'S THE WAY IT WAS
DESIGNED AND I THINK I HEARD
THAT THERE'S A PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND THAT CONCEPT --
STATE STATEWIDE --
IF YOU ARE EXTREMELY LOYAL YOU
GET FREE TUITION IF IF YOU ARE
EXTREMELY RICH YOU DON'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT BECAUSE YOU PAY.
HOW ABOUT IN THEM BORDERLINE?
I MEAN THEY NEED ASSISTANCE --
TO SO THAT THAT'S THE SECOND
TIME I'M A SPEAKING YEAH YEAH
AND THAT CUT AND THIS THE
SAVINGS INCENTIVES THAT EXIST
AND DO TEND --
TO THE PARTICIPANTS TEND TO BE
AND UPPER INCOME --
TERRITORY SO --
SURE THAT OTHERS SAY AND THAT
THEY KNOW THEY HAVE SAVINGS NOT
JUST FOR TUITION BUT FOR THOSE
OTHER EXPENSES WERE TALKING
ABOUT BECAUSE GETTING TO TO YOUR
YOUR EARLIER POINT ABOUT.
WORKING YOUR WAY THROUGH COLLEGE
WE HAVE THE STRUCTURE OF A CON A
MI HAS CHANGED SO MUCH THAT IT
USED TO BE THAT YOU CAN WORK
PART TIME AND COVER.
UP RENT AND FOOD --
AT SCHOOL BUT WITH WAGES THE WAY
THEY ARE NOW FOR NON COLLEGE
GRADUATES IT IS NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH TO DO THAT WHICH IS WHY
WE HAVE --
THAT COST ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
EVEN WHEN TUITION IS WAIVED.
AND I JUST WANNA NOTICEABLY
MEMBER --
THIS STUDENT AID COMMISSION IS --
ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN --
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO ENCOURAGE FAMILIES TO SET UP
THOSE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS WHEN THE
CHILD IS YOUNG SO --
LAST YEAR --
THE THINGS TO LEGISLATION THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
MCCARTY --
AUTHORED AND TOOK THE LEAD ON WE
STARTED ADMINISTERING THE EVERY
KID COUNTS PROGRAM WHICH IS WERE
REACHING OUT TO CITIES LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO SACRAMENTO'S GETTING
ONE SET UP.
ON IN MY CITY WEST SACRAMENTO
THEY HAVEN'T CALLED HOME RUN
BECAUSE ON LOW INCOME FAMILIES
IN PARTICULAR AND THE IDEA IS
THAT WHEN THE STUDENT ENTERS.
KINDERGARTEN OR SCHOOL THE CITY
SAYS HEY YOU WE'RE GONNA HELP
YOU OPEN A SAVINGS ACCOUNT WILL
PUT A LITTLE BIT IN TO BEGIN
WITH AND THEN WE CAN MATCH SOME
THAT YOU PUT IN EVERY YEAR.
OR WHATEVER IT IS EVEN IF IT'S
JUST A SMALL AMOUNT AND AS
MISTER SHERMAN MENTION THE
IMPORTANT THING WITH THE COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS IS THE REACH
AND ENSURING THAT THAT GETS.
TO SOME OF THE LOWER INCOME
FAMILIES WHO SIMPLY MAY NOT HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO SET UP THAT
SAVINGS ACCOUNT BUT ALSO TO YOUR
POINT ABOUT THE TOTAL COST WHEN
THAT STUDENT GETS TO COLLEGE IF
THEY HAVE THAT MONEY THAT
SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
THEN THAT IS THAT IS GOES
TOWARDS THEIR TOTAL FINANCING
IT'S NOT JUST.
THE STATE OR THE GOVERNMENT
COVERING THE WHOLE THING IF THEY
IF THEY DO HAVE SAVINGS THAT SET
ASIDE FOR COLLEGE.
THEN THEY CAN RELY ON THAT AS
WELL. TO THANK YOU.
I I HAD ONE MORE AT MAYBE I
WANNA KNOWLEDGE A COUPLE THINGS
FIRST -- I
THINK SOME OF THE DISCUSSION
THAT WE'RE HAVING HERE THIS
MORNING GOES TO WHETHER --
HIGHER EDUCATION IS A A PRIVATE
OR PUBLIC GOOD AND I THINK WE
ALL ACKNOWLEDGE HERE --
THAT HIGHER EDUCATION IS A
PUBLIC GOOD SO IT IS NOT JUST
THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL BUT THAT WE REACH
THAT WE READ.
AS A AS A STATE AS AN ECONOMY OF
FROM THE FRUITS OF THOSE --
THE ECONOMIC AND AJ GRADUATE THE
BUILDS ON THE ECONOMY OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
HOW THINGS HAVE CHANGED WHEN MY
FATHER CAME TO THIS COUNTRY FROM --
PANAMA IN NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT
TO GO TO SCHOOL HE WAS ABLE. TO
WORK IN THE SUMMER CATALINA AS A
BELL HOP.
OR WORK DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR
WHEN HE WAS ATTENDING SAN JOSE
STATE -- IN
THE CANNERIES TO PAY FOR HIS
TUITION AND SUPPORT HIS FAMILY.
MYSELF AND MY SISTER AND OUR
MOTHER.
I WORK IN THE CANNERIES BUT
DEFINITELY THOSE TIMES ARE GOT --
AND IF THAT IS NOT --
ANY ANYWHERE NEAR WITH THE
REALITY IS AND TO THAT I WANT TO
ASK A QUESTION IF.
YOU SEE STUDENTS AND THE AMOUNT
THAT THEY'RE EXPECTED LOW INCOME
UC STUDENTS.
AND THE AMOUNT THAT THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEY ARE.
EXPECTED TO CONTRIBUTE.
ARE THOSE REASONABLE I I I HEAR
FROM A LOT OF THE STUDENTS THAT
THAT IS MORE THAN THEIR FAMILIES
CAN.
ACTUALLY AFFORD --
THE CONTRIBUTION AND THE AMOUNT
OF WORK THAT THEY ARE ASKED TO
DO.
YOU KNOW --
THE TIME THAT IT TAKES FOR THEM --
TO IN THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY.
TIME OUT OF SCHOOL WORKING SO
THAT REASONABLE TO EXPECT THE
LOWEST --
EARNING FAMILIES TO CONTRIBUTE
BECAUSE I HEAR FROM STUDENTS
THAT IT'S NOT.
I'M I WOULD SAY I THINK THERE'S
REASON TO QUESTION WHETHER IT
REALLY IS I THINK THE U. I
MENTIONED BEFORE THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA EFM THEIR
EDUCATION FINANCE MODEL.
AND IT'S BUILT ON A PRINCIPLE
THAT STUDENTS ACROSS ALL INCOME
RANGES SHOULD CONTRIBUTE THE
SAME AMOUNT IT'S ROUGHLY ABOUT
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR
AND THAT CAN BE FROM WORK THAT
COULD BE FROM DEBT.
NOW.
IF IT IS TRUE THAT THAT'S
INEQUITABLE APPROACH THAN YOU
WOULD SEE EQUAL LEVELS OF
BORROWING SOME STUDENTS IN EACH
INCOME CATEGORY WHICH USED TO
BORROW SOME WHICH IS TO WORK.
BUT THE TWIST IT SHOULD BE
ROUGHLY SIMILAR BUT WE DON'T SEE
THAT BECAUSE WE ARE SEEN YOUR
THREE QUARTERS OF THE LOWEST
INCOME STUDENTS.
LEAVING SCHOOL WITH THAT MUCH
HIGHER SHARE THAN ANY OTHER
INCOME GROUP SO SOMETHING
SOMETHING ABOUT THAT MODEL IS
NOT WORKING AND IT COULD BE THAT
STUDENTS HAVE IN THAT INCOME
RANGE HAVE A HARDER TIME ACCESS
SEEN.
GOOD JOB SOLID JOBS OR MAYBE
JOBS THAT MAKE ABOVE MINIMUM
WAGE.
IT COULD BE THAT --
THOSE STUDENTS ARE HAVING TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR FAMILIES
RIGHT NOT THAT THEIR FAMILIES
CONTRIBUTED TO THEM THEY'RE
CONTRIBUTING TO THEIR FAMILIES
WHICH MAKES LESS OF THEIR
EARNINGS AVAILABLE FOR SCHOOL
COSTS -- IT
COULD BE ANY ONE OF A NUMBER OF
ISSUES THAT COULD BE THAT THE
COSTS THAT ARE ESTIMATED BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THAT'S
ACTUALLY SENDING THEIR FINANCIAL
AID ELIGIBILITY ARE INADEQUATE --
BUT I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT I THINK
YOU'RE ON TO SOMETHING THAT
THERE IS A PROBLEM IT'S SHOWING
UP IN OUR LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND IT NEEDS MORE EXPLORATION.
HOW DO I WOULD WE --
HELP ALLEVIATE THAT THAT PROBLEM
FOR THOSE STUDENTS.
LIKE WHAT CAN WE DO --
ONE OPTION WOULD BE TO INCREASE
THE FINANCIAL AID FOR THE LOWEST
INCOME STUDENTS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA --
GIFTS THAT SOME OF THE LOWEST
INCOME STUDENTS.
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR BOTH CAL GRANT
EIGHT AND CAL GRANT BE --
AND WHAT THE STUDENT COMMISSION
DOES BOTH TYPES OF GRANTS AS
THEY GIVE THE STUDENT ONE THAT'S
MOST VALUABLE TO THEM --
YOU KNOW SO RIGHT NOW THAT WOULD
BE THE CAL GRANT A AWARD IF WE
INCREASE THE CAL GRANT BE ACCESS
AWARD MORE OF THEM WOULD GET CAL
GRANT THE AWARDS AND WE WOULD
THEN NEED.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA ALLOWED STUDENTS
TO BENEFIT FROM THAT
ADDITIONALLY IT.
AND DIDN'T JUST ROLL IT BACK UP
INTO THEIR OTHER INSTITUTIONAL
PACKAGING.
NOT JUST --
ACTUALLY MAKE IT SO THAT IT THEY
BENEFIT FROM THAT YES AND NOT
JUST TAKE AWAY MANY EXACTLY
RIGHT RIGHT NOW RIGHT RIGHT
EXACTLY TAKE BACK SOME OF THEIR
OWN INSTITUTIONALLY THAT THEY'RE
PROVIDING TO THOSE STUDENTS IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE IT TO OTHERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE'RE GOING TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND WE WILL MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT PANELIST AND I
INVITE THE PANELS REPRESENTING.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT COLLEGES
TO COME TO THE TABLE.
AND AS THEY'RE COMING I WILL
INTRODUCE THEM.
EVE THAT THE LAST INTER VICE
PRESIDENT OF STUDENT AFFAIRS THE
UC OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT.
NO WELL YEAH GONZALEZ DIRECTOR
OF ADMISSIONS AND FINANCIAL AID
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
STANISLAUS.
LARA MATTOON VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
EXTERNAL RELATIONS CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRANCERS
OFFICE AND THOMAS THE QUARTER
DEAN OF FINANCIAL AID.
AT USC WELCOME.
AND I'VE EIGHT THEY WILL BEGIN
WITH THE THAT.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU CHAIR
MEDINA AND HER MCCARTY FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
PERSPECTIVE ON FINANCIALLY
REFORM.
MY NAME IS THE BACK A LOT AND I
AM THE INTERIM VICE PRESIDENT
FOR STUDENT AFFAIRS AND VICE
PROVOST FOR DIVERSITY IN
ENGAGEMENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN MY CAPACITY IN STUDENT
AFFAIRS I'M RESPONSIBLE FOR
FINANCIAL AID AT THE UC SYSTEM.
IN MY CAPACITY AROUND ACCESS
EQUITY INCLUSION I ALSO SEE HELP
FINANCIALLY IMPACTS THE COLLEGE
PIPELINE. TO PUT IN A MORE
PERSONAL TERMS I SEE HOW GIFTED
STUDENTS FOREGO THE OPPORTUNITY
OF THE EDUCATION THEY DESERVE.
BECAUSE OF FEARS OF COLLEGE
COSTS COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY IS
ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES AND TO THE
WELL BEING OF OUR STATE.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY STRESSING
HOW CRITICAL CAL GRANTS ARE TO
THE SUCCESSES WE HAVE HAD AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND MAINTAINING ACCESS FOR LOW
AND MIDDLE INCOME STUDENTS AND I
WANT TO JOIN THE CHORUS IN
STATING THAT YOU SEE STUDENTS
BENEFIT FROM ACCESS TO THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL STATE GRANT PROGRAM
IN THE NATION.
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM AS WELL AS
A STE PROGRAM OUR OWN YOU SEE
GRANTS WHICH IS WHY CRAP CAL
GRANT REFORM HOLD SUCH PROMISE
OF FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. ONE OF THE KEY
PRINCIPLES THAT POLICYMAKERS ARE
DISCUSSING IN THE CONTEXT OF CAL
GRANT REFORM IS THE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE.
AND WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE OUR
FINANCIAL AID STRATEGY WHICH
YOU'VE HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
TODAY IS CALLED THE EDUCATION
FINANCING MODEL AND WE'VE TAKEN
THE SERIOUSLY FOR THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS.
IF YOU'LL TURN TO YOUR HAND OUT
I'D LIKE TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION
TO SLIDE.
THREE WHERE WE EXPLAIN OUR
PHILOSOPHY.
WE BELIEVE THAT A PARTNERSHIP
WITH PARENTS STUDENTS AS WELL AS
STATE FEDERAL AND UNIVERSITY
FINANCIAL AID CAN HELP STUDENTS
FINANCE THEIR TOTAL COST COST OF
ATTENDANCE.
SLIDE FOUR SHOWS THE FUNDING
THAT OUR STUDENTS RECEIVE FROM
THREE CRITICAL SOURCES THE CAL
GRANTS.
OUR OWN UC GRANTS AND PELL
IN TERMS OF TOTAL FUNDING CAL
GRANTS PROVIDE THE MOST SUPPORT
ABOUT NINE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
UC'S -- NEED
BASED GRANT COMES IN SECOND AT
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION AND
THE PELL GRANT FOR COMPARISON IS
ABOUT HALF OF THAT ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION --
PERHAPS MORE MOST IMPORTANTLY
SLIGHT FIVE SHOWS HOW THOSE
FUNDS HELP STUDENTS COVER
TUITION AND FEES OR OTHER
EDUCATIONAL EXPENSES.
AS YOU CAN SEE CAL GRANTS ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR YOU SEE STUDENTS
AND COVERING THEIR TUITION AND
FEES WHICH IS WHY MAINTAINING
THE FOCUS ON TUITION AND FEES
GOES A LONG WAY. TO DOING NO
HARM TO OUR STUDENTS.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE SLIDE
IF FEET IT FREES UP HELL GRANT
AND OUR OWN YOU SEE GRANT
FUNDING TO HELP OFFSET NON BE
EDUCATIONAL COSTS THAT STUDENTS
FACE.
THIS IS WHY WE AGREE WITH THE
RESOLUTIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE EIGHT COMMISSION AS ISSUED
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
RESOLUTION TO MAINTAIN AT A
MINIMUM.
COVERAGE OF TUITION AND FEES AT
THE PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM.
BUT CAL GRANT PROGRAM WAS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL IN KEEPING
YOU SIX SENSIBLE TO LOW INCOME
STUDENTS DURING AND FOLLOWING
THE GREAT RECESSION.
THIS IS BECAUSE CAL GRANT COVER
TUITION AND FEE STUDENTS WHICH
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY IN THOSE
YEARS.
I WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT WE
THINK THAT THE STATE HAS A
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
ON THE EXISTING SUCCESS OF THE
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS WITHOUT A
WHOLE SO RE ENGINEERING. FOR
EXAMPLE SIMPLIFYING AND
CONSOLIDATING THE PROGRAMS
INCREASING THE CAL GRANT BE
ACCESS AWARD.
AND ELIMINATING THE BARRIERS FOR
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS ARE ALL
GREAT THINGS TO DO AND WOULD
HAVE AN IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS.
WE'RE ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE RECOMMENDATION TO EXPAND CAL
GRANT INTO SUMMER SESSION.
AT UC ARE CHRIS DIDN'T GRADUATE
ON AVERAGE IN FOUR YEARS
ADEQUATE AND AND AND A TERM --
SO IF THE STUDENTS COULD PULL
TOGETHER A NEW YEAR ROUND HELL
GRANT WITH THE SUMMER CAL GRANT
THEY GRADUATE AND ENTER THE
WORKFORCE EARLIER AND THAT WOULD
FREE UP SPACE THAT YOU SEE IN
THE FALL FOR ADDITIONAL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
WANTS TO BE YOUR PARTNERS IN
HELPING STUDENTS MEET THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDING OUR
INSTITUTIONS WE CAN BRING OUR
OWN RESOURCES AND EXPERTISE AND
WANT TO BE AT THE TABLE FOR
THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU AND
OTHERS.
WE GET YOU SEE HAVE HAD GREAT
SUCCESS IN A ROLLING LOW INCOME
STUDENTS AS EVIDENCED BY THE
SHARE WHO QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL
PELL GRANTS.
YOU CAN SEE IN FLIGHT SIX THAT
WE FAR OUTPACE OTHER RESEARCH
UNIVERSITIES IN THE COUNTRY.
AND INSIGHT SEVEN YOU CAN SEE
THAT WE ALSO HELP THEM GRADUATE
WITH MEDICAL DEBT ON AVERAGE.
BUT NO POLICY WHETHER IT'S AT
THE STATE LEVEL OR AT THE LEVEL
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CAN COVER EVERY STUDENT
SITUATION.
THE MOST IMPORTANT REASON TO
PARTNER WITH US IN COVERING THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE IS THAT
WE ARE WHERE THE STUDENTS ARE.
WE CAN SIT WITH THE STUDENTS
HEAR THEIR STORIES REVIEW THEIR
CIRCUMSTANCES AND MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS WERE POSSIBLE TO
THEIR FINANCIAL AID PACKAGES.
SO IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO SAY
THAT CAL GRANT SO THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELEMENT TO OUR SUCCESS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR
EFFORTS TO EXPAND AND IMPROVE
THE PROGRAMS AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSULTING
WITH US ALONG THE WAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NO IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU CHAIRS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THANK YOU TO MY HIGHER EDUCATION
COLLEAGUES AND FELLOW?
PANELISTS.
I AM NO ALL THE GONZALEZ
DIRECTOR OF ADMISSIONS AND
FINANCIAL AID AT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY STANISLAUS.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM HERE TODAY.
I ALSO HAPPEN TO BE A MEMBER OF
SEE SEX FINANCIAL AID ADVISORY
BOARD.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE NEED COMMISSION
FOR THEIR IMPORTANT WORK IN
ASSESSING.
CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS.
AFFORDABILITY IS FUNDAMENTAL TO
THE C. ISSUES MISSION OF
PROVIDING ACCESS TO A HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATION.
FINANCIAL AID IS ONE OF THE SIX
PILLARS OF OUR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE AND IT IS ESSENTIAL TO THE
GOALS OF THAT INITIATIVE. TO
IMPROVE DEGREE COMPLETION
ELIMINATE EQUITY GAPS AND
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY WORKFORCE NEEDS.
WE ARE ENCOURAGED BY A NUMBER OF
PROPOSED REFORMS THAT WOULD
GREATLY BENEFIT STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES WITH FINANCIAL NEED.
AS WE HAVE EXAMINED THE
FINANCIALLY PROPOSAL SUBMITTED
UP TO THIS POINT WE HAVE BEEN
GUIDED IN OUR ASSESSMENT BY A
SET OF CORE PRINCIPLES WITCHER
STAFF SUMMARIZED IN YOUR AGENDA.
PLEASE PRINCIPLES INCLUDE.
BUILT ON THE CAR GRANT SIX
BUILDING KAGHAN SUCCESS AND DO
NO HARM.
CHANGES TO THE CAR GRANT PROGRAM
SHOULD NOT RESULT IN A
REDISTRIBUTION OF RESOURCES AWAY
FROM CATEGORIES OF STUDENTS WHO
ALREADY QUALIFY.
MAINTAIN CAL GRANTS CORE FOCUS
ON TUITION COVERAGE THE COVER ON
FOCUS ON COVERING TUITION FOR
LOW AND MIDDLE INCOME STUDENTS
HAS SERVED STUDENTS WHILE.
IT ALSO SENDS A POWERFUL MESSAGE
TO STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
IF YOU QUALIFY FOR CAL GRANT YOU
WILL HAVE YOUR PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
TUITION COVERED AT A MINIMUM.
EXPAND THE REACH OF COG RATS THE
CURRENT PROGRAMS INCLUDE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA THAT
EXCLUDES MANY NEEDY STUDENTS.
ELIMINATING UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
FOR STUDENTS WOULD BE.
HELPFUL FOR MANY NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS AND ESPECIALLY TRANSFER
STUDENTS.
A STAB ESTABLISH SUPPLEMENTAL
SUMMER CAR GRANT ELIGIBILITY
SUMMER ENROLLMENT HELP STUDENTS
GRADUATE FASTER WHICH OPENS
ENROLLMENT CAPACITY FOR OTHER
STUDENTS.
ALLOWING STUDENTS TO UTILIZE CAL
GRANT IN THE SUMMER SHOULD BE
ACCOMPANIED WITH ADDITIONAL
ENROLLMENT FUNDING SO THAT
ACCESS IS MAINTAINED THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR.
MAINTAIN COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES FOCUS ON THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE.
ADDRESSING THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE IS AN APPROPRIATE
ASPECT OF FINANCIAL AID REFORM.
ADDITIONALLY CAMPUSES SHOULD
CONTINUE TO BE THE HUB FOR
COORDINATING AND RESPONDING TO
STUDENTS SHIFTING NEEDS OF THEIR
THE ONLY ENTITY WERE ALL THE
FINANCIALLY PIECES FIT TOGETHER.
FEDERAL STATE AND INSTITUTIONAL
AID.
WITH THESE PRINCIPLES IN MIND
WE'VE EVALUATED THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR REFORMING
THE COG GRANT PROGRAM.
AND OUR PLEASE THAT SEVERAL OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS ALIGNED TO
THE CORE PRINCIPLES I'VE JUST
MENTIONED.
FIRST IN REGARD TO ELIGIBILITY
IN ACCESS BARRIERS WE SUPPORT
EXPANDING CAL GRANT BE TUITION
COVERAGE FOR THE FIRST YEAR AND
ELIMINATING THE GAP LEFT BY THE
INCOMING GPA REQUIREMENTS OF THE
CAL GRANT A AND B..
THESE ARE COMMONSENSE CHANGES IN
ELIMINATING UNNECESSARY BARRIERS
WOULD HELP POTENTIAL TRANSFER
STUDENTS ENROLLED AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN PARTICULAR AS WELL
AS THE MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
WITH SOME COLLEGE COMPLETED BUT
NO DEGREE.
ADDITIONALLY THE ELIGIBILITY
CRITERIA FOR THE HIGH SCHOOL
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM CURRENTLY
REQUIRE STUDENTS TO BEGIN
COLLEGE NO MORE THAN ONE YEAR
AFTER GRADUATING.
AND THE TRANSFER ENTITLEMENT
REQUIRE STUDENTS TO BE UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY EIGHT THIS IS AN
OUTDATED MODEL THAT DOES NOT
SERVE CSU STUDENTS.
MANY OF WHOM DO NOT FIT INTO THE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD
CATEGORY VERY WELL.
SECONDLY WE AGREE THAT THE FOCUS
OF FINANCIAL AID SHOULD BE ON
THE TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE AND
IT SHOULD MAINTAIN FULL COVERAGE
OF TUITION AND FEES.
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
SHOULD KNOW THAT IF THEY QUALIFY
FOR ACOG GRANT.
THEY WILL AT LEAST HAVE THEIR
TUITION COVERED.
EVEN WHEN TUITION INCREASES ARE
NECESSARY NECESSITATED.
THROUGH DICK DECREASE STATE
SUPPORT DURING HARD ECONOMIC
TIMES.
WE FULLY RECOGNIZE THAT TUITION
IS FOR FACED BY STUDENTS.
OUR CAMPUSES PACKAGE FINANCIAL
AID BASED UPON THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE AND THE TOTAL COST OF
INCLUDE BOOKS ROOM AND BOARD AND
TRANSPORTATION.
THE FIND THE COVER NOT BE AXIS
AWARD SHOULD BE INCREASED IN
ORDER TO BETTER ADDRESS THE
TOTAL COST FACED BY OUR STUDENTS
BEYOND TUITION.
THIRD WE ALSO SUPPORT A
SUPPLEMENTAL SUMMER CAL GRANT.
FACILITATING SOMEONE ROOM IT
WILL HELP STUDENTS GRADUATE MORE
QUICKLY THEREBY LOWERING THE
TOTAL COST AND STUDENT BARRING
ASSOCIATED WITH ACHIEVING A
DEGREE.
AND ALSO OPEN ENROLLMENT SPACE
FOR ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
THEY SHOULD BE SUPPORTED THROUGH
THE EXPANSION OF CAL GRANT
FUNDING.
FINALLY WE AGREE WITH THE
PERSPECTIVE NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE AGENDA THAT MAJOR
CHANGES TO THE CAR GRANT PROGRAM
SHOULD BE PHASED IN OVER SEVERAL
YEARS.
I'D LIKE TO CONCLUDE WITH A FEW
CAUTIONARY NOTES.
CHANGES TO THE CAR GRANT PROGRAM
SHOULD NOT RESULT IN A
REDISTRIBUTION OF RESOURCES AWAY
FROM CATEGORIES OF STUDENTS WHO
ALREADY QUALIFY.
UNIFORM WORK EXPECTATION FAMILY
CONTRIBUTION WOULD BE HARMFUL TO
OUR STUDENTS.
THEY ARE ALREADY WORKING HARD TO
SUPPORT THEIR FAMILIES AND
EARNED A DEGREE.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT MOVING TO A
MODEL THAT FIRST FACTORS AND
EXPECTED CONTRIBUTIONS AND THE
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS WOULD ONLY
HURT STUDENTS WHO ARE ALREADY
STRUGGLING.
LASTLY WE URGE THAT ANY
INCREASES IN THE BREATH OF
FINANCIAL AID MUST BE PAIRED
WITH INCREASES TO INSTITUTIONAL
FUNDING.
AS THE DEMAND FOR A CSU
EDUCATION INCREASES TO TO
REMOVING BARRIERS TO FINANCIAL
AID.
THE DEMAND FOR ENROLLMENT WILL
INEVITABLY NEED TO INCREASE AS
WELL.
WITHOUT A CONSCIOUS PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN AND WILL MAKE FUNDING
AND ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID WE
WILL ALL BE MAKING A HOLLOW
PROMISE TO STUDENTS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE THE CS USE PERSPECTIVE ON
FINANCIALLY REFORM WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO BE PART
OF THIS CONVERSATION MOVING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU THIS MEANT.
TO GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEDINA
CHAIR MCCARTY AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M LARA MATTOON VICE
CHANCELLOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR EXTERNAL
RELATIONS.
THANK YOU FOR PROVIDING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK.
UP AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR ON
GOING LEADERSHIP ON THIS REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
I THINK WE ALL KNOW THAT A
COLLEGE CREDENTIAL IS
INCREASINGLY THE KEY FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO UNLOCK SOCIAL
MOBILITY AND ECONOMIC PROSPERITY.
A STUDENT'S ABILITY TO AFFORD
THE TUITION AND NON TUITION
COSTS OF COLLEGE PLAY A MAJOR
ROLE IN THEIR DECISION TO ATTEND.
AND THEIR ABILITY TO GRADUATE.
THE MASTER PLAN FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION PROVIDES A DEEP
COMMITMENT TO COLLEGE ACCESS.
BUT IT REINFORCES TOO DEEPLY
CONCERNING INEQUITIES.
FIRST COMMUNITY COLLEGES SERVE
THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS BUT WE RECEIVE THE
LOWEST PER STUDENT FUNDING LEVEL
OF ANY SYSTEM OF EDUCATION IN
THE STATE.
AND SECOND THE STATE'S FINANCIAL
AID POLICIES REINFORCED OUTDATED
STEREOTYPES.
ABOUT TRADITIONAL COLLEGE
STUDENTS VANTAGE'S TODAY'S
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND IT PROVIDES
LITTLE AID TO MEET THEIR BASIC
NEEDS LIKE FOOD AND HOUSING.
WITH NEARLY TWO POINT TWO
MILLION STUDENTS THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES REPRESENT THE
LARGEST SYSTEM OF HIGHER
EDUCATION IN THE COUNTRY.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS STUDENTS.
MOST FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS
MOST STUDENTS OF COLOR WILL
BEGIN THEIR AT HIGHER EDUCATION
JOURNEY AT ONE OF THE STATE'S
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN COLLEGES.
WERE THE LARGEST WORKFORCE
EDUCATION PROVIDER.
AND WE HAVE A MAJOR ROLE IN
TRANSFER PREPARATION IN FACT 51%
OF CSU GRADUATES AND 29% OF YOU
SEE GRADUATES ALSO ATTENDED A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE ON
THE PATHWAY.
POLICY MAKERS IN THE STATE HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD TO ENSURE THAT
TUITION IS NOT A BARRIER FOR
STUDENTS IN OUR SYSTEM AND WE
SHOULD CELEBRATE THAT WORK THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE GRANT
WHICH WAS FORMERLY THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS FEE WAIVER.
PAYS TUITION FOR ALL STUDENTS
WITH FINANCIAL NEED.
NEARLY ONE MILLION STUDENTS HAVE
THEIR TUITION WAVED EVERY YEAR.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE FUNDED
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
WHICH PROVIDES TUITION COVERAGE
FOR UP TO ONE YEAR. FOR STUDENTS
WHO ARE NOT MEET THOSE
TRADITIONAL LOW INCOME STANDARDS
BUT ARE ABLE TO ATTEND FIRST
TIME AND FULL TIME THAT'S ABOUT
ANOTHER TWENTY THOUSAND STUDENTS.
AND FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO DO
NOT QUALIFY FOR EITHER THE
PROMISE GRANT FOR THE PROMISE
PROGRAM.
THEY BENEFIT FROM THE LOWEST
FEES OF ANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM IN THE NATION THEY PAY
LESS THAN FOURTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS ANNUALLY TO ATTEND FULL
TIME.
BUT THE TOTAL COST TO ATTEND A
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS
MUCH MUCH MORE THAN TUITION.
COSTS LIKE FOOD HOUSING AND TEXT
BOOKS CAN EXCEED NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
AND BECAUSE SO LITTLE GRANT AID
IS AVAILABLE TO COVER THOSE NON
TUITION COSTS.
AT A CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IT CAN OFTEN BE LESS
AFFORDABLE FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS TO ATTEND AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
IN THEIR REGION THAN THE
UNIVERSITY OF WE NEED TO CORRECT
THIS INEQUITY.
FINANCIAL AID IS A KEY COMPONENT
OF STUDENT SUCCESS AS HEART HAS
ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED THIS
MORNING.
AND IN RECOGNIZING THAT IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUR
BOARD OF GOVERNORS VOTED TO
REQUEST A ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL AID
STRUCTURE.
UNDER THE PROPOSAL NEW FINANCIAL
AID WOULD BE DIRECTED BASED ON
THREE PRINCIPLES.
FIRST ALL CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WITH FINANCIAL
NEED SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE FINANCIAL AID.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR AGE THE TIME
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL FOR THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE.
SECOND A STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
SHOULD BE LINKED TO THE TOTAL
COST OF ATTENDANCE NOT JUST
TUITION AND FEES BUT ALSO COSTS
LIKE FOOD HOUSING TRANSPORTATION
AND SUPPLIES.
AND THIRD A STUDENT SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO FINANCIAL AID
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY'RE
SEEKING A TRANSFER OR A HIGH
QUALITY SHORT TERM CAREER
PROGRAM OFFEREDAT ONE OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
THIS YEAR OUR SYSTEM IS
SPONSORING SENATE BILL TWO
NINETY ONE TO CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM.
IT'S REMARKABLY SIMILAR TO THE
PROGRAM DESCRIBED BY IT --
MISTER CHAIRMAN FROM THE CENTURY
FOUNDATION IT WOULD ESSENTIALLY
BE.
AN ADD ON AWARD FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS THE PROGRAM
WOULD PROVIDE A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT WITH A NEW GRANT
LINK TO THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE WANTED ACCOUNTS FOR
THE GIFTED THEY ALREADY RECEIVE
AND THE RESOURCES THEY HAVE TO
CONTRIBUTE.
THIS AID WOULD HELP STUDENTS
ELIMINATE LOAN DEBT AND REDUCE
EXCESSIVE WORK HOURS GIVING THEM
THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
COMPLETE THEIR PROGRAMS ON TIME.
IN ORDER TO PARTICIPATE COLLEGES
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO IMPLEMENT
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES THAT
SUPPORT STUDENT SUCCESS
SUCCESSFUL STUDENT OUTCOMES
PRACTICES LIKE DUAL ENROLLMENT.
EARLY OUT REACHED A HIGH SCHOOLS
FATSO COMPLETION BASIC SKILLS
REFORMS AND GUIDED PATHWAYS.
SB TWO NINETY ONE ENTERS A
MEANINGFUL COMMITMENT TO COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY BY PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO STUDENTS WITH THE
GREATEST FINANCIAL NEED.
I WANT TO THANK SENATOR LABOR
FOR INTRODUCING THE BILL AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM FOR BEING
A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF THE
MEASURE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
WORKS IN TANDEM WITH THE BROADER
FINANCIAL AID REFORM
CONVERSATION THAT'S HAPPENING IN
THIS COMMITTEE.
OUR PRIORITY IS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL RENTS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ACCEPT TO ATTEND AND SUCCEED
IN COLLEGE.
NO MATTER WHERE IN OUR PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM THEY
BEGIN THEIR JOURNEY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
THIS RECORD.
HI GOOD MORNING SERVER CARTUJA
MEDINA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK THIS MORNING
MY NAME IS THOMAS RECORDER ON
DEAN OF FINANCIAL AID AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS
AND I'M PROUD TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OF OVER TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
CAL GRANT RECIPIENTS WHO ATTEND
AN INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT
INSTITUTION IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
SCHOOLS THAT SUPPORT THEM.
AS A NATIVE CALIFORNIAN RAISED
IN BAKERSFIELD I BECAME AWARE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MASTER PLAN FOR
EDUCATION.
WHEN CAL STATE BAKERSFIELD
WELCOME ITS FIRST STUDENTS IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ASSURING THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION WAS MADE
AVAILABLE TO AN EXPANDING AREA
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY?
I ATTENDED PUBLIC SCHOOLS ONE ON
TWITTER ON UNIVERSITY OF
REDLANDS OR TO GRADUATE FROM USC.
WHAT MAKES THE KALRA UNIQUE IS
THAT IT WAS ESTABLISHED AT A
TIME WHEN CALIFORNIA WAS GROWING
COULD NOT CURING TO ALL ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS ACCESS TO THE PUBLIC
SYSTEM OF HIGHER EDUCATION?
CREATION OF THE CAL GRANT
INSURED STUDENTS ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY AND HIGHER
EDUCATION.
THE MASTER PLAN SUPPORTED THE
DEMAND FOR HIGHER EDUCATION AND
A WAY TO MANAGE THE INVESTMENT
IN THE ECONOMIC GROWTH AND WELL
BEING OF CALIFORNIANS.
IT ACKNOWLEDGED THAT THE
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT SECTOR
SHOULD AND WOULD PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE STATE'S
HER EDUCATION PATH.
THAT STORY CONTINUES TO BE TRUE
TODAY.
THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THE FOR YOUR
PUBLIC AND THE PRIVATE NONPROFIT
SECTORS.
HELPS TO CREATE EFFICIENT
INVESTMENT OF TAX DOLLARS WHILE
LEVERAGING THE CAPACITY IN
SUPPORT OFFERED IN THE
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT SECTOR.
IT ALLOW STUDENTS TO ATTEND THE
COLLEGE OR YOU THAT IS THE BEST
FIT FOR THEM ACADEMICALLY
FINANCIALLY.
AND WHAT'S WILL PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT NECESSARY FOR THEIR
SUCCESS.
AS WE ALL KNOW THE COST OF
COLLEGE CONTINUES TO INCREASE
AND STUDENT SUPPORT IS CRITICAL.
MUCH OF OUR DISCUSSION TODAY
REVOLVES AROUND ON TUITION
EXPENSES SUCH AS BOOKS AND
SUPPLIES ROOM BOARD AND OTHERS
THAT ARE CONSIDERED EDUCATIONAL
COSTS FOR THE PURPOSES OF NEED
BASED FINANCIAL IT.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
STUDENTS NON TWITCHING COSTS ARE
SIMILAR IN EVERY SECTOR.
THE PRIMARY DIFFERENCES IN THE
TUITION COSTS WHICH IS SUPPORTED
BY TUITION AND ELEMENT AND GIVES
OF THE INDEPENDENT SECTOR AND
TAXPAYER SUBSIDIES AND EXTERNAL
SUPPORT IN THE PUBLIC SECTOR.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT A LOW INCOME
STUDENT IS A LOW INCOME STUDENT
NO MATTER WHERE THEY A TON TO
CHOOSE COLLEGE.
THEIR SOCIAL ECONOMIC REALITY IN
CHALLENGES FOLLOW THEM WHEREVER
THEY ATTENDED I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
THINK ABOUT.
THE IMPROVEMENTS DISCUSSED TODAY
IN THE CONTEXT OF TREATING ALL
STUDENTS EQUITABLY.
AND ENSURING THAT WITH ANY
CHANGES WE SEEK TO BUILD UPON
THE STRENGTH OF THE COBRA
PROGRAM AND DO NO HARM TO
STUDENTS.
OUR SECTOR INVESTS HEAVILY IN
OUR STUDENTS AND ON ROMAN A
FLOOD REFLECTS THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE SPEND APPROXIMATELY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN INSTITUTIONAL
EIGHT EACH YEAR PROVIDING AN
AVERAGE OF NINETEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN INSTITUTIONAL GROUNDS
TO EACH KALRA RECIPIENT.
WE STRIVE TO MAINTAIN FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAMS THE BALANCE LOAN
AND WORK WITH BROWN'S.
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS GRADUATE
WITH APPROXIMATELY TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN STUDENT AT A
GRADUATION PLACING US FORTIETH
IN THE NATION.
AT US SUIT THE AVERAGE STUDENT --
KILL SLIGHTLY LOWER AT ABOUT
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT SECTOR OF
WHICH IS APPROXIMATELY.
TWENTY NINE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED OUR SECTORS FOUR YEAR
AVERAGE GRADUATION RATE IS 61%.
AND AT USC OR SECURE RATE IS 92%.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT OUR FOREIGN SECURE
GRADUATION RATES FOR CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS IS HIGHER THAN THE
OVERALL AVERAGE.
WHEN STUDENTS GRADUATE EARLIER
THE COST TO REDUCE THEY BORROW
US AND THEY'RE ABLE TO ENTER THE
WORK FORCE SOONER WITH THEIR NEW
EARNING POTENTIAL?
WHILE IT IS TRUE THE CALIFORNIA
HAS LONG BEEN CONSIDERED A
LEADER IN THE NATION IN HIGHER
EDUCATION THE PROMISE OF EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY IS THE ROAD AND AS
WE SEE ISSUES IN COLLEGE
COMPLETION AN ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. FOR OUR LOWEST INCOME
STUDENTS.
THE CALVET WRONG GETS GROANING
COMPLEXITY IS NOT SERVING ALL
STUDENTS AS WELL AS IT SHOULD.
WITH THE RECENT ECONOMIC GROWTH
OF OUR STATE AND A STABLE BUDGET
THIS IS A GOOD TIME TO EVALUATE
EVALUATE OUR POLICIES.
AT A HIGHER LEVEL AND CONSIDER
THE TIME RIGHT FOR MAJOR REFORM.
WE SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL TO
REINSTITUTE A FORMULA FOR
DETERMINING THE CAL GRANT AWARD
FOR STUDENTS ATTEND AN
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT SCHOOLS.
THERE'S BEEN NO INCREASE IN
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS EQUATING TO
NEARLY 50% REDUCTION OF
PURCHASING POWER.
EACH YEAR FUNDING HAS BEEN
VULNERABLE AS THE BUDGET PROCESS
UNFOLDS AT A TIME THAT STUDENTS
NEED TO KNOW WHAT SUPPORT THEY
WILL RECEIVE AND CREATING
UNCERTAINTY FOR STUDENTS AND THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT SORT OF THEM.
THE LACK OF PREDICTABILITY AND
DECLINING VALUE MAKE IT LESS
ATTRACTIVE TO FAMILIES AND
AFFECTS THE CHOICES THEY MAKE.
THIS HAS AN IMPACT ON THE AROMA
OF THE STUDENTS OUR SECTOR WHERE
THERE IS CAPACITY TO SUPPORT AND
SORT OF THEM. FOR EXAMPLE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND ONE THE CSU HAS
SEEN A TWO HUNDRED AND 27%
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF CAL
GRANT RECIPIENTS.
UC AT A HUNDRED AND 6% WHILE THE
PERCENTAGE OF CAL GRANT
RECIPIENTS AT I CC YOU
INSTITUTIONS HAS INCREASE JUST
18%.
WE BELIEVE THAT ARBITRARY
BARRIERS TO CAL GRANT AWARDS
WILL BE ADDRESS SUCH AS AGING
TIME OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL AND
DIFFERENT GPA AND INCOME AND
ALSO QUALIFICATIONS.
OVER THE LAST DECADE DEMAND FOR
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS IS
INCREASED BY OVER 2100% WHILE
THE NUMBER OFFERED HAS ONLY
INCREASED 14%.
STEPS WILL BE TAKEN TO SIMPLIFY
THE CAL GRANT TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR STUDENTS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE.
EXAMPLES ARE THE DIFFERENCES AND
CAL GRANT AMD QUALIFICATION OUT
AN ALTERNATIVE METHODS OVER
FEDERAL METHODOLOGY TO TO
TERMINATE.
AND RESTRICTING AWARDS TO
TUITION ONLY. FOR INSTANCE SOME
OF OUR ROTC EVEN VETERANS
BENEFITS WHICH MEET THEIR
TUITION COSTS SO THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO RECEIVE A CAGR OUT WHICH
THEY MAY BE QUALIFIED.
FOR EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY TO
SUMMER COULD HELP STUDENTS STAY
ON TRACK TO GRADUATE ON TIME OR
EVEN AHEAD OF TIME.
ALLOWING THEM TO REDUCE THEIR
EDUCATIONAL EXPENSES AND OUGHT
TO LAY AND IN THE WORK FORCE.
WITH THE RETURN OF YOUR OWN CALL
THE SUPPORT COULD BE INVALUABLE.
AS MENTIONED EARLIER WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO ASSESS THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS FOR ALL OF THEIR
EDUCATIONAL EXPENSES NOT JUST
TUITION SUPPORT.
UNDERSTANDING THE DIFFERENT
METHODS OF EVALUATING THE IT AND
AWARDING A WILL SYSTEM PROVIDING
POLICY MAKERS WITH A CLEARER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT STUDENTS FAIRS.
I HOPE THIS DISCUSSION HAS BEEN
HELPFUL TO AND THAT YOU CAN SEE
HOW OUR STUDENTS WOULD BENEFIT
FROM A FUNDING FORMULA.
IT WOULD PROVIDE PREDICTABILITY
THAT WOULD REDUCE ANXIETY OVER
FUTURE FUNDING AND A STATEMENT
OF EQUITY FOR STUDENTS THAT THEY
ARE VALUED EQUALLY IN OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM.
ASSURING THEM THAT IS THE STATE
INCREASES INVESTMENT IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR THERE WOULD ALSO
BE MODEST GROWTH IN THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT AND THEIR SUCCESS.
AND IT WOULD ALLOW THE STUDENTS
THE ABILITY TO ACCESS THE
INSTITUTIONAL CAPACITY OF OUR
INSTITUTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT QUESTION TO THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE YOU SEE
AN AND CSU A REGARDING SUMMER
SCHOOL --
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN SCHOOL SO I I HAVE A
QUESTION.
IS SUMMER SCHOOL MORE EXPENSIVE
TO STUDENTS NOW.
IS THE COST OF ATTENDING SUMMER
SESSION MORE THAN THE NORMAL
OTHER --
SEMESTERS OR QUARTERS TO THEM OR
IS IT [inaudible]
THE SAME.
A FOR THE CSU IT'S ALMOST THE
SAME.
IT'S REALLY BASED ON HOW MANY
STUDENTS ARE HOW MANY UNITS EACH
OF THE STUDENTS ARE TAKING.
A BIT OF THEIRMOST STUDENTS
TAKE ABOUT SIX UNITS EACH SUMMER
AND IT'S ROUGHLY ABOUT THE SAME
COST OF THE REGULARS MASTER IN
TERMS OF FEES.
AND FOR THE UC FOR USE IT'S
ABOUT THE SAME AGAIN IT'S BY
CREDIT HOURS OF THE COSTS ARE
DETERMINED DIFFERENTLY BUT IT'S
MORE OR LESS THE SAME.
COMPARABLE COMPARABLE.
AND AS IT STANDS RIGHT NOW
STUDENTS ARE NOT ABLE TO USE CAL
GRANTS OF FOR SUMMER SCHOOL
ATTENDANCE I CORRECT.
WHAT THE STUDENTS BECAUSE --
HAVE ATTENDED THE FLU THE YEAR
PRIOR FOR EXAMPLE AT THE
VIEWSTER OUT THERE ARE YEARS
ALLOCATION OF CAL GRANT ALREADY --
AND SO THEY HAVE THE FOUR YEARS
OF CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY IF WITH
THEIR TEETH DURING THE SUMMER IT
WOULD TAKE AWAY FROM THE FOUR
YEARS SO THEY WOULDN'T IF THEY
USE IT IN THE SUMMER THEY
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO USE IT. FOR
THE REST OF IT WITH A FOUR YEARS
HERE FUTURE ELIGIBILITY WRECKED
AND SO IT DO YOU HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION AS TO HOW MANY.
SEMESTERS OF QUARTERS --
WE SHOULD GRANT THEM STUDENTS TO
BE ABLE TO USE --
CAL GRANTS THAT TAKING SUMMER
CLASSES.
WHAT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA FOR STUDENTS ARE
GRADUATING IN FOUR YEARS ON
AVERAGE WITH AN ADDITIONAL TERM?
THEN A SUMMER OF CAL GRANT WOULD
HELP THEM GET INTO THE JOB FORCE
IN INTO THE INTO THE WORK FORCE
EARLIER SO IT WOULD CERTAINLY
BENEFIT OUR STUDENTS --
AND ENCOURAGE THEIR EARLIER
GRADUATION WHICH WOULD FREE UP
SPACE IN THE FALL. FOR NEW FOR
NEW UC STUDENTS BECAUSE OUR
STUDENTS WOULD NOT THEN BE
ENROLLED IN FALL AND FALL TERM
THREE RECOMMENDATION FROM YOU
SEE WOULD BE JUST THE ONE ONE
TIME.
AT A MINIMUM THAT'S ADDITIVE --
AND FROM CSU.
SO WE HAVEN'T LOOKED AT IT VERY
CLOSELY TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION
SPECIFICALLY BUT FROM MY
EXPERIENCE --
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK. THREE FROM THREE
SUMMER TERMS.
SO STUDENT WITH BE ABLE TO
ATTEND EACH SUMMER BETWEEN THEIR
FRESHMAN AND SOPHOMORE YEAR
THEIR SOPHOMORE AND JUNIOR.
IN JUNIOR AND SENIOR SO THREE
TERMS IT'S SIMILAR TO WHAT THE
PROGRAM THE FEDERAL PROGRAM IS
DOING NOW.
HAD THANK YOU.
FAN AND I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE --
THE THE IMPORTANCE OF A PRIVATE
NON PROFIT SCHOOLS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT THE GREAT
JOB THAT THEY DO AND THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE --
LIKE PART TIME FACULTY --
YOU KNOW OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WOULD NOT EXIST IT WERE NOT FOR
PART TIME FACULTY --
THAT CALIFORNIA WOULD NOT HAVE
THE EXCELLENT --
HIGHER EDUCATION A SYSTEM THAT
WE DO WERE IT NOT FOR THE THE
PRIVATES --
AND I AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I VERY MUCH WANT TO SEE
WOULD YOU RECOMMENDED.
THAT WE PUT IN A FORMULA SO THAT
THE THE THE PRIVATES DON'T HAVE
TO COME BACK.
EVERY YEAR TO KEEP PACE WITH THE
CAL GRANT SO I I HOPE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE THAT.
UP IN THIS BEEN THAT WOULD BE MY
RECOMMENDATION.
YEAH JUST --
JUST ADD ON WHAT YOU SAID MISTER
MEDINA ON THE THE SUMMER SCHOOL
ISSUE I I THINK THAT'S A GREAT
IDEA.
AND IT REALLY ADDRESSES TO
ISSUES ADDRESSES FINANCIAL AID
AND STUDENTS BUT ALSO THE ISSUE
WERE TRYING.
TO GET AT WITH CSU AND THEIR
GRAD.
AND YOU KNOW SUMMER IS A BIG
ISSUE IN SELF WE GET STUDENTS
GOING TO SUMMER MORE.
WE GET THE GRADUATING IN A
FASTER PER OF TIME AND OPEN UP
THOSE CSU CHAIRS FOR THAT THREE
THOUSAND STUDENTS WHO CAN'T GET
INSULTS AT WIN WIN WIN --
ALL THE WAY AROUND I KNOW THIS
THIS TO DATE COMMISSION MISTER
O'BRIEN DID YOU HAVE A DO YOU
HAVE A A NUMBER AS FAR AS WHAT
THAT WOULD. FOR THAT WOULD COST
YOU COME ON SURE SCHOOL YEAH IF
WE IF WE HAD MISTER LEVINE WAS
HERE EARLIER HAD A HE HAD A BILL
ON THIS LAST YEAR WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE SO IT'S IT IT'S NOT A
NEW IDEA THAT GOOD --
ONE SO WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT
WOULD COST --
IT IT DEPENDS ON THE FORMULA BUT
THE LEGISLATION THAT'S BEEN
INTRODUCED FOR STILL COSTING IT
OUT.
VARIOUS VERSIONS OF PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION WE'VE COSTED IT
ANYWHERE FROM. TWENTY TO FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR --
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON THE
CURRENT ONE YES SO JUST BE KIND
OF LIKE UP PLUS THE CAL GRANT
PLUS WE GIVE THEM.
YOU KNOW THEY GET CREDIT FOR UP
TO YOU KNOW. FOR FIVE CLASSES
THROUGHOUT THEIR CAREER DURING
THE SUMMER SOMETHING LIKE YEAH
YEAH A IN A LOT OF IT DEPENDS ON
THE IMPACT TO STUDENTS --
ENROLLMENT SO.
WE CAN RUN THE GOAL OF THE
LEGISLATION SEE MORE STUDENTS
INTO THE COURSES THAN.
THOSE OBVIOUSLY GO UP BUT WE'VE
LOOKED AT VARIOUS VERSIONS THAT
IN THAT -- I
BELIEVE TWENTY TO FIFTY MILLION
I'M JUST CHRIS WAS THERE OF AND
IT WAS A BILL LAST USER A BILL
AGAIN THIS YEAR INTRODUCED ON
THE TOPIC.
YES I BELIEVE THERE HAS BEEN
RUBIO.
OKAY AND THEN FOR FOR UC AND CSU
I I KNOW IT'S SOMEWHAT
CONTROVERSIAL BUT WHATDO YOU
THINK ABOUT THE PRIOR.
NOW WE TALKED ABOUT THAT ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION YOU KNOW
ROUGHLY INTEREST SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND FOR EACH OF THE TWO
SEGMENTS THAT.
IS YEAR YOUR AGE I MEAN IT'S NOT
YOU IT'S HAS STEERED YOUR
STUDENTS PAYING.
A THIRD OF THEIR WALTER PAY THE
TUITION A THIRD OF IT GOES BACK.
TO EIGHT AND SOME HAVE HOW
HAVING MORE COORDINATION IN A
POTENTIALLY HAVE IT GO THROUGH
ONE ENTITY. TO TO STREAMLINE AND
MAKE IT MORE EFFICIENT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK FROM THE
SEGMENTS ABOUT THAT?
THANK YOU FOR THAT FOR THAT
QUESTION OF I SO AS WE AS WE
STATED THE THE THE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THAT A STUDENT GETS.
COMES TO A CAMPUS IT IS IT IS
LOCALLY PACKAGE AND SO.
THE COLLABORATION COORDINATION
DATA SHARING BETWEEN THE STATE
AND THE AND THE CAMPUSES WITH
RESPECT TO THAT.
IS WHICH WOULD BE HELPFUL AND IT
WOULD HELP US ALL MAKE BETTER
DECISIONS BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY ALL THE OTHER FORMS OF AID
ARE AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL AND
THAT'S WHERE STUDENTS ARE AND
THAT'S WHERE DECISIONS HAVE TO
BE MADE.
AND SO WE COULD WE COULD
ENVISION BETTER COLLABORATION
BETTER --
DATA SHARING WITH US FOR
PACKAGING REMAINING WITH THE
WITH THE SEGMENTS AND WITH THE
WITH THE CAMPUSES.
AN ARM TO MUCH FOR THE CSU WE
ARE IT'S MORE OF A WAIVER
PROGRAMS HAS SAID THE FEES FOR
THAT THOSE STUDENTS --
ALTHOUGH THERE IS A VALUE TO IT
BECAUSE WERE WAVING A FEE --
IT'S IT'S MORE OF A WAIVER
PROGRAM SO THERE ISN'T YOU KNOW
IT'S KIND OF A POT OF CASH
ANYWHERE.
TO REDISTRIBUTE --
SO WE'LL ESPECIALLY WAVING THE
FEES FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
MISTER CHOI.
YES IT IS --
THE NO FINANCIAL AID --
NOW FROM USC --
MAKE NOT WATERS HERE I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK --
DOES SOMETHING A PRIVATE SCHOOLS.
I USED TO HAVE --
AS I UNDERSTAND --
LAW WHICH IN DOMON --
MONEY MOSTLY --
TOWARDS THE SCHOLARSHIPS WHITE.
SO ARE YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
SECTEUR YOU ASSUMES BUT YOU
YOU'RE YOU SEM TALK ABOUT VERY
LITTLE AND ELEMENT TARGETED
SPECIFICALLY FOR STUDENT AT WERE
ACTUALLY MUCH MORE TUITION
DEPENDENT.
IS MOSTLY FOR ACADEMIC
PRIORITIES RESEARCH ACADEMIC
SIDE OF THE HOUSE.
SO YOUR AND ALMOST AND I WERE
PARTNER AND A LOT OF GRADUATE
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS THE SO ABOUT
4% OF OUR UNDERGRADUATE AND
COMES FROM AND DOLMA.
I A C. -- I
A WAS UNDER THE IMPRESSION WAS
HOPING THAT --
HAD LARGE AMOUNT THE HOME CLOSE --
TO THE AT THE WHAT THE
SCHOLARSHIP AID THE FOR THE SO
WHO -- TO
NOT GET --
THE REST OF THE ON THE
GOVERNMENT --
FINANCIAL AID THE HOUSE --
AGAIN EMULATED BY PUBLIC SCHOOLS
TO BECAUSE OF PROP PRIVATE
SCHOOLS TO TEND.
TO HAVE A MORE --
HELLO NIGHT DONATIONS --
ETCETERA ETCETERA AND WHY NOT
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL REDUCE --
ORDERED TO THE SAME LEVEL OF
WHAT FUND RAISING.
AND COME FROM THOSE AMOUNT THE
THE SCHOLARSHIP CAN BE COVERED --
DOES THE REST OF US THAT THE CAT.
CAN BE COVERED THE BY THE DONATE
DONATED THE FUNDS.
BUT THE YOU ARE SAYING ONLY 4%
OF YOU AND ONE FROM COAST TO
SCHOLARSHIP AT THE UNDERGRADUATE
LEVEL.
MEMBER WE HAVE WILL FORTY NOT A
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE UNDERGRAD
RIGHT SO AT THE UNDERGRADUATE
LEVEL VERY LITTLE STUDENT IT IS
SUPPORTED BY AND ALMA.
BUT AGAIN REPRESENTING EIGHTY
ONE INDEPENDENT SCHOOLS THEY'RE
VERY GREATLY IN THEIR AND
ALMONDS.
YOU HELLO OF A STAFFER FRENZEL'S
WITH THE VERY SIGNIFICANT
ELEMENT PROVIDING VIRTUALLY NO
LOAN PACKAGE RULES.
OTHER SCHOOLS WERE THERE WOULD
BE MORE TUITION DEPENDENT.
BASED ON THE SIZE OF THEIR
INCOME AT USC HAS HAS JUST
FINISHED A CAMPAIGN WITH ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED MILLION RESIDENTS TO
NAY BUT OF COURSE MUCH OF THAT
IS GIPSON WILL UP TO RECEIVE FOR
MANY YEARS.
THROUGH GIFT AGREEMENTS BEQUESTS
OF SERVICE.
SHOW YOU INVEST A DEFENSEMAN TO
WE'RE ALLOWED --
MORE SPECIFICALLY DO YOU USED TO
AND AND FUND IT'S IT'S MOSTLY
FOR ACADEMIC PRIORITIES SO MUCH
MORE THAN ENOUGH TO MAKE POWER
FUNDING FACULTY.
YOUR EFFORT OF A FUNDRAISING
FROM ONE ON NINE TESTS --
LOGICALLY NOT USED TO FOR
SCHOLARSHIP PURPOSES SIZE
[inaudible]
ON THE INFORM FORMA PERFECT
PURPOSE OF ROOM FROM A US SECRET
SCHOOL OF LIBRARY AND
INFORMATION MANAGEMENT THOUGH
RIGHT AFTER MY PH.
SOBRE.
THAT BROKE BROUGHT ME TO
CALIFORNIA.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER YOU ARE
THEY ARE NOT THAT THAT THE
THIRTY THREE OKAY THANK YOU.
AT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS HELP WITH THAT THEN OUT
THANK THE PANEL.
AND AND THEN INVITE THE PANELS
REPRESENTING THE STUDENTS.
OF UC.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT --
COLLEGES TO COME TO THE TABLE.
AND AS THEY'RE COMING I WILL
INTRODUCE THEM.
CAROLINE SIEGEL SAYING.
PRESIDENT OF THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION.
MIA COULD SHE OWNERS PRESIDENT
OF THE CSU.
AND I APOLOGIZE PRESIDENT OF THE
CSU STUDENT ASSOCIATION
[inaudible]
DANNY.
THIRD CALL LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR.
REGION TO STUDENT SENATE OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND NAY THE NOON YES FROM MRS --
PACIFIC UNIVERSITY WELCOME ALL.
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH CAROLINE
FROM THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU TO
COMMITTEE LEADERSHIP FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM FOR YOU SEE STUDENTS.
AND ALSO FOR MAKING SURE THAT
STAND VOICE IS A PART OF TODAY'S
HEARING AND THE POLICY MAKING
PROCESS IT'S VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED.
AS THE CURRENT THIRD YEAR AT UC
SAN DIEGO THE CAL GRANT IN
COMBINATION WITH THE FEDERAL
PELL GRANT AND A GENEROUS
INSTITUTIONAL AID PROGRAM.
HAS MEANT THAT I AM ABLE TO
ATTEND THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT HAVING TO
WORRY ABOUT PAYING THE COST OF
TUITION.
ROUGHLY 56% OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
IN THE SAME SITUATION.
THE CAL GRANT HAS AFFORDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STUDENTS AT ALL
THREE INSTITUTIONS SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IN NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE
AS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SCHOLARSHIP.
ESSENTIALLY SAYS THAT CALIFORNIA
SEES THEM AND THEIR EDUCATION AS
AN INVESTMENT.
I THINK THE REFORM PROCESS
ALLOWS US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPAND THIS PROMISE TO ADDRESS
THE TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE AS
WELL.
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
THREE CONCERNS WITH THE CURRENT
PROGRAM THAT I'M HOPING CAN BE
ADDRESSED IN THE REFORM PROCESS.
THE FIRST BEING BETTER SUPPORT
FOR TRANSFER STUDENTS ONCE THEY
ENTER OUR INSTITUTION.
SECOND BEING A SUMMER CAL GRANT
TO INCREASE TIME TO COMPLETION.
AND THE THIRD BEING THE
INCLUSION OF UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS INTO OUR STATE AID
PROGRAM.
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
THE GENEROUS ONE THIRD RETURN TO
AID MODEL MEANS THAT STUDENTS
WHO WOULD QUALIFY FOR CAL GRANT.
BUT ARE EXCLUDED FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS SUCH AS BEING OVER
THE AGE OF TWENTY EIGHT TAKING
MORE THAN A YEAR OFF AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL.
AND US SOMETHING EVEN AS SIMPLE
AS TURNING IN THEIR AFTER THE
MARCH SECOND DEADLINE.
MEANS THAT THEY ARE NOW NOT ABLE
TO RECEIVE THE STATE CAL GRANT
HOWEVER THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA USES ROUGHLY TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS OF OUR INSTITUTIONAL AID.
TO BACK FILL THESE GENTS
FINANCIAL AID --
PACKAGES TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE NOT GOING WITHOUT. TOO MANY
TRANSFER STUDENTS ARE EXCLUDED
FROM THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT
PROVIDED IN THE CURRENT CAL
GRANT PROGRAM AND I THINK THAT
SENDS A MESSAGE THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA DOES NOT SEE THOSE
STRANDS AS WORTHY OF THE SAME
INVESTMENT AND IT'S REALLY
UNFORTUNATE I HOPE THAT CHANGES
SOON. TO QUICKLY PUT NUMBERS TO
THE ISSUE THERE ARE ROUGHLY
TWENTY THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
STUDENTS AT UC.
WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
RECEIVING THE GRANT IF WE WERE
TO FOLLOW THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
AID COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATIONS
APPROVED IN NOVEMBER?
BY JUST ELIMINATING THE AGE
REQUIREMENT OF TWENTY EIGHT WE
COULD PROVIDE AID TO AN
ADDITIONAL ONE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED STUDENTS AT UC.
THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF WHO IS
PURSUING HIGHER EDUCATION IN THE
STATE IS RAPIDLY CHANGING I KNOW
THAT IN THE LAST FEW YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PLACED AN
EMPHASIS ON MAINTAINING A TWO TO
ONE TRANSFER RATIO.
AT THE UC.
THIS MEANS IT NOW MORE THAN EVER
THE INSTITUTION IS AND ROLLING
AND NEEDING TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
FOR THIS POPULATION. TO SUPPORT
THEIR SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION.
WE NEED TO EXPAND THE CURRENT
PROGRAM BEYOND COVERING JUST THE
COST OF TUITION AND LOOK AT
COVERING THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE.
POSSIBLY THROUGH AN INCREASE TO
THE ACCESS AWARD.
TODAY TUITION ONLY ACCOUNTS FOR
ABOUT A THIRD OF STUDENTS COST
OF ATTENDANCE IN THE UC.
AND SOME OF THE LARGEST BARRIERS
TO OUR STUDENTS TODAY ESPECIALLY
LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
ARE THE NON TUITION COSTS SUCH
AS FOOD AND HOW.
CONCERNING NUMBERS OF STUDENTS
ON OUR CAMPUSES ARE STRUGGLING
WITH HOMELESSNESS AND BASIC NEED
SECURITY AND SECURITY.
OUR STUDENTS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
AFFORD BASIC NEEDS.
LAST SUMMER I WAS ABLE.
TO TAKE SUMMER COURSES AT UC SAN
DIEGO AND SO THROUGH THE
INSTITUTIONAL AID.
I RECEIVED ROUGHLY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS WITH THE FEDERAL PELL
GRANT PROGRAM BEING A NEWLY
APPROVED YEAR ROUND PROGRAM I
RECEIVED ROUGHLY.
NINE HUNDRED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THAT COVERED TUITION.
AND LEFT ME WITH.
MAYBE TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
EVERY OTHER COST ASSOCIATED WITH
ATTENDING SCHOOL THAT SUMMER.
CURRENTLY STUDENTS CANNOT BE
AWARDED CAL GRANT FOR THE SUMMER
SESSIONS.
BECAUSE A WOULD ESSENTIALLY
REMOVE ONE OF THEIR ELIGIBILITY
DURING THEIR SENIOR YEAR. FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE A STUDENT AT
UC BERKELEY AND YOU CHOSE TO USE
YOUR CAL GRANT DURING THE SUMMER.
YOUR SENIOR YEAR LAST SEMESTER
YOU WOULD SUDDENLY BE AN
ELIGIBLE.
THAT PROVIDES AN ISSUE FOR A LOT
OF OUR STUDENTS.
TAKING SUMMER SESSIONS ENSURES
THAT STUDENTS ARE LESS LIKELY TO
DROP OUT OF SCHOOL AND GET THEIR
DEGREE FASTER.
HELLO GRANT RECIPIENTS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAVE A
SIX YEAR GRADUATION RATE OF 72%.
FOR THOSE WHO DO NOT ENROLL IN
SUMMER.
HOWEVER WHEN YOU TAKE OUT --
OUT IN ONE ADDITIONAL SUMMER
CHIU THAT GOES UP 286%.
WHEN STUDENTS TAKE TWO SUMMER
TERMS IT GOES UP 291%?
YEAH BY PROVIDING A SUMMER CAL
GRANT THIS WOULD FREE UP
INSTITUTIONAL AID TO ALSO HELP
COVER THE NON TUITION COSTS
DURING THE SUMMER.
ADDITIONALLY INCREASE INCREASING
THE CAL GRANT BE ACCESS AWARD
WOULD ALSO HELP WITH THESE NON
TUITION COSTS.
MY LAST POINT THAT I WOULD LIKE.
TO SAY IS THAT THE CAL GRANT
ALSO NEEDS TO BE EXPANDED TO
ALLOW ELIGIBLE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS TO COMPETE FOR CAL
GRANT AWARDS JUST AS THEIR PEERS
DO.
WITHOUT ADDITIONAL BARRIERS
DESPITE THE ELIGIBILITY OF THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT FILERS FOR
ENTITLEMENT CAL GRANTS CURRENT
STATUTE REQUIRES THE ALL
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS COMPLETING A
FAFSA.
MUST BE AWARDED THE COMPETITIVE
CAL GRANT BEFORE THEIR PEERS
THAT COMPLETE THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT.
TO SO IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
CHANCE APPLIED.
FOR ROUGHLY TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS MEANING
THAT FEWER THAN 7% OF THESE
APPLICANTS RECEIVED MUCH NEEDED
FINANCIAL AID.
THIS IS ACTUALLY MEANS THAT
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT FILERS WILL
NEVER RECEIVED THE COMPETITIVE
AWARDS DESPITE POTENTIALLY
HAVING GREATER FINANCIAL NEED
AND DEMONSTRATING.
THE SAME ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE.
I THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INCLUDE YOU SEE
STRANDS AND YOUR PRIORITIES THIS
YEAR.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU TO SEE AN AFFORDABLE YOU SEE
EDUCATION BECOME A REALITY FOR
ALL OF ACTION POPULATIONS.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MIA.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MIA KEY
JANICE I'M A SENIOR AT
SACRAMENTO STATE STUDYING
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION AND I'M
HERE REPRESENTING CSU STUDENTS
AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MCCARTY MEDINA AFTER
GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
REPRESENT MY CONSTITUENTS AND
THAT'S CRITICAL CONVERSATION.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK OUR
STATE LEADERS AND OUR
INSTITUTIONAL LEADERS FOR
WORKING TO MAKE COLLEGE
AFFORDABLE AND CALIFORNIA.
DESPITE THIS WORK THE REASON
THAT WE ARE HERE TODAY IS
BECAUSE THERE IS STILL A GREAT
PROBLEM IMPACTING OUR STUDENTS.
ONE THAT OUR STATE'S FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM STILL DOES NOT
ADDRESS.
LET ME START BY DESCRIBING THE
PROBLEM AS CSU STUDENTS YET.
LAST YEAR'S CS A SAVER RELEASED
A REPORT WITH TI GUESS WHICH
FOUND THAT ALTHOUGH CSU HAS ONE
OF THE LOWEST TUITIONS IN THE
COUNTRY.
AND WERE NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF
STUDENTS DO NOT PAY TUITION AT
ALL.
MANY ASSUME THAT THE CSU DEGREES
AFFORDABLE.
YET FINANCIALLY NEEDY STUDENTS%
CONTINUE TO FACE VERY REAL
CHALLENGES AFFORDING ALL OF THE
COSTS NECESSARY TO EARN A
COLLEGE DEGREE.
THIS IS REFLECTED IN DEBT
BURDENS THAT FALL MORE HEAVILY
ON UNDER REPRESENTED STUDENTS
AND EXCESSIVE WORK HOURS NEEDED
TO COVER LOW INCOME STUDENTS NOT
COSTS. FOR EXAMPLE EIGHT IN TEN
STUDENTS WHO GRADUATE WITH THAT
HAVE ANNUAL FAMILY INCOMES OF
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS OR
LESS.
AND TWO THIRDS AND ANNUAL FAMILY
INCOMES OF LESS THAN TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
WEEKLY WORK HOURS NEEDED RANGE
FROM TWENTY TO FIFTY FIVE WITH A
MEDIAN OF TWENTY NINE HOURS.
THREE AND FOUR AFRICAN AMERICAN
BACHELOR'S DEGREE RECIPIENTS
GRADUATE WITH STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
NEXT MOST OF YOU IN AS HEARING
ARE AWARE OF THE BASIC NEEDS
CHALLENGES FACING OUR STUDENTS.
TEN POINT 9% OF CSU STUDENTS ARE
HOMELESS.
OVER 40% FACE SOME.
TO SOME FORM OF FOOD INSECURITY.
UNFORTUNATELY NO HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
AVOID THESE ISSUES.
LOW INCOME STUDENTS ACROSS ALL
SEGMENTS STRUGGLE TO FEED
THEMSELVES REGULARLY AND FALL
INTO HOMELESSNESS.
THIS IS A SIGN THAT OUR
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM IS NOT
GIVING ENOUGH TO THE STUDENTS
WHO NEED THE MOST SUPPORT.
OF COURSE MUCH HAS BEEN DONE TO
SUPPORT BASIC NEEDS CHALLENGES
THAT STUDENTS FACE.
CAMPUSES LEADERSHIP STUDENT
LEADERSHIP AND STATE LEADERSHIP
OF ALL STEPPED UP TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES.
BUT WE ALSO BE WORKING TOWARD
THE TIME WHEN NONE OF THIS IS
NECESSARY.
WHEN THE STUDENTS STRUGGLE IS
NOT HOW I FEED MYSELF TODAY BUT
RATHER HOW I GET AN A ON MY MID
TERM?
THERE IS THE RESIDENCE HALL
ADVISER ON MY CAMPUS AT
SACRAMENTO STATE.
SHE SOUGHT OUT THE ROLE AS AN RA
BECAUSE SHE WANTED TO SUPPORT
HER PEERS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAD A WHOLE SOME COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE ONE THAT SHE LONGED
FOR AS WELL.
AND AS AN R. A. HER HOUSING IS
COVERED BY THE UNIVERSITY.
YET SHE STILL HAS TO WORK THREE
JOBS IS THIS DUTIES.
THAT MEANS YES FOR TOTAL JOBS
PLUS SCHOOL AND SHE'S BEING A
ROLE MODEL TO HER PEERS.
SHE'S A COMPLETELY FINANCIALLY
INDEPENDENT WOMAN OF COLOR AND
IS MAKING TREMENDOUS SACRIFICES.
THIS STORY OF HERS MAKES ME ASK
HOW CAN STUDENTS BE SUCCESSFUL
IN THE CLASSROOM IF THEY CANNOT
AFFORD THEIR COLLEGE EXPERIENCE.
OF COURSE RESOURCES TO THE
INSTITUTION ARE NECESSARY FOR
STUDENTS TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND FOR YEARS CSSA.
HAS STOOD ALONGSIDE OR
INSTITUTION AND MAKING THAT CASE
TO YOU ALL.
BUT WITHOUT INVESTMENT INTO
FINANCIAL AID TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES FOR ARE UNDER REPRESENTED
AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
THE INVESTMENT INTO THE
INSTITUTION CAN NEVER BE FULLY
REALIZED.
HERE'S WHAT STUDENTS ALL ACROSS
ALL SEGMENTS OUR LOOKING TO SEE
ACHIEVED WE KNOW IT'S A BOLD
GOAL.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT OUR STATE
LEADERS AND DON'T SHY AWAY FROM
BOLD OPPORTUNITIES.
SO FIRST IF A STUDENT HAS AN
ECONOMIC NEED AND GETS ACCEPTED
INTO COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA WE
NEED TO REDUCE AND REMOVE
BARRIERS SO THAT THEY CAN
RECEIVE STATE AID.
SECOND AS THE TEARS HAVE
MENTIONED WE NEED TO DO MORE TO
COVER THE NON TUITION COSTS
FACING OUR STUDENTS FOOD HOUSING
BOOKS TRANSPORTATION.
THIRD STUDENTS WHO WANT TO
GRADUATE QUICKER BY ATTENDING
SUMMER COURSES SHOULD ACCESS TO
STATE AID TO MAKE THAT A
REALISTIC POSSIBILITY FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS.
FOURTH WHILE WE WORK TO FIX
FINANCIAL AID BASIC ME THE
NATIONAL NEED TO BE FUNDED AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
I WOULD LIKE TO AND MY COMMENTS
WITH IT A SHORT ANECDOTE.
WHEN STUDENT LEADERS SOME
STANDING SITTING WITH ME TODAY
FROM CALIFORNIA JOINS OTHER
STUDENT LEADERS FROM NEW YORK
AND FLORIDA? TO ADVOCATE IN
WASHINGTON DC WE TALKED WITH
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT FINANCIAL
AID IN AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES
IN OUR STATE AND ACROSS OUR
NATION.
AND AND ONE OF THEM OUR MEETINGS
A CONGRESSMAN ASKED WHY IS THIS
HAPPENING WISE IT'S
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS HAPPENING
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AT THE TIME IT WAS HARD TO
GIVE HIM AN ANSWER WHY.
BUT I THINK I CAN ANSWER THAT
TODAY.
IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE DONE THE
NECESSARY JOB OF GETTING MORE
STUDENTS PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
STUDENTS TO ENROLL IN COLLEGE.
ADDITIONALLY TODAY AND HAS NEVER
BEEN MORE EXPENSIVE TO LIVE IN
OUR STATE.
AND LASTLY THE PALO WORD HAS
NEVER HAD A LOWER PURCHASING
POWER.
THIS MEANS THAT WHILE THE STATE
STILL DOES A GREAT JOB ON
TUITION STUDENTS ARE DROWNING IN
NON TUITION COSTS WITH VERY FEW
LIFERAFTS.
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL ON PAL BUT WE KNOW
WHEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TAKES A STEP BACK.
ARE CALIFORNIA LEADERS TAKE A
STEP FORWARD.
WE ARE ASKING YOU TO TAKE THE
STEPS TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
DANNY [inaudible]
Q..
MORNING JOHN MEDINA AND MCCARTY
UP MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE.
MY NAME IS DANNY FEARFUL AND I
SERVE AS LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR FOR REGION TO FOR THIS
IN SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND TODAY AT THE HONOR TALKING
ABOUT MY JOURNEY TARGET
EDUCATION AND THROUGH IT.
AS WELL AS THE IMPACT
FINANCIALLY IT HAS HAD ON ME.
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL?
I ALWAYS THOUGHT I WOULD END UP
LIKE WHAT I SAW ON TV I WOULD BE
THIS TEEN THAT WOULD HAVE GOOD
GRADES.
GO OFF TO COLLEGE AND MOVED OUT
OF MY PARENTS HOUSE BY.
EIGHTEEN AND FOR THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS I WAS IT WAS GOING TO BE
AMAZING.
I WOULD BE LIVING IN A DORM TAKE
PART IN STERN ORGANIZATIONS.
AND ONLY HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
GETTING MY EDUCATION DONE.
SO I CAN FIND A FULL TIME JOB
LATER IN A CAREER THAT I WANTED.
AND BEING IN LOW INCOME STUDENTS
I THOUGHT KNOW DAT.
MY TUITION IS GOING TO BE PAID.
FOR I'D BE GETTING A LOT OF
SCHOLARSHIPS BECAUSE OF THE
EXTRA CURRICULAR ACTIVITIES AND
HAVING HIGH GPA.
I MY FINANCIAL AID WOULD COVER
MY TEXTBOOKS FOOD AND HOUSING.
AND MY FAMILY WOULD BE STRESS
FREE.
I SHOULD HAVE KNOWN BETTER THAN.
TO BELIEVE WHAT I SAW ON TV.
I I WAS ALWAYS.
TAUGHT THOUGH IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
I WAS BEING PREPARED FOR THAT
EXPECTATION THOUGH.
AND THE REALITY IT IS NOT.
WHAT IT IS?
I COULD NOT MOVE OUT.
I STILL OF THE PARENTS AND I'M.
TWENTY ONE IS MY THIRD YEAR AT A
COMMUNICATIVE.
AND WORK PART TIME.
HEY PAY BILLS WHEN I CAN.
TAKING CLASSES.
SOME DAYS I DO GO HUNGRY.
OTHER DAYS I USE MY CREDIT CARD
TO EAT BUT NOT AFTER CHECKING MY
BANK ACCOUNT EVERY SINGLE TIME
TO MAKE SURE THAT I DON'T GET
THE CLIENT AT THE CASH REGISTER.
AND THEN.
I DON'T HAVE A CAR SO I HAVE TO
USE PUBLIC TRANSIT.
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT RELIABLE OR
SOMETIMES THE WEATHER MAY NOT
ALLOW ME TO TRAVEL SO LONG.
OUTDOORS AND HAVE TO RELY ON
RIGHT SERVICE HERE RIGHT SERVICE
APPS. TO GET FROM ONE PLACE TO
ANOTHER OTHERWISE I'D BE
DRENCHED AND MY SCHOOL WORK
WOULD BE DAMAGED.
MY FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE GIVES
ME ENOUGH TO COVER TUITION
TEXTBOOKS AND SUPPLIES AND SOME
MEALS.
BUT I WOULD STRUGGLE TO BALANCE
MY JOB WITH MY ACADEMICS.
MY NEEDS WITH MY
RESPONSIBILITIES AT HOME.
AND MY HUNGER WITH MY DEBT OVER
THE NEXT THREE MONTHS FOR THE
SEMESTER UNTIL THE NEXT MISTER
COMES.
BEING FIRST GENERATION AMERICAN
AND FIRST GENERATION OF MY
FAMILY TO GO TO COLLEGE.
IT IS MY DUTY TO BE TRIUMPHANT.
TO FACE ADVERSITY HEAD ON AND
NOT ALLOW ANYTHING TO STOP ME
AND I WILL I WILL GET MY DEGREE.
AND I WILL ENCOURAGE AT LEAST
AMOUNT POSSIBLE.
AND O. MOVE OUT WITH MY AT MY
PARENTS HOUSE EVENTUALLY.
BUT IT SHOULDN'T BE THIS
DIFFICULT.
SINCE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO STRUGGLE
TO EAT.
STRUGGLE TO FIND HOUSING.
STRUGGLE TO BALANCE A JOB WITH
ACADEMICS.
AND SIMPLE FIX ITS FINANCIAL AID
FORM.
WE NEED TO INCREASE A SET
ACCESSIBILITY.
AND THE INCREASING THE AMOUNT.
THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT
WITH INCREASED EIGHT STUDENTS
WILL BE ABLE TO FOCUS BETTER ON
THE EDUCATION.
I KNOW I WOULD.
ANCHORED YOU TO THE RIGHT BY THE
NEXT GENERATION AND THAT WILL
LEAD OUR STATE AND OUR NATION.
TO FIX FINANCIAL AID IS A BETTER
FUTURE CAN BE MADE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NATHAN.
MORNING THREE CHAIRS MEMBERS OF
STAFF MY NAME IS MAKING ANY IS
AND I'M A STUDENT FROM PACIFIC
UNIVERSITY THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO MY TESTIMONY TODAY.
I BELIEVE ALL STUDENTS WHERE
THEY TEND CALIFORNIA'S
EXCEPTIONAL STATE COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES OR ARE DIVERSE
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT COLLEGES.
AND UNIVERSITIES SHOULD BE
TREATED EQUITABLY AND INCLUDING
FINANCIAL REFORM CONVERSATIONS.
FROM A YOUNG AGE REPAIR SURE TO
MEET IMPORTANCE OF A COLLEGE
EDUCATION. FOR THEM CALLS REALLY
TALK ABOUT.
AND SEE FINANCING IMPOSSIBLE FOR
BOTH HISPANIC NEED AMERICAN
PERSPECTIVE.
A LACK OF RESOURCES WILL SUPPORT
FOR TO PUT THE IDEA OF COLLEGE
HOW MUCH FURTHER OUT OF REACH.
THE HARD WORKING TERMINATION MY
PARENTS WERE ABLE TO OVERCOME
THESE BOUNDARIES AND HOW
ADOPTING TO PURSUE A COLLEGE
DEGREE.
MY MOM ATTENDED UNIVERSAL --
AND WE'RE SURE IN YOUR BASS IS A
MASTER'S DEGREE ON MY DAD HAD
THE CHOICE STUDY JOURNALISM AT
UNIVERSITIES AND CALIFORNIA. FOR
MY FOR MY MOM FORTY COLLEGE
MEANT MULTIPLE JOB THE TIME AWAY
FROM TO THE BORN SON.
SINCE SHE WAS ALREADY TO TWENTY
EIGHT SHE WAS KNOWLEDGEABLE FOR
MANY SCHOLARSHIPS AND GRANTS
WHICH IS THE STATE FUNDED CAL
GRANT. TO PAY FOR COLLEGE
GENERAL CHOICE EXCEPT A LARGE
NUMBER STUDENT LOANS.
ALTHOUGH THE FINANCIAL BURDEN
WITH SUBSTANTIAL THE UNIVERSITY
WILL BURN WITH CLOSE ENOUGH TO
HOME TO LOWER TO CARE FOR
NEWBORN SON.
WHILE OFFERING THE RIGHT PROGRAM
THE FRIED EGG FLEXIBLE CLASS
SCHEDULES.
GOOD CHARACTER DETERMINATION AND
PERSISTENCE OPEN MANY DOORS MY
PARENTS.
DRUG GRADE SCHOOL I WAS
MOTIVATED TO ATTEND COLLEGE AND
MOTIVATION FUEL BY STORIES MY
PARENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO EARN A
COLLEGE DEGREE.
HOWEVER THE PROCESS LIKE FOR
MANY WAS NOT EASY WITH MY
PARENTS DIVORCE AND NUMEROUS
FINANCE ROADBLOCKS ON THE WAY.
ADVANCE MY SENIOR YEAR IT WAS
APPARENT SCHOLARSHIPS GRANTS.
FOR STUDENT LOANS WERE NEEDED TO
PAY FOR COLLEGE AS A FINANCIAL
BURDEN ON MY PARENTS TO BE TOO
HEAVY.
FORTUNATELY I QUALIFIED FOR THE
CAL GRANT WHICH CONSIDERABLY
LOWER THE COST OF COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE AND ALLOW FOR
CONSIDERATION A PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES OFFER SMALL CLASS
SIZES.
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIPS AND FOR
ME A CHRISTIAN EDUCATION.
I CHOSE THIS PACIFIC UNIVERSITY
RECORD SANTA HOMETOWN OF THIS IS
A PURSUE MY PASSIONS LOOKING
BACK TO MY COMMUNITY.
SPARKED BY SHOULDER INJURY
DURING MY DURING HIGH SCHOOL.
I FELT DESIRE TO HELP OTHERS TO
FORM A PHYSICAL REHABILITATION.
AB IS KINESIOLOGY PROGRAM OFFERS
SMALL CLASS SIZES AND
APPROACHABLE PROFESSORS.
THAT COMPLEMENT MY LEARNING
STYLE.
THE CAL GRANT AS LONG YOU PURSUE
A CAREER IN OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
AND UNIVERSITY THE BEST FITS ME.
ATTENDING IF YOU HAS OPENED
DOORS THAT WOULD NEVER IMAGINED
POSSIBLE.
STARTING AS IDEA OF MY FORMER
CAMPUS PROFESSOR I CO CREATE A
CAMPAIGN CALLED FLY START
FREEZES.
THIS CAMPAIGN EVENTUALLY EVOLVED
INTO COMMITTEE PROJECT CALLED
THE CAN CITY ENVIRONMENTS
PROJECT.
AIMS PROMOTE HEALTHY AND GREEN
COMMUNITY.
AND STARTING A CITY WIDE
MOVEMENT FOR VIOLENCE AWARENESS
AND COMMUNITY ACTION
[inaudible]
I ALSO CREATE MORE SUSTAINABLE
CAMPUS.%
NOT ONLY THESE VALUABLE
EXPERIENCE PREPARE ME FOR FUTURE
OR OF CONTRIBUTION TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY COMMUNITIES.
BUT THE ALLOW ME TO SUPPORT ON
AN UPLIFT MY DATE AMERICAN
BROTHERS AND SISTERS.
BEING PART A NATIVE AMERICAN
MANY PARTIES REALITY.
AND MANY ARE NOT ABLE TO ATTEND
COLLEGE OR EXPERIENCE
OPPORTUNITY SUCH IT IS IN THE
STATE CAPITAL.
THE CALTRAIN UNDERTAKE FUNNY
HOWEVER CAN OPEN MANY CLOSED
DOORS FOR NATIVE COMMUNITY.
RAISING A CAL GRANT TWENTY
FORMULA ONE SURE FINANCIALLY
STABILITY AND PREDICTABILITY FOR
STUDENTS LIKE ME.
MY STORIES IS ONE OF MANY.
THERE ARE TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
OUR STUDENTS WITH STORIES LIKE
MINE WHO ATTEND CALIFORNIA'S
INDEPENDENT CALLS UNIVERSITIES.
YOU FOR LISTENING TO MY STORY
FOR INVESTMENT CAL GRANT OF FOR
BELIEVING STUDENTS LIKE ME AS IS
PACIFIC.
AND OTHER INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT
VERSUS ACROSS STATE THANK YOU.
GIVE.
I HAVE A AND THANK THE PANEL
HANK THE STUDENTS --
THANK YOU FOR COMING BACK
[inaudible]
OUR MAYBE A QUICK QUESTION --
CAROLINE TO THE WITH THE
DREAMERS STUDENTS FILL OUT
INSTEAD OF THE FASTER.
I I I ATTENDED --
ARLINGTON HIGH SCHOOL THIS
WEEKEND WERE STUDENTS WERE
FILLING OUT BOTH OF HIS A CASH
FOR COLLEGE OF PROGRAM.
AND I SAW SOME STUDENTS FILLING
OUT FAST.
FOR AND I SAW DREAMERS FILLING
OUT THE DREAMERS [inaudible]
CAN.
CAN YOU CAN YOU TELL ME MORE
ABOUT WITH WITH THERE ARE
FILLING OUT WHEN THEY'RE FILLING
THAT OUT.
ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH IT.
I AM NOT FAMILIAR ENOUGH WITH
THE FORM ITSELF I DO KNOW THAT
FOREIGN DOCUMENTS DANCER
AUTOMATICALLY.
PUT INTO THE COMPETITIVE C. POOL.
AND IT'S OKAY CAM THAT THE
PERSON FROM --
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
ANSWER.
IS ONE FEDERAL IN ONE STATE.
THAT'S CORRECT SO --
STUDENTS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE IN STATE TUITION --
AB.
FIVE FORTY CAN FILL OUT THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT APPLICATION
WHICH IS THE STATE BASED
APPLICATION THAT REPLICATES THE
FEDERAL APPLICATION THE FACT
THAT AS CLOSE AS POSSIBLE.
AND THAT MAKES THEM ELIGIBLE FOR
STATE AID AND INSTITUTIONAL
FINANCIALLY AS WELL BUT IS NOT A
LITERALLY DON'T FIT RIGHT OKAY
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
NOT NOT THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
NOPE.
WELL.
MAYBE -- YOU
THIS IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU
FOR YOU AND YOU HAVE LOTS OF
STUDENTS BEHIND YOU AND WE'RE
GONNA HEAR FROM PUBLIC TESTIMONY
IN A MINUTE [inaudible]
ANY ANY [inaudible]
INCLUDING SUGGESTIONS TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
OF WE HEARD FROM YOU --
OBSTACLES THAT WE CAN TAKE OUT
OF THE WAY WHAT ELSE WOULD YOU
LIKE.
TO LEAVE WITH US.
YOU KNOW I I THINK WHAT ALL THE
STUDENTS HAVE MENTIONED WOULD BE
HELPFUL SOLUTIONS I I THINK THAT --
IN PREVIOUS PANELS THAT WE SAW
TODAY ON LOOKING AT OKAY WELL IF
YOU HAD ONE GO OUT IT WHAT WOULD
YOU DO WITH ONE PART OF MONEY.
TO ME I THINK.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT LED US TO
THIS PROBLEM AS THAT WE'VE YOU
KNOW SEEN SOLUTIONS COME IN BITS
AND PIECES.
AND I THINK REALLY WHAT OUR
STUDENTS NEED TODAY IS A PACKAGE
THE NEED TO SEE A PLAN.
THEY NEED TO SEE YOU KNOW IF
IT'S TODAY IF IT'S LONG TERM
WHATEVER IT IS I THINK SEEING A
PLAN OF HOW THESE SOLUTIONS CAN
BE CREATED OVER TIME.
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY THE
PIGEON HOME --
ANY BUDGETS OR ARE PUT OTHERS --
AND UNCOMFORTABLE POSITIONS BY
MAKING GIVING US TIME TO CREATE
A PLAN AND I THINK THAT'S
EXTREMELY NECESSARY NOT SAYING
OKAY WILL WANT WHAT IS THE ONLY
OR ONE THING THAT COULD BE
FEASIBLE.
I THINK ALL OF THESE SOLUTIONS
THAT WE'RE PROVIDING.
CAN BE FEASIBLE AND WE CAN BE
CREATIVE AROUND THAT AND I THINK
ALL OF US STUDENTS ARE REALLY
INTERESTED IN BEING A PART OF
THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
AND HELPING CREATE A PLAN THAT
CAN HELP LONG TERM FOR OUR
STUDENTS THINK BUT I WILL.
RESPECT GO BACK SO WE DO ADOPT A
PLAN IT'S A MULTI YEAR.
PLAN AND WE CAN PHASE IN CERTAIN
ELEMENTS WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT
IS IT TO HELP YOU IN YOUR
COLLEAGUES.
GRADUATE WITH LESS DEBT --
HELP YOUR LITTLE NEPHEWS AND
BROTHERS AND COUSINS GET IN.
AND GET A GREAT THE FIRST PLACE
TO GO OUT TO GET THAT SO WE HAVE.%
TO BALANCE THOSE COMPETING NEEDS
AND AS A STUDENT LEADER YOU'RE
YOU'RE ONE OF FOUR POUND THE
PANEL BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK WE
SHOULD START.
I THINK THAT SAID THAT'S A TOUGH
QUESTION TO ANSWER AND THAT'S
WHY I WAS YOU KNOW KIND OF
THINKING ONE OTHER PANELISTS
WOULD ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
THAT I THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A
HOLISTIC CONVERSATION MORE SO
ABOUT --
WHERE THE NEEDS ARE WHICH WE'VE
DESCRIBED IN ALSO WHEN THOSE
SOLUTIONS CAN BE MADE --
I KNOW THAT SOME MIGHT BE EASIER
TO MAKE SOME MIGHT BE QUICKER
FIXES THAN OTHERS IF IT'S YOU
KNOW FUNDING BASIC NEEDS REQUEST
THAT AND INSTITUTIONAL LEVEL FOR
NOW AND WORKING ON A MORE LONG
TERM STRATEGY MOVING FORWARD I
KNOW THE CSU.
ONLY HAS A ONE TIME --
FUNDING REQUEST FOR BASIC NEEDS
LOOKING OUT WHAT THAT COULD LOOK
LIKE LONG TERM WILL HELP IN
DIFFERENT WAYS AND YOU KNOW WHEN
THERE'S DIFFERENT ISSUES OF
ACCESS AND THEN ALSO THE BASIC
NEEDS.
COMPONENT --
AND GRADUATING WITH THAT THOSE
ARE THREE ISSUES THAT ARE KIND
OF MOVING IN DIFFERENT AREAS AND
HAVE DIFFERENT --
IMPACTS OF WHAT'S CAUSING THEM.
SO -- I
WOULD SAY.
WE SHOULD LOOK AT PRIORITIES AND
I THINK ALL FOR OF BEES --
ITEMS THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE
BRINGING FORWARD SHOULD BE
PRIORITIES --
AND SEEMED KIND OF HOW WHAT
YOU'RE LEADERSHIP SAYS ON WHAT
WE CAN DO FIRST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WHAT TYPE BEFORE WE GET THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS WHEN I SAY THANK
YOU FOR THE STUDENT PANEL YOU
KNOW WE ALWAYS HAVE THE STUDENT
PANEL -- AT
THE END FOR SOME REASON AND HE
SAID.
FLIP IT SO WE CAN HAVE MORE OF
OUR MEMBERSHEARING FROM THAT
THE STUDENTS AND YOU KNOW.
YOU HAVE THAT.
THE REALISTIC --
UNDERSTANDING OF AND HOW A
MINIMUM WAGE JOB DOESN'T GO AS
FAR TO COVER THE BASICS LIKE IT
DID THIRTY YEARS AGO AND HOUSING
COSTS ARE JUST NIGHT AND DAY.
SO WE WANT TO MODERNIZE OUR
COLLEGE FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM AND
GET TOWARDS A GOAL OVER CAN HAVE
DEBT FREE COLLEGE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CERTAINLY.
THE GOAL BUT REALIZING THAT YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO MAKE COLLEGE.
MORE AFFORDABLE FOR THE CURRENT
STUDENTS THAT WE ALL SEE MORE
PEOPLE GOING TO CALLS FOR OUR
ECONOMY SO I THINK THIS HELPS.
PUT IT ALL TOGETHER SO THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD OKAY SO SO WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO GO --
TO PUBLIC PUBLIC COMMENT NOW
[inaudible]
AND YOU CAN ASK OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT PARTICIPANTS TO KEEP
THEIR COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE --
LAST. ONE METER LAST WE HAVE A
BIG LINE AND WE HAVE TO HAVE TO
GO AND IN SOME OF US HAVE A GOOD
ARE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN A
LITTLE BIT --
BUT I BELIEVE MISTER --
IMPLEMENTING GOV --
MINUTE OR LESS AND IF YOU CAN.
TACK ON TO SOMEBODY ALSO BE
GREAT WE WE DO HAVE TO GO TO A
CAUCUS DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN A
FEW MOMENTS PRESENT ON THE
BUDGET.
INCLUDING THIS SAME TALK IT
TOPIC ABOUT.
A COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY SO KEEP
THAT IN MIND THANK YOU PLEASE BE
A GOOD THANK YOU MY NAME'S KEVIN
AS THEY ARE WITH THE COALITION.
OF CALIFORNIA ROUGH RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND I'M HERE OF
REGARDING FOOD STAMPS.
BILLS OF THE THIS WIDESPREAD
HUNGER IN MANY COLLEGES SPECIAL
COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
AND ONE OF THE THIS THE ONE OF
THE WAYS STEP FOLKS.
OF STUDENTS COULD GET CAL FRESH
A FOOD STAMPS IS IF THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR CAL GRANT.
AXIS BE IF THE CALPERS HOOKED
HEALTH FIRST ACCESS BE IS THE
DEATH DONE ASSISTANCE PAYMENT
RATHER THAN AN ASSISTANT PAYMENT.
IT'S KIND OF TECHNICAL BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS IF YOU MAKE A
LITTLE CHANGE IN THE CAR.
CAL GRANT SYSTEM A HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS WOULD BE ABLE
TO GET FOOD STAMPS.
URGENT TO CONSIDER THIS A WOULD
BE GLAD TO WORK WITH YOUR STAFF
FOR ANYBODY. TO MAKE SURE THAT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS COULD
GET FOOD STAMPS AND CALIFORNIA
AND WITH THIS HUNGER IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU GEN I'M IN
MY THIRD YEAR OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE PLUS --
ONE I A AS A MEMBER OF MY SCHOOL
STUDENT LEADERSHIP I OFTEN TAKE
THE ROLE OF MENTORING AND
GUIDING STUDENTS TO THE
COMPLEXITIES OF THE COLLEGE
SYSTEM.
OFTENTIMES BEING FINANCIAL AID --
IN TIME AND TIME AGAIN I GET THE
SAME CIRCUMSTANCE WHICH IS
STUDENTS ASKING.
DO I CONTINUE MY CALL PURSUIT OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IN MY GOALS
WARD TO I DROP OR LESSEN MY
COURSE LOAD SO THAT I CAN
MAINTAIN A PART TIME OR FULL
TIME JOB.
SO THAT THEY CAN PAY RENTS THE
BILL'S PROVIDE FOR MY FAMILY OR
SIMPLY MAINTAIN MORE FINANCIALLY
VIABLE LIFESTYLE --
THIS IS AN EXTREMELY COMMON
CIRCUMSTANCE AT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM THESE DAYS --
WITH THE LIMITS INSTRUCTOR
RESTRICTIONS ON WHO CAN QUALIFY
FOR SUBSTANTIAL FINANCIAL AID.
ARE STATES AT RISK STUDENTS MUST
TAKE THIS DECISION EXTREMELY
[inaudible]
IMPORTANTLY --
THREE ECHO DISCREETLY VITAL FOR
THE CORE OF OUR A FORWARD
MOBILITY IN CALIFORNIA AND SO IS
HAVING A VERSATILE AND DYNAMIC.
APPROACH TO FINANCIAL AID ONE
THAT TAKES A HOLISTIC APPROACH
TOWARDS THE FULL STUDENT
EXPERIMENT TO STOP YOU YOU'RE
MINUTE IS UP AND I'M GONNA
REMIND SPEAKERS THAT YOU WE WE
DID SAY AT THE BEGINNING THAT
YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING HONORING CANISTER
IN A SECOND IN A CITY COLLEGE
ASSIGNMENT INDEPENDENCE SEDAN
WITH NO FAMILY IN UNITED STATES
ANY TO WORK TWO JOBS TO MEET
BASIC NEEDS --
FINANCIAL AID IN STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVEL HAS NOT KEEP UP
WITH THE RACING BECAUSE NATIONAL
WIDE BUT IT'S IF IT'S IF THE
CIVIC LEE HAS IMPACTED INSIDE
CALIFORNIA.
AS A SERVER SO WE'RE SEEING --
FOOD INSECURITY AND LEGISLATION
THAT ALLOW STUDENTS TO LEAVE IN
THE CAR AND ALL THEIR SIDE.
SOLUTIONS EVERYTHING HAS
DIFFERENT NEEDS BY INCREASING
THE FINANCIAL AID IS STUDENTS
WILL BE ABLE TO ALLOCATE THE MY
BEING IN HISTORICALLY THESE
PROPORTIONAL.
IMPACT TO STUDENTS.
EVE YOU BASED FINANCIAL AID ON
GPA THAT WILL IMPACT PRIMARILY
STUDENTS THAT ALREADY HAVE
OBSTACLES LIKE FULL TIME
STUDENTS A SINGLE MOTHER
STUDENTS.
OR SIMPLICITY AND I HAVE NOT HAD
ENOUGH RESOURCES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND CREATE IN AN
ENDLESS LOOP THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I THE GREETINGS MY NAME'S ASIA
BLOSSOMS TODAY AS SACRAMENTO
CITY COLLEGE [inaudible]
AND STARTING COLLEGE BACK IN
FALL OF TWENTY SIXTEEN FINALLY --
I CAME TO THE REALIZATION OF
WHAT IT MEANS TO BE AN ADULT --
WHAT IT MEANS FROM MONTH TO SAY
NO ASIAN YOU CAN HAVE THAT
BECAUSE WE NEED THIS?
LEARNING TO PRIORITIZE WHAT I
WANT WHAT I NEED VERSUS WHAT I
WANT CAME INTO THE REALIZATION
BALANCING MY COLLEGE WORKLOAD OF
FORTY HOURS. FORTY HOURS A WEEK
AND THEN.
FULL TIME STUDENT AT COLLEGES
NOT NOT THE EASIEST THING TO OF
TO MANAGE SOMETIMES AND
SOMETIMES GOING IN THE TELL IS
THE BEST CHOICE BUT IS NOT THE
BEST REYES BUT IS THE CHOICE
THAT YOU WANT BUT YOU.
SHOULD NOT DO --
ID THE FAST A. FOR ME PERSONALLY
THE DANGLE UP. FOR ENOUGH FOR ME
TO FINANCIALLY SUPPORT MYSELF
AND HELP MY PARENTS --
WITH RENT.
AND EVERYTHING THAT COMES WITH
BEING AN ADULT --
AND WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE YOU
GUYS TO TAKE IN CONSIDERATION
THAT INVESTMENT IN.
EDUCATION IS INVESTMENT NOT ONLY
FOR THE STUDENT BUT INVESTMENT
FOR CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEDINA
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
CONSULTANTS MANY RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION TRUST
WEST.
WE APPRECIATE IT IS CONVERSATION
WHICH RECOGNIZES THAT OUR
CURRENT FINANCIALLY SYSTEM IS
NOT ALIGNED WITH THE NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS.
AND HE'S BE MODERNIZE WITH A
FOCUS ON EQUITY.
THE EDUCATION TRUST WAS SUPPORT
FINANCIALLY REFORM THAT WILL
REMOVE ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
INCREASE EIGHT TO FIND MORE NON
TUITION COSTS AND EXPAND ACCESS
TO OUR CAL GRANT.
PROGRAMS GIVEN THAT WELL OVER
HALF WERE CAPABLE STUDENTS ARE
LOW INCOME OR STATE MUST
CONTINUE TO DESIGN POLICIES THAT
INCREASE COLLEGE ACCESS. ONE WAY
WE CAN DO THIS IS BY HAVING MORE
OF OUR LAST YEAR WE MAY
THIRTIETH IN THE NATION AND FAST
COMPLETION AND ONLY 53% OF OUR
GRADUATING SENIORS COMPLETED
THESE APPLICATIONS.
CALIFORNIA CAN AND MUST DO MORE
TO FIX OUR FINANCIALLY SYSTEM.
AND WE STAND READY TO HELP YOU
IN ANY WAY POSSIBLE THANK THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS AN
EDITOR THAT'S THE END OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF STUDENT
SERVICES IT'S KIND OF COLLEGE
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CHIEF
STUDENT SERVICES OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
ULTIMATELY WE'RE HERE BECAUSE WE
WANT TO SUPPORT THE FINANCIAL
AID TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS SHOULD IN FACT PUT THEM
IN CONTROL AND IN THE DRIVER
SEAT OF THEIR EDUCATION.
MANY OF US IN THIS ROOM HAVE
BENEFITTED FROM THE FACT THAT
BECAUSE WE'VE EARNED OUR COLLEGE
DEGREE THERE'S NO VALUE JUDGMENT
THAT WE VALUE EDUCATION THAT WE
HAVE HARD WORK ETHIC OR THAT WE
WANT TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
SOCIETY INTO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WANT
THAT EXACT SAME OPPORTUNITY THEY
WANT THE OPPORTUNITY TO PERSIST
AND THEREFORE THE FINANCIAL AID
REFORM ADDRESSING THE CAL GRANT
ALLOWING THEM --
THE ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS TO
GIVE THEM A CHANCE TO PERSIST
FROM TERM DETERMINE THAT FIRST
YEAR GIVEN THE CHANCE TO
EXPERIENCE SUCCESS AND SHOW HOW
THEY CAN CONTRIBUTE. TO THE
SOCIAL MOBILITY THAT THERE ARE
DESERVING OF AND TO THE WORK
FORCE THAT THE STATE NEEDS IS
PRECISELY THE FINANCIAL AID
REFORM THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
SUPPORT.
THE CHIEF STUDENT SERVICES
OFFICES ARE HERE FOR STUDENTS
AND WE'RE READY TO STAND AND
WORK WITH YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
I THANK YOU ARE MY NAME IS ROY
THAT CORN AND THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCIAL AID FOR LOS RIOS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT --
SOME OF THE CONVERSATIONS TODAY
TOOK PLACE THAT I WAS ASKED WHAT
WOULD YOU DO IF YOU HAD A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS BUT IN
PRIVATE HOW WOULD YOU PRIORITIZE
AT AND I THINK THE ANSWER TO
THAT IS WE HAVE.
TO PRIORITIZE ON EQUITY BASIS
AND THEREFORE I I WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB TWO
NINETY ONE WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
MORE SUPPORT FOR THE CUP
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MANY FULLER AND THE ASSISTANT
FINANCIAL AID OFFICER AT FOLSOM
LAKE COLLEGE IN FOR TEN YEARS
I'VE BEEN HAVING TO LOOK AT
STUDENTS.
THAT ARE MOSTLY INDEPENDENT THEY
HAVE AN INCOME RANGE ABOUT
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE THEY'RE
WORKING THEY MIGHT NOT HAVE ANY
FAMILY AND THEY JUST DON'T
QUALIFY FOR ANYTHING BUT THE FEE
WAIVER.
THAT'S ALL THERE TUITION SIDE TO
LOOK AT THEM AND SAY SORRY STAY
IN SCHOOL DON'T GIVE UP.
I'M SORRY THERE'S NO AID FOR YOU.
SO THEY ARE FALLING IN THE RANGE
FOR THEIR ESC THERE'S JUST HIGH
ENOUGH FOR THERE'S NO PELL
GRANTS.
THERE'S NO CAL GRANT AND THERE'S
NO HELP AND SO THEY HAVE TO WORK.
SO THEY CAN'T GO THEY CAN'T STAY
I'M GO TO SCHOOL FULL TIME AND I
ALSO DO THE FEDERAL AND SEC
STUDENT WORK PROGRAM AT OUR
COLLEGE.
AND THEY CAN'T DO THAT THEY
CAN'T DO WORKS IT BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T AFFORD IT IT'S ONLY TWELVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR NOW SO THEY
CAN'T.
WORK IN CAMPUS THEY DON'T WANT
TO DO LOANS BUT THE BILL THAT
YOU GUYS ARE PROPOSING FOR THAT
GROUP OF STUDENTS.
THEY NEED IT AND THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEDINA
MEMBERS OF THANK YOU --
FOR FACILITATING THIS
CONVERSATION LOOKING AT A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL OUR STUDENTS
OBJECT RENDERING WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
BUT HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
PRIORITIES THAT THE CALIFORNIA
UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER EDUCATION
COALITION.
HAS PUT FORTH FOR FINANCIAL AID
WE HAVE SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
ESTIMATED UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN OUR INSTITUTIONS
THEY FACE A MORE ACUTE.
OF FINANCIAL NEED GAP DUE TO
THEIR IN ELIGIBILITY FOR FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID AS WELL THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT THAT WAS
DISCUSSED --
BY PANELISTS AS A RESULT THEY
FACE AN ADDITIONAL SEVENTY FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS TO NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLAR COSTS --
RELATIVE TO THEIR PEERS WHO
QUALIFY FOR THOSE OTHER FORMS OF
AID WHICH IS WHY ARE COALITION --
MANY ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE HEARING
HERE TODAY --
REALLY ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO EXPLORE HOW WE CAN MAKE THEM
ELIGIBLE FOR ALL FORMS OF STATE
AID AS WELL AS CREATE A SERVICE
AND SENATE GRANT PROGRAM TO PUT
SOME MONEY IN THEIR POCKET.
AND GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GAIN PROFESSIONAL SKILLS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN IN A AN
HONORABLE MEMBER COMMITTEES
THIRTY WAS ELECTED TO GO DOWN
NOW I AM A NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENT FROM EAST AUSTIN COLLEGE
AND I ALSO GRADUATE FROM LOS AND
JUST HARPER COLLEGE --
SO JUST QUICKLY VERY QUICKLY IN
RESPONSE SOMETHING THAT I DID
HERE TODAY I DID WANT TO SAY AND
I WANT TO MAKE MENTION TO YOU
ALL YOU GUYS TO KNOW THE AVERAGE
WAGE FOR A DISHWASHER RIGHT NOW
IS ACTUALLY TWELVE DOLLARS AND
NINETY CENTS.
SO IN MY EARLY YEARS A COLLEGE I
ACTUALLY WORKED AS A MAID AS A
HOSTESS AS A MATTER OF AN ICE
CREAM SHOP GET I STILL GONNA FOR
COLLEGE AND TO THIS DAY I STILL
CANNOT AFFORD IT.
SO AS A STERN ORGANIZER FOR RICE
CALIFORNIA.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT YOU ALL
KNOW THAT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO NINE ONE TWO NINE ONE AND
AB.
TWO SO WE REPRESENT CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE.
OUR STATE CIVIC AND ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY DEPENDS ON INVESTING
MUCH MORE IN STUDENT SUCCESS.
SO SB TWO NINE ONE IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP.
TOWARD FOR FILLING CALIFORNIA'S
PROMISED TO STUDENTS AND WE
SUPPORT ALLEGE EFFORTS TO EXPAND
FINANCIAL AID AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY IN THE CSU
SYSTEM.
SO WE HOPE YOU TAKE THE YARN TO
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS VALERIE JOHNSON
I'M A STUDENT FROM CRAFTON HILLS
COLLEGE --
I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE AND MISTER
CHAIR -- ON
BEHALF OF RICE CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS FIGHTING FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTAIN A FULLY
FUNDED HIGHER EDUCATION.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SERVE THE LARGEST
POPULATION OF STUDENTS IN THE
STATE OVER TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS AND THIS IS MORE
STUDENTS THAN BOTH THE UC SYSTEM
AND THE CSU SYSTEM COMBINED.
YET COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
GET THE LEE.
OUT OF ALL THREE SEGMENTS AND
EVEN MORE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
STUDENTS RECEIVE LESS FUNDING
PER STUDENT THAN EVEN K. THROUGH
TWELVE STUDENTS.
SO AS A LOW INCOME STUDENT
MYSELF I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
HOW THIS DIRECTLY AFFECTS OUR
LIVES AND STUDENTS.
THE PROPOSAL TO EXTEND THE
COLLEGE PROMISE PROGRAM IN AB
TWO TO INCLUDE TWO YEARS OF FREE
TUITION AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS
A BIG STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AND WE WANT TO SHARE OUR SUPPORT
FOR A BI TO AND I PERSONALLY
HAVE HAD TO WORK UPWARDS OF
THIRTY HOURS FOR WE GOT SOME
POINTS IN MY EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY
TO BE OF ABLE TO AFFORD
TEXTBOOKS AND OUTSIDE TUITION
COSTS -- AND
WHERE I COME FROM IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE.
UP WE HAVE ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
LOWEST COLLEGE GOING RATES IN
THE STATE AND WE'RE WORKING HARD
BUT MANY OF US JUST CAN'T AFFORD
TO GO TO COLLEGE.
IT MIGHT OF WORK TO SPEND TIME
WASHING DISHES ARE BUSSING
TABLES WHEN SOME FOLKS WERE IN
COLLEGE TWENTY PLUS YEARS AGO.
BUT IT DOESN'T EVEN COME CLOSE
TO CUTTING IT NOW WAS STAGNATING
WAGES AND CONSTANTLY RISING
COSTS IS COST OF ATTENDANCE
EXPANDING FINANCIALLY BY
ADDRESSING THE TOTAL COST OF
COLLEGE.
NOT JUST TUITION WILL OPEN THE
DOORS FOR FOLKS WHO MAY HAVE
NEVER CONSIDERED COLLEGE TO BE
AN OPTION IN THE PAST.
SO YOU THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS RIOS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT WE'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE EFFORTS
TAKEN. TO ADDRESS THE PRINCIPLES
OF PROVIDING STUDENT FINANCIAL
AID -- WE'D
ALSO LIKE TO YOU KNOW EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION FOR THE
LEGISLATION CARRY BY THE
CHAIRMAN AS WELL AS THE OTHER
MEMBERS AND ON THE SENATE SIDE
AS WELL BY --
SENATOR LEYVA --
AT A RATE THAT THE COSTS OF
FINANCIAL --
THE COSTS OF STUDENT.
ATTENDANCE.
COLLEGES ESPECIALLY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IS MORE THAN JUST
STUDENT FEES AND TUITION IT'S
ALSO HOUSING TEXT BOOKS.
FOOD AND TRANSPORTATION --
AND WE WERE REALLY JUST LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR THE EFFORTS TAKEN --
WITH ME TODAY ARE A COUPLE OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE GOING TO SHARE
WITH YOU THEIR EXPERIENCE WITH
FINANCIAL BURDENS THAT
COMMUNICATE WHICH IS.
THANK YOU A GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE BOARD THANK YOU FOR
GIVING US A HEARING MY NAME IS
MARK SAID NICK OF OUR PRISON AIR
SEA -- I
WORKED THERE AS A STUDENT HELP
AND FINANCIALLY AND A FULL TIME
STUDENT ON PURSUING CIVIL
ENGINEERING --
LITTLE BIT ABOUT ME I'VE DROPPED
OUT OF COLLEGE AND THOUSAND FIVE
IN BECAUSE IT WAS A WORK LOOKS
TOO HARD FOR ME.
AND I TALKED TO MY PARENTS THEY
TOLD ME --
MAYBE COLLEGE IS NOT FOR YOU
MAYBE SHOULD PICK UP A TRADE IN
WORK.
SO IT'S NEVER REALLY ENCOURAGED
TO PURSUE EDUCATION. THOUSAND
SIX NO LONGER LIVE IN THE AREA
ON THE TWO INCOMES.
AT THE TIME I COULD NOT ALSO
RECEIVE ANY FINANCIAL AID
BECAUSE OF MY INCOME BRACKETS
BUT ON THE IN BAY AREA AT THAT A
MATTER -- SO
AS NOT ABLE TO RECEIVE FINANCIAL
AID WORKING AND GOING TO SCHOOL
IN THE EVENINGS WE MOVED OUT
HERE TO SACRAMENTO --
TO FOR ME TO GO TO SCHOOL FULL
TIME.
AND I STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET I GO TO SCHOOL FULL TIME.
I WORK TWELVE DOLLARS AN HOUR
COLLEGE WORK THE WEEKENDS FOR
CASH JUST TO MAKE THE ENDS NEEDS.
SOME --
MONTHS WHEN WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
FOOD STAMPS AND OTHER LOCAL FOOD
BANK.
I HOPE THIS WILL EXPAND.
PROGRAM FOR ME TO FINISH SCHOOL
SUCCESSFULLY THINK EVERY TIME
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TANYA BECAUSE
NOT I AM A STUDENT AT AMERICAN
RIVER COLLEGE AND A STUDENT
WORKER OUT FINANCIAL AID
AMERICAN FOR COLLEGE FOR ABOUT A
YEAR AND A HALF NOW --
MY EXPERIENCE WITH AMERICAN OVER
HUSBAND AMAZING IN PURSUING
EDUCATION HAS BEEN A DREAM OF
MINE FOR A VERY.
SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME SO IT'S A
MUCH MORE PASSIONATE THING FOR
ME AS OF RECENT YEARS BUT I DO
FIND IT HARD TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD COLLEGE I DO WORK AT
AMERICAN RIVER FOR TWELVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR.
AND I'M LIMITED TO TWENTY SIX
HOURS A WEEK SO I DO HAVE TO
TAKE TIME TO TAKE MORE THAN JUST
ONE JOB -- I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF EXPANDING
THINGS PASSED COST OF ATTENDANCE
TO LOOK AT THE FULL PICTURE THAT
THERE ARE THINGS THAT ARE.
PREVENTING US FROM BEING ABLE TO
GO TO SCHOOL MORE BEING ABLE TO
COMPLETE FASTER.
SO I'M GLAD THAT WE'RE TAKING A
REEVALUATION OF THAT AND THANK
YOU.
WHEN I STARTED THIS GOOD
AFTERNOON MY VALLEY KINCAID WITH
PUBLIC ADVOCATES?
AS A FIRST GENERATION LOW INCOME
COLLEGE.
ADD TO IT NOW OF FINANCIAL AID
FINANCIAL AID CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF MY AND MY FAMILY'S
LIFE.
A TO ENSURE ALL STUDENTS PLACED
FURTHEST FROM OPPORTUNITY TO
ACCESS AND SUCCEED IN COLLEGE
OUR FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM MUST
PRIORITIZE STUDENT NEED.
AND COVER THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE BLACK AND BROWN
STUDENTS LOW INCOME FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS.
THEIR SUCCESS AND THE STATE'S
ECONOMY DEPEND ON YOUR BOLD
ACTION.
AND ON FINANCIAL AID AND WE
STAND READY TO ASSIST THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HI AM BARBER BEREN I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EDGE COALITION WHICH
IS A LONG STANDING COALITION OF
BUSINESS LABOR SOCIAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS WORKFORCE
ORGANIZATIONS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND MY MEMBERS ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED THAT BOTH THE EQUITY
AND PROSPERITY OF CALIFORNIA ARE
AT RISK.
BECAUSE OUR FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM
IS NOT KEPT PACE WITH THE
CHANGING CHARACTER OF THE
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE NEEDING --
TO COME TO SCHOOL --
TO GAIN THE SKILLS THEY NEED TO
GET GOOD JOBS INCLUDING LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
RETURNING BACK TO DO SKILLS
UPGRADES WE THINK --
SB TWO NINETY ONE IS A REAL
ACTION AND HOPE YOU WILL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS TERRACE IN OUR
NAME THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION THE
BACKWARD SO THE SPA.
AND TODAY I'M HERE TO YOU AND
SHARE OUR SUPPORT A SENATOR
LEYVA SPELL SENATE BILL.
TWO NINETY ONE AND THIS REFORM
BILL AND HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE THE GAP ON EDUCATIONAL
COSTS FOR OUR NEEDIEST
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATE STUDENTS
THIS BILL IS CRITICAL TO
ELIMINATING THE FINANCIAL
BARRIERS OUR STUDENTS FACE AS
THEY WORK.
TO OBTAIN EDUCATIONAL AND CAREER
GOALS AND WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT
A REFORM BILL THAT ADDRESSES THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDING COLLEGE
WILL OFFER MORE STUDENTS TO
FOCUS ON THEIR EDUCATIONAL
SUCCESS.
AND WE COMMEND OUR STATE LEADERS
FOR THEIR BALDNESS TO MAKE REAL
CHANGE AND EXTEND AN INVITATION
TO THE AUTHORS. TO REFINE THE
BILL LANGUAGE TO POSITIVELY
IMPACT THE BROADEST GROUP OF
STUDENTS AND AND ALSO WHILE THE
SAME TIME MINIMIZING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE CHALLENGES THAT
ARE COLLEGES FACE GETTING TIMELY
AID TO STUDENTS.
THING THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S MICHAEL
DURING THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCIAL
AID AND SCHOLARSHIPS AMERICA'S
TO COLLEGE AND ALSO THE
PRESIDENT ELECT OF CEASEFIRE --
SO THE SHARE OF COLLEGE COSTS
COVERED BY THE MAXIMUM PELL
GRANT BACK IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE EIGHTY WERE NEARLY 80%.
AND THAT HAS NOW DROPPED TO LESS
THAN 30% SO.
WHILE WE DO HAVE AN AMAZING --
PROGRAM HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
COVERING TUITION --
AND THAT'S TO BE COMMENDED
COVERING TUITION IS SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH SO I ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR SB TWO NINETY
ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE MY NAME
IS JONATHAN LEON AND I AM A
STUDENT AND PEER MENTOR AT CRC
CONSUME THIS RIVER COLLEGE.
AND TODAY I AM HERE TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE WITH FINANCIAL AID AS
WELL AS THE STUDENTS EXPERIENCE
THAT I'VE MENTORED.
TO AND WE ALL SHARE ONE COMMON
THEME.
AND THAT'S HAVING TO PRIORITIZE
OUR ACADEMIC NEEDS OVER ANYTHING
ELSE SHOULD TAKE IMPORTANCE AS
OUR CAREER AS COLLEGE STUDENTS.
AND WE ALSO WANT TO SHARE THE
SUPPORT FOR SB TWO NINETY ONE AS
WELL AS ALSO LOOKING AT WHAT WE
CAN DO ON A FIRST YEAR BASIS FOR
STUDENTS IN TERMS OF FINANCIAL
AID.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MALICIOUS AND I AM
A STUDENT AT CONSUMERS WERE
COLLEGE --
AFTER RECESSION IN TWO THOUSAND
AND SIX OR SEVEN I HAD TO GO
BACK TO COLLEGE I HAD ALREADY
GRADUATED FROM A AS THE ISSUE
BAD TO GO BACK TO COLLEGE AND I
HAD TO GO TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND SO --
AFTER BEING THERE FOR A COUPLE
YEARS I HAD TO QUIT BECAUSE I
WASN'T ABLE TO GET FINANCIAL AID.
DUE.
TO NOT BEING ABLE TO GET
TRANSCRIPTS --
SO I THINK THAT IF CALIFORNIA IT
WOULD HAVE HAVE MONEY TO SUPPORT
ME I WOULD HAVE HAD TO QUIT
HOWEVER I'M I'M GETTING READY TO
GRADUATE AND NEXT YEAR --
BUT I THINK THAT THIS WILL HELP
SOME FUTURE STUDENTS BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THEIR GOALS ESPECIALLY
OLDER STUDENTS --
SO THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS MIGUEL
FUND AS I AM THE EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE STUDENTS
SENATE.
AS WELL AS A STUDENT OUT ALONG
THE COLLEGE.
I AM --
DRAMATIC RECIPIENT AS A DREAM
NEXT TO IT AND WE DON'T RECEIVE
A LOT OF HELP TO FUNDING.
I DO RECEIVE THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISE GRAND BUT DAD STEALS NOT
ENOUGH TO COVER FOR MY BOOKS AS
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT --
THAT HAS ME WORKING AT A AT A
GRAVEYARD SHIFT AT A A U. P. S.
WHICH SOMETIMES AB I ONLY SLEEP
AN HOUR AND JUST GO TO CLASS
RIGHT AFTER WORK.
WHICH IT DOESN'T GIVE ME TIME
ENOUGH TO FULLY FOCUS ON WHAT I
HAVE TO DO IT IF YOU KNOW IT
WILL BE NICE ENOUGH TO ALSO HAVE
SOME HELP FOR THE DREAMERS AS
WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
BREANNA EVERITT I ATTEND GAVEL
IN COLLEGE WHICH IS ALL THE WAY
DOWN AND GILROY --
I'M A STUDENT WHO DIDN'T QUALIFY
FOR FINANCIAL AID INITIALLY AND
TWO YEARS INTO MY COLLEGE CAREER
MY MOM FELL ILL.
AND WE WERE MAKING LESS THAN
HALF OF OUR INCOME AND I STILL
DIDN'T QUALIFY FOR ANY FINANCIAL
AID SO I'D REALLY LIKE TO SEE.
FINANCIALLY BECOME MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND COLLEGE BE MORE
AFFORDABLE FOR STUDENTS LIKE ME
THANK YOU THANK YOU --
HELLO MY NAME IS LILY FLORIO I
AM A FULL TIME STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE.
AND I JUST WANNA GIVE
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS OF OF WHEN
IT COMES TO FINANCIAL AID BEING
A RECOGNIZING OF THE TOTAL COST
OF EVERYTHING LIVING EXPENSES.
ARE CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW IS
CLEARLY LIKE THE NEXT PAYCHECK
OR ANYTHING I MIGHT BE HOMELESS
LIKE I WAS.
CURRENTLY I NOW REALIZING THAT
I'M ONE AN ARMY THAT --
HIRE A LOT OF TIMES I DO HAVE TO
USE FOOD BANK.
FOR FOOD AND SORRY DO SUFFER
FROM MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES TO
TO SAY THAT THIS IS JUST ONE
PERSPECTIVE BUT I KNOW THAT
THERE'S MANY PEOPLE YOU'RE NOT
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE.
WERE I SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE COLOR
BLACK AROUND THE STUDENTS AND
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE.
OF FACE I KNOW THEY CANTELL THE
FACE THE SAME SIMILAR CHALLENGES
I FACE SEEN.
AS ONE SAY TO TO RESPECT TO THAT
I DO THINK THAT THIS SB TWO
NINETY ONE DOES BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THESE THINGS.
AND I JUST WANT TO CONTINUE TO
SAY THAT WE ALSO NEED YOUR
CONTINUE TO ALSO RECOGNIZE
INTERTEXTUALITY OF THIS WORK.
PACIFIC LEE WHEN IT COMES TO ALL
BLACK AROUND OF AN INDIGENOUS
AND IMMIGRANTS AND AND NOT ONLY
THAT BUT QUEER AND TRANS SO THE
IDENTITIES.
THANK YOU.
HELLO TO THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS PHOEBE FAMINE I'M A STUDENT
AT A LOONY COLLEGE I'M IN MY
SOPHOMORE YEAR.
I ALSO SERVE ON THE STUDENT
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA CLEANING
COLLEGES AS THE REGIONAL AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR. FOR REGION FOUR AND IN
THE SF BAY AREA WHICH IS WHERE
WE'RE PRIMARY LOCATED EXTENDING.
TO YOUR A BIG ISSUE HAS BEEN WE
CAN MAKE UP 200-100-0200
THOUSAND YEAR AND IT STILL WON'T
BE ENOUGH FOR A STUDENT. TO BE
INDEPENDENT STUDENT AND STILL
HAVE THAT MONEY COVERED BE CASA
TO TUITION AND THE COST OF
LIVING ALONG WITH ANY OTHER
ADDITIONAL EXPENSE AND SO I
REALLY WANT TO THANK YOU OFFER
EFFORTS IN FURTHERING FINANCIAL
AID ACCESSIBILITY AND I HOPE TO
SEE CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT AS
WELL.
THANK YOU --
OPEN -- I'M
STILL SAYS I'M A STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH ALMOST IN A SEGMENT THE
COLLEGE -- I
DO HAVE A QUESTION FOR THE PANEL
IF I MAY ASK.
REALLY WE'RE JUST TAKING THE
COMMENTS UGH --
SO BEING THE TWENTY FOUR YEAR
OLD BIRACIAL STUDENT --
HAVING NO FAMILY AT ALL GREW AND
GROWING UP BOSS HERE I HAD NO
FINANCIAL STANDING FINANCIAL
BACKING AT ALL MAJORITY TIME
THAT'S TO SUPPORT MYSELF AND I
DO GO HUNGRY.
BUT IT'S VERY INTERESTING THAT I
HAVE TO SACRIFICE.
AN IDEA OF BALLING MY PASSION.
OR FALLING --
FINANCIAL OBLIGATION BECAUSE I
HAVE TO PAY RENT OR I HAVE TO
AFFORD FOOD.
AND IT'S A COMPROMISE BETWEEN TO
THE INTO THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS NO WELL MORE ON AND I
CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE PRESIDENT
OF ASSOCIATED STUDENTS.
THAT ARE CSU DOWN THE STREET
REPRESENTING THIRTY ONE THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
I WILL MAKE MY CALL IN BRIEF BUT
IT'S REALLY TO WITH THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING
IN THE SENSE OF URGENCY.
I THINK WHEN YOU SEE A STUDENT
WILLINGLY SHARE WITH YOU THAT
THEY'RE LIVING OUT OF THEIR CAR
AND NOT ONE STUDENT THE MULTIPLE
STUDENTS AND YOU GET TO SEE THAT
FIRSTHAND.
IT REALLY CHANGES THE SENSE OF
URGENCY THAT YOU HAVE TO REFER
TO RESOLVE INTO TACKLE THESE
KINDS OF ISSUES LIKE FINANCIAL
AID REFORM.
THAT'S WHY I THINK OUR STUDENTS
STORIES AND BRINGING THEM TO THE
SPACES ARE CRITICAL TO REALLY
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S BEHIND
THESE NUMBERS THAT SOCK STATE WE
HAVE 47% OF OUR STUDENTS FOOD
SECURITY.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
CONDUCIVE TO LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT WE TRY TO TACKLE IT
AS MUCH AS WE CAN WITH STUDENTS
HELPING OTHER STUDENTS OUT.
BUT I THINK AT THE END OF THE
DAY IT IS SOMETHING WHERE THE OF
REFORM AND THAT'S WHY I'M
THANKFUL FOR THESE CONVERSATIONS
HERE TODAY.
WE NEED TO MAKE EQUITY SOMETHING
MORE AT EQUITY AND ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION SOMETHING MORE
THAN BUZZ WORDS THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS EMILY
I'M A THIRD YEAR YOU SEE
RIVERSIDE --
AS A STUDENT FROM THE INLAND
EMPIRE FEELS GOOD TO WALK INTO
THE CAPITOL IN NOW THAT WE HAVE
PEOPLE LISTENING TO US.
I'M A FIRST GENERATION STUDENT
WHICH OFTENTIMES MEANS THAT I
HAVE TO TRUST MYSELF.
I RECENTLY DECIDED TO TAKE TIME
OUT OF SCHOOL SO I WOULDN'T HAVE
TO TAKE OUT EVEN MORE LOANS.
RIGHT NOW I MAKE SURE TO WORK
TWO JOBS I CAN SAVE TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL --
AND IT OFTENTIMES FEELS LIKE IT
IS THEN THAT MANY PEOPLE WANTING
TO HAVE STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF WHO
DON'T WANT TO GRADUATE WITH
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN DEBT --
I TELL YOU THIS BECAUSE I WANT
YOU TO KNOW THAT FOR SOME
STUDENTS TUITION IS JUST AS PART
OF THE ISSUE AS THE TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDANCE I DON'T BELIEVE
IT'S A CONVERSATION OF EITHER OR
SHOULD WE COVER STUDENTS TUITION --
SHOULD COVER STUDENTS BASIC
NEEDS I DON'T THINK WHICH YOU
SEE IT THAT WAY I THINK WE
SHOULD SEE IT AS A CONVERSATION
OF BOTH --
SOME VERY HAPPY TO SEE SO MANY
OF YOU MAKING THIS A PRIORITY --
WITH BILL SUCH AS AB TWO SB TWO
NINE ONE IN MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN THE NINE MAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS VINCENT
ROSSUM A STUDENT AND YOU SEE
RIVERSIDE I'M ALSO CAL GRAMMAR
CPN -- FIRST
I JUST WANTED KNOWLEDGE THE
PROVISION THAT THEY HAVE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO SPACE LIKE THIS ON
MANAGEMENT THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR ON THE DIALOGUE IS CREATED
AROUND --
ISSUE THAT STUDENTS ARE FACING
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ON
SPECIFICALLY THE CAMPUS AT
COMMUNITY AT YOU SEE OUR HAS
VERY MUCH BEEN ON THE FOREFRONT
OF WITNESSING THE COMPLEXITIES
OF THE CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM.
WE PRIDE OURSELVES AS BEING ONE
OF THE MOST DIVERSE SPECIES AND
ON THIS STEMS FROM AT THE APPEAL
THAT YOU SLICE GENEROUS
FINANCIAL AID PACKAGES HAVE. TO
LOW INCOME STUDENTS AND STUDENTS
WHO COMMUTE LIKE MYSELF ON AND
THAT WITH OUR FAMILY DID LIKE
HOUSING COSTS.
ON THE CAPACITY FOR YOU SEE OUR
STUDENTS TO RECEIVE ENOUGH
FINANCIAL AID TO COVER THEIR
TUITION COSTS HAD HAVE BEEN
OFFSET BY LARGE DISPARITIES IN
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES.
THAT ARE BEING AFFECTED BY THE
CAPACITY TO AFFORD TOTAL COSTS
OF ATTENDANCE INCLUDING FOOD
SUSTAINABILITY OVERALL.
SO MOVING FORWARD WITH CAL
GRAHAM FORM I BELIEVE WE SHOULD
BE REFLECTIVE OF THE STUDENT
MEANS -- SO
MOVING FORWARD WE REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY
OF ON THE CAL GRANT BY REMOVING
IT ANSWERED RESTRICTIONS AND
BARRIERS INCREASING THE AWARD
BASED ON NEED FOR STUDENTS
ALREADY RECEIVING CAL GRANT AID.
AND SUPPORTING INITIATIVES LIKE
ON RIVERSIDE SENATOR ROBB JUST
INTRODUCED THIS SUMMER CAL GRANT
BILL ON INTENDED TO UPLIFT
STUDENTS FACING THESE ISSUES
THANK YOU.
AOSHIMA SAKE OF LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
THOUGH THE DISTRICT IS IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH YOUR MEASURE A.
B. THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND SB.
TWO NINETY ONE DURING THE
DELIBERATIONS OF BOTH THOSE
BILLS WOULD LIKE TO HAVE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF AN AMENDMENT.
THAT WOULD ADDRESS OF A PROBLEM
FOR CERTAIN LGBT Q. STUDENTS.
OF CERTAIN STUDENTS ARE UNABLE
TO GET THEIR PARENTS SIGNATURE
TO SEE I CAN'T EVEN GET ACCESS
TO FINANCIAL AID AND AS A RESULT.
THEY CAN'T EVEN.
GET -- GET
ANY KINDOF FINANCIAL SUPPORT
AND THEY ARE UNABLE ATTEND
COLLEGE AT ALL OR THEY HAVE TO
TAKE OF FEWER UNITS --
TO PARTICIPATE SO WE'D LIKE TO
HAVE SOME CONSIDERATION TO GET
US A WAIVER FOR THE PARENTS
SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT UNDER
THESE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO LISTEN TO
STUDENTS SUCH AS MYSELF --
MY NAME IS A NUMBER OF THE YOUNG
MAN'S AND I'M A SECOND YEAR
POLITICAL SCIENCE MAJOR AT YOU
SEE OUR I'M FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO
HAVE MY TUITION FULLY COVERED BY
FINANCIAL AID BUT UNFORTUNATELY
IT FAILS TO COVER EXPENSES SUCH
AS HOUSING --
BOOKS AND OTHER OTHER THINGS AS
A FIRST GENERATION LOW INCOME
STUDENTS I RECEIVED VERY LITTLE
TO ALMOST NO HELP FROM MY
PARENTS AND THEREFORE FORCED TO
HEAVILY RELY ON LOANS TO PAY FOR
COLLEGE.
OTHERWISE GOING TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY WOULD BE NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE --
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THESE
FINANCIAL BURDENS --
CAN ALSO HINDER US STUDENTS
PERFORMANCE IN SCHOOL JUST LAST
QUARTER I HAVE SO MANY EXPENSES
THAT EVEN WITH LOANS IT WAS
OVERWHELMING BECAUSE THE COST OF
MY REQUIRE BOOKS WERE A LOT
HIGHER THAN THE THAN THEY HAD
BEEN IN THE PAST.
SO I CHOSE NOT TO BUY ONE OF THE
REQUIRED TEXTBOOKS FROM MY
CLASSES AND INSTEAD I BARRED AN
OLDER ADDITION --
FROM THE CULTURAL CENTER AT
SCHOOL THAT DIDN'T HAVE --
MANY LOW INCOME STUDENTS FACE
SIMILAR ISSUES AND MANY ARE
DRIVEN AWAY FROM FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS BECAUSE OF THIS I
WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT ALL FOR
YOUR WORK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LOSS
OF US DOWN AND I'M A FIRST YEAR --
MAJOR AB --
POLITICAL SCIENCE MAJOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE.
AND I GUESS I WANT TO STRESS
WITH LIKE THE DAY TO DAY
STRUGGLES FOR STUDENTS WHO LIKE.
DON'T HAVE THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES --
AND MY STRUGGLE AT EACH DAY IS
ONLY HAVING ACCESS TO TWO MEALS
PER DAY SO I HAVE TO CITY DEEPLY
PLAN WHEN I CONSUME MY MEAL SO I
HAVE.
BOTH THE ENERGY.
TO ATTEND MY LECTURES AND NOT
HAVE TO GO TO BED HUNGRY.
SAW THIS IS ONLY LIKE ONE STORY
OUT OF LIKE THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS WHO ATTEND MY COLLEGE
BUT I JUST.
I HOPE YOU GUYS TAKE THE RIGHT
STEPS TO MODIFIER CAL GRANT AND
ALSO.
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR THE AB.
TWO YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RUNNING CURRY IN THE SECOND YEAR
A UC RIVERSIDE STUDY POLITICAL
SCIENCE BEFORE I BEGIN I JUST
WANTED KNOWLEDGE TO HUNDREDS OR
EVEN THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS WHO
DON'T HAVE THE OPTED OPPORTUNITY
OR ABILITY OR PRIVILEGED EVEN
ATTEND THIS KIND OF HEARING.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THEM ARE
MANAGING MORE THAN TWO JOBS
WE'VE BEEN JUGGLING ARM --
SCHEDULES THAT --
OVERBEARING SCHEDULES ALSO
REALLY TO REALLY BEGIN WHAT
ABOUT YOU 90% OF UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENTS DURING THE ACADEMIC
YEAR RECEIVE SOME FORM OF STATE
AID.
THAT COVERS A MAJORITY OF THEIR
TUITION HOWEVER THE TOTAL COST
OF ATTENDING USE YOURS
OVERBEARING AND CONTRIBUTE AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THINGS SUCH AS OUR
60% WOULD SECURITY RATE.
ON OUR INDIVIDUAL CAMPUS.
I THINK COMMITTEE LEADERSHIP FOR
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATIONAL
CALL GOT REFORM BUT I ASKED
UNDERSERVED CAMPUSES SUCH AS USE
YOUR AMBER SAID OR PRIORITIZE AS
MODELS OF THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE TO MAKE HIGHER EDUCATION
AND ACCESSIBLE SPACE.
FROM MARGINALIZED STUDENT GROUPS
TO THRIVE IN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN TINA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JULIE ARAMBULA AND I AM A SECOND
YEAR PUBLIC POLICY STERN AYE YOU
SEE OUR TODAY MY PEERS AND I
FLEW INTO SACRAMENTO A FIVE IN
THE MORNING WHICH MEANT MISSING
CLASS TO COME TO THIS HEARING.
TO ENSURE THAT THE MOST
IMPORTANT STAKEHOLDERS IN THIS
DISCUSSION STUDENTS ARE HEARD
AND HAVE A PRESENCE IN THIS VERY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS.
IT IS CLEAR THAT THERE ARE TOO
MANY STUDENTS ARE LEFT BEHIND.
I LEFT OUR OR LEFT BEHIND WHEN
IT COMES TO FINANCIAL AID THE
TIME HAS COME TO ADDRESS THIS BY
REFORMING OUR FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
WILL SUPPORT THE MILLIONS OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS WERE IN OR FACE
OF THE TREMENDOUS BURDEN OF
TUITION COSTS SO THAT STUDENTS
CAN FOCUS ON A PERSONAL IN THEIR
EDUCATION.
RATHER THAN WORRYING ABOUT THE
RISING COSTS IN OVERALL INCIDENT
AT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEDI NINE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS I'LL HANDLE IT AND
WITH THE WHITE MAN GROUP HERE ON
BEHALF OF NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
NEXT AND OF COURSE.
SUPPORTS FINANCIALLY REFORM AND
WE COMMEND STAFF FOR THEIR
CONSTANT WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND
THERE ARE CERTAIN ASPECTS THAT
WE FULLY SUPPORT A WILL NAME
AHMAD BUT JUST TO NAME A COUPLE
EXPAND THE I'M REDUCING BARRIERS --
TO THESE GRANTS AND EXPAND IT'S
NEXT AND HAS PRIORITIZE STUDENT
LOAN DEBT OF COURSE A LOT OF
THESE STUDENTS.
ARE PROBABLY GONNA TAKE OUT
LOANS OR STUDENTS ARE GONNA.
GRADUATE RES I AM IN THE NEXT
YEAR SO WITH MAJOR STUDENT LOAN
DEBT BUT WE ARE ALSO PER TYSON
AND WE WE WANT YOU OUGHT TO
CONSIDER THOSE STUDENTS THAT
HAVE GRADUATED --
AND HAVE MASSES SCHOOL ONE DEBTS
JUST BROUGHT A FEW NUMBERS.
OUT THERE THERE'S ABOUT THREE
POINT SEVEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
THAT HAVE STOOD ON ALL DAY WHICH
ROUGHLY TRANSLATES TO ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE BILLION.
DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT SO
JUST HAVING THE CONVERSATION OF
THOSE WHO HAVE GRADUATED AND ARE
DEALING WITH THOSE TO DOWNLOAD
LOAN DEBT --
WILL BE SURE TO REACH OUT TO THE
CONSULTANTS AND OF COURSE YOU
CHAIRMAN ON THIS ISSUE BECAUSE I
KNOW IT'S A HIGHLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR EVERYONE HERE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SET A
FLORIDA IS A THIRTY YEAR
TRANSFER STUDENT AT UCLA AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOUR SIXTY ONE I'M A FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT REYES
Y. SINGLE IMMIGRANT MOTHER OF
FOR MY MOTHER DOES WHAT SHE CAN
FOR OUR SURVIVAL HER HANDS ARE
ROUGH FROM WORKING IN THE SAME
FACTORY FOR OVER. TWENTY YEARS
OUR PRECARIOUS FINANCIAL
SITUATION LEAVES IS BARELY
AFFORDING A ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT.
I SEE MY EDUCATION AS A WAY OF
HELPING MY FAMILY'S PRECARIOUS
FINANCIAL SITUATION AND I HAVE
MY MOTHER STREAMS OF A BETTER
LIFE TO REALIZE AND I FEEL THE
IMMENSE PRESSURE TO GRADUATE IN
ORDER TO MAKE MY MOTHER
SACRIFICE IS WORTH IT.
BY I'M FINDING THIS MORE
DIFFICULT WITH THE LACK OF
FINANCIALLY DURING THE SUMMER.
I'M FORCED TO MAKE A DECISION
BETWEEN GRADUATING WORK FORCE IN
ORDER TO SAVE MONEY.
TAKING CLASSES OVER THE SUMMER
HAS PROVEN ITSELF TO BE A
PRIVILEGE THAT I CANNOT AFFORD
PLEASE SUPPORT AS BEFORE SIXTY
ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN NINA MY
NAME IS MEGAN IS ON THE LINE
WITH HOPE YOU SPANISH ORGANIZED
FOR POLITICAL EQUALITY FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS HOPE HAS ADVOCATED
FOR ECHO WILL ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HIGHER AD. FOR
LATINOS OVER 70% OF LATINO
STUDENTS ATTEND THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IS
A GATEWAY FOR LATINO STUDENTS
AND MUST BE PRIORITIZED WE'RE
ENCOURAGED BY IN SUPPORT THE
CHANCE OR SUPPORT PROPOSAL TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE FOR TO DETERMINE
STUDENTS NEEDS.
HOPE SUPPORTS CAL GRANT
EXPANSION INCREASING THE AWARD
AMOUNT AND THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
WARTS OFFERED AND RE EVALUATING
AT ELIGIBILITY. TO RIDE MORE
ACCESS FOR LATINOS AGENT
IMMIGRATION STATUS SHOULD NOT BE
DETRIMENTS TO STUDENTS --
TO STUDENTS CAL GRANT AWARDS
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ARE
PARTICULARLY AT A DISADVANTAGE
AS THEY ARE UNABLE TO ACCESS
FEDERAL FUNDS LIKE THEIR PEERS.
THIS IS WHY WE SUPPORT THE
CREATION AND FUNDING OF A
SERVICE INCENTIVE GRANT WE HOPE
THAT HE USED AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
YOU PRIORITIZE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE.
CAL GET EXPANSION AND
ELIGIBILITY REFORM AND THE
CREATION OF SERVICE INCENTIVE
GRANTS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TERM MEDINA
CONSULTANTS AND STUFF I'M
DOLLARS DAVIS AND I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE ACADEMIC
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
THE ACADEMIC SENATE WELCOMES
THIS DISCUSSION OF FINANCIAL AID
REFORM RECOGNIZING THE IMPACT
THAT FINANCIAL AID HAS OR
STUDENT SUCCESS AND ACCESS
THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM.
WE ARE ALSO HAPPY TO ASSIST THE
LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE IN
EVALUATING ANY RAMIFICATIONS
THESE REFORMS MAY HAVE --
ON OUR STUDENTS AND OUR COLLEGES
AND WE STAND READY TO ASSIST
WITH ANYTHING WE CAN DO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COUNTY ABOUT
AUSTIN REPRESENTING JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH --
THIS IS AN ORGANIZATION THAT
WORKS TOWARDS --
COLLEGE ACCESS AND COMPLETE FOR
I TO CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS FOSTER
YOUTH AND HOMELESS --
AND HOMELESS YOUTH --
THESE STUDENTS ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY --
SERVED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND WHAT WE FIND IS THE WORK
THAT WE DO CONTINUOUSLY BRINGS
US BACK TO THE FACT THAT --
STUDENTS ARE HAVING MORE MORE
CHALLENGES AS YOU'VE HEARD TODAY.
AND BECAUSE OF FINANCIAL AID OR
LACK OF FINANCIAL AID --
WE DO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES --
PROPOSAL TO CREATE A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAM. TO MORE FULLY MEET THE
NEEDS OF OF THESE POPULATIONS
AND WE ALSO EXPECT US SUPPORT
EXPANDING ACCESS TO CAL GRANTS.
AND TO INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF
THE GRANT GRANT ITSELF WHETHER
THIS IS DONE THROUGH --
ARE LARGER REFORM EFFORT AT OR
THREE INCREASES TO THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANTS AVAILABLE.
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU TO TO ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS --
THROUGH SOME SORT OF REFORM FOR
FOR FINANCIAL AID.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEDINA THING
WHERE --
ORGANIZING COMMITTEE HEARING
TODAY I AM AN INSTITUTIONAL AND
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY --
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS THE MOST
GENEROUS STATE AID PROGRAM IN
THE COUNTRY BUT WE ALSO LEAD THE
NATION IN ASSISTING STUDENTS.
I'M TO MEET THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE IN THE PERCY OF
HIGHER EDUCATION MONEY SHOULD
NEVER BE A BARRIER TO TALENT.
THE COST FOR MY STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES GO BEYOND SIMPLE
TUITION AND FEES CALIFORNIA
SHOULD WORK TO REDUCE THE GAP AN
UNMET FINANCIAL NEED BORN BY
STUDENTS AFTER GREAT GREAT GRANT
AID.
A REASONABLE AMOUNT OF STUDENT%
WORK AND FAMILY CONTRIBUTIONS TO
ZERO DOLLARS FIRST.
CALL STUDENTS ATTENDING COLLEGE.
INVESTMENTS AND FINANCIAL AID
MUST PRIORITIZE AID FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
NOT ONLY IS SUCH TARGETING
ALIGNED WITH CALIFORNIA VALUES
BUT IT BEARS GREATER RETURN ON
TAXPAYER INVESTMENT.
ENSURING THAT EACH ELIGIBLE
STUDENT APPLYING FOR AID
RECEIVED AN AWARD IS A SOMEWHAT
RIGHT IMPERATIVE.
THE COST OF HEALTH A COLLEGE AS
ONE OF THE REASONS STUDENTS SITE
MOST FOR CHOOSING NOT TO ATTEND
COLIFORM YEAH MUST ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS ANNUALLY APPLY AND ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FINANCIAL AID.
YET RECEIVE.
NINE THE SIGNIFICANT MONETARY
INVESTMENTS NEEDED TO ENSURE
LASTING COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA WILL LIKELY NEED TO
BE MADE OVER TIME.
WE URGE LIKE ANY REFORM OF THE
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM MUST START
FIRST WITH THE FOCUS ON
EXPANDING AID TO COVER STUDENTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY GIVEN NO
ASSISTANCE.
AS WELL AS INCREASING THE AID
PROVIDED TO LOW INCOME STUDENTS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
CHAIRS AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
I CAME OVER TODAY TO ASK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SB TWO NINETY ONE
AS IT IS AN INVESTMENT TOWARDS.
THE EDUCATION OF ADULTS AN THE
EDUCATION OF FUTURE ADULTS WHICH
WILL BE INVESTMENT FOR THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
HI THERE MY NAME IS REGION
CORPUS GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
DEAN AND THE COMMITTEE --
I WORK WITH GARNERING COMMITTEE
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND REALLY
WORKING WITH THEM BUT NOW I WANT
TO SPEAK AS A RECENT GRADUATE
FROM THE UC SYSTEM AND ALSO FROM
THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE SYSTEM.
I'VE KNOWN MANY OF MY PEERS WHO
EVEN FROM THAT TIME A YEARS AGO
WHO HAD TO WORK MULTIPLE JOBS
AND SOME OF THEM HAD TO DROP OUT
BECAUSE IT WAS TOO HARD TO
REALLY BALANCE BOTH.
ACT LIVING COSTS AND ALSO PAYING
FOR EDUCATION SO HOPE FOR
CALIFORNIA AND CON SUS WE REALLY
LOOK MORE TO THE HOLISTIC EFFORT
KIND OF THINGS THAT SB TWO
NINETY ONE IS GOING TO DO.
BUT ALSO TO CONSIDER WAYS THAT
WE CAN HELP THE CALIFORNIA
APPLICANTS TO ALSO RECEIVED
EQUITABLE AMOUNT.
WITH THE IN A CAL GRANT COMPETE
HAVE CAL GRANT AND ALSO MAYBE A
STUDY SERVICE PROGRAM BECAUSE
THEY ARE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR A
STUDY FINANCIALLY MANY OF THEM
WANT TO COME TODAY BUT BECAUSE
THE THE EXAM SEASON.
BUT ALSO THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
WORKING THEY'RE NOT SURE WHAT TO
SAY HOUSE WANNA SPEAK ON BEHALF
AND HOPEFULLY ASIDE FROM THIS
HEARING WILL HAVE A MORE EFFORTS
TO GENUINELY.
A REACH OUT TO THEM AND LISTEN
TO THEIR A POWERFUL VOICES THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS RYAN
MICHAEL ANY OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LIKE A CALIFORNIA
TESTIFYING ON CALIFORNIA SEVENTY
TWO COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
BEHALF --
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA SHOULD
JUSTIFIABLY PROUD OF HAVING THE
LARGEST AND MOST COMPREHENSIVE --
FREE TUITION PROGRAM IN THE
COUNTRY --
HOWEVER --
AND ALSO OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE
NOT PAYING FOR YOU TO THE LOWEST
FEES IN THE NATION HOWEVER THE
STUDENTS ALSO --
FACED A REALLY HIGH LIVING COSTS
IN HERE IN CALIFORNIA THINGS
LIKE ISAAC HOUSING.
RENT --
TRANSPORTATION THOSE ITEMS AND
SO WE WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE BOTH
THE COMMITTEES TO THINK ABOUT --
LIVING COSTS WHEN THINK ABOUT
HIGHER EDUCATION POLICY AND THEN
ALSO MAKING SURE THAT MORE
STUDENTS THE NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS ARE ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR
ANY SORT OF FINANCIAL AID AWAY --
TO PROGRAM SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO --
THANK YOU FOR STAYING THROUGH
THE REPUBLIC COMMENTED HEARING
OUR STUDENT MEANS MY NAME IS LEE
SAID THE ORDERS I'M A THIRD YEAR
POLITICAL SCIENCE.
MAJOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA MERCED I'M ALSO THE
EXTERNAL VICE PRESIDENT I
REPRESENT MY SOMEBODY LOCALLY
STATEWIDE IN FEDERALLY I'M A
DAUGHTER OF A SINGLE IMMIGRANTS
STRONG POWERFUL WOMAN TOGETHER
HER AND I ARE SUPPORTING MY
THREE YOUNGER SIBLINGS AND ONE
WAY OR ANOTHER WILL SUPPORT
THEIR JOURNEY THROUGH.
LIFE ONE IMPACT IN MY LIFE
DISCOGRAPHY OR WOULD HAVE DONE
LAST YEAR --
IS NOT IN FORCE ME TO QUIT MY
ELECTED POSITION AS A UC MERCED
SENATOR IN ORDER TO FIND A JOB
THAT PHYSICALLY STRESS ME OUT TO
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT MY MOTHER
AND MY THREE SIBLINGS.
IT WOULD HAVE EASE THE HARDSHIP
EXTENDING OUTSIDE OF CAMPUS TO
MY LIFE.
I A GOAL IN A STATEMENT OF THE
PRIVILEGE TO UNDERSTAND AND
ACCESS THE SPACE THE NEED AND
FOCUS AND A TORQUE CAMPUSES AND
THE COMMUNITIES WE ARE A PART OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY FOR MYSELF.
I AM HERE TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT IN
EXTENDING CAL GRANT
ACCESSIBILITY TO UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS ESPECIALLY NON AB.
FIVE FORTY I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE REGION'S AGENDA ITEM TO
INCREASE STUDENT FEES FOR NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS I ASK THAT.
YOU CONSIDER THE WAY WHICH
UNDOCUMENTED THESE INSTITUTIONS
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEGISLATORS MY
NAME IS JON ACOSTA WELL AND I AM
A FIRST YEAR UC MERCED.
I'M ALSO THAN DOCU COALITION
REPRESENT REPRESENTATIVE FOR UC
MERCED WHICH IS A STATE WIDE
STUDENT BASED UNION.
I WOULD LIKE TO STATE MY SUPPORT
FOR SB FOUR SIXTY ONE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SPENDS FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS LESS ON YOU SEE
STUDENTS.
THAN IT DID FORTY YEARS AGO
WHEREAS THE SUMMER CAL GRANT
WOULD HELP STUDENTS GRADUATE
FASTER.
IN ADDITION TO A SUMMER CAL
GRANT WE WANT TO SEE A FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM THAT HELPS ALL INCOME
STUDENTS INCLUDING UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AND THOSE WHO ARE DO
NOT QUALIFY FOR AB.
FIVE FORTY REGARDLESS OF
INSTITUTION AND REGARD THIS
INSTITUTION THERE TEN AND
INCREASING AWARD SIZE AND
REDUCING BARRIERS FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS TO RECEIVE STUDENT
EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NOT ON THE
REMOTE ALICE I AM A STUDENT AT
UC MERCED --
I AM AND UNDOCUMENTED INDIGENOUS
WOMAN --
WITH MY SEVERAL IT IDENTITIES
COMES MANY OBSTACLES AND LACK OF
RESOURCES ON CAMPUS --
FORTUNATELY.
YOU KNOW THROUGH A LOT OF TOUGH
PUSHING I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
GRADUATE SOON I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PUSH THROUGH EVERYTHING BUT IT
COULD HAVE BEEN IT WAY EASIER.
SCHOOL THE PEOPLE ATTENDING
SCHOOL NOW ARE NOT THE SAME
STUDENTS THAT WERE ATTENDING.
EVEN TEN YEARS AGO THERE IS
DIFFERENT STUDENTS WITH
DIFFERENT IDENTITIES DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE LACK OF ACCESSIBILITY --
AS AN UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT YOUR
GETTING FOOD IS ANOTHER OPTION
THEIR STUDENTS WHO ARE UNABLE TO
GET A JOB WHICH LIMITS THEM EVEN
MORE SO WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR SIXTY ONE TO BE ABLE.
TO SUCCESSFULLY ENSURE ALL
STUDENTS INTO ENTERING HIGHER
EDUCATION ARE ABLE TO GRADUATE --
I HIGHLY HIGHLY I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THAT BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEDINA.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN ENOUGH
HOT THANK YOU FOR BEING PATIENT
AND LISTENING TO OUR STORIES WE
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
I'M A SECOND YEAR POLITICS NIKON
DOUBLE MAJOR FROM UC SANTA CRUZ --
AND I ALSO WORK ON BASIC NEEDS
ISSUES WITH THE UNIVERSITY
CALIFORNIA'S AN ASSOCIATION --
AND I'M IN ONE OF THE WORST
HOUSING MARKETS IN THE WORLD
LIVING IN SANTA CRUZ ARE RENTS
ARE RIDICULOUS AND MYSELF AND
MOST OF MY PEERS HAVE BEEN SOME
KIND OF HOUSING AND SECURE AT
SOME POINT.
DURING OUR TIME AS
UNDERGRADUATES AT UCSC.
THEN PLEASE INDOOR CONDITION AS
FOOD INSECURE STUDENTS BECAUSE
WE OFTEN HOLD TWO SOMETIMES
THREE FOR PART TIME OR FULL TIME
JOBS TO TRY TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
MEET OUR BASIC NEEDS.
BECAUSE FINANCIALLY IT JUST
DOESN'T DO THAT FOR US AND YOU
ALREADY HEARD MANY STUDENTS TALK
ABOUT THIS RIGHT.
UNREALISTIC TO EXPECT THAT
FINANCIALLY THE WAY THAT IT IS
SET UP RIGHT NOW IS JUST NOT
GOING TO MAKE COLLEGE AFFORDABLE
FOR STUDENTS IN NEED.
I WANT ALSO ON I WANT TO ALMOST
SAY THAT THE PRIORITIES AND
FINANCIALLY PERFORM AT THIS
POINT --
INTUITIVE THEIR COMMONSENSE.
SO BODY CRITERIA FOR THOSE WHO
DON'T CURRENTLY QUALIFY FOR
STATE BASED AID AND HELP
STUDENTS GRADUATION RATES BY
EXPANDING CAL GRANT INTO THE
SUMMER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CHRIS RESPONSES WHICH I LOVE THE
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS AND ALSO REPRESENTING OUR
PROJECT THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
NETWORK REPRESENTING STUDENTS
FROM ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ONE ECHO MANY OF THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE BY THE
STUDENTS I THINK THEY SAID IT
PERFECTLY SO I'M NOT GONNA
REPEAT.
ON BUT JUST TO TO SAY THAT --
YOU A DOCUMENT STIRS TO HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF EQUITY ISSUES I
THINK WE COULD ADDRESS IN THIS
OFTEN ACTUALLY REFORM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS JAMIE
CAN RECOMMEND THE UNDERGRADUATE
EXCEL VICE PRESIDENT AT UCLA I
ALSO SERVE AS THE VICE CHAIR.
FOR THE UC STUDENT.
UNIVERSITY AFFAIRS COMMITTEE --
THE ONLY REASON I AM HERE TODAY
IS BECAUSE OF THE FINANCIAL AID
THAT I RECEIVE --
IT IN FACT AS A FOURTH YEAR I AM
ACTUALLY HAVING TROUBLE GETTING
THE CLASSES THAT I NEED TO
GRADUATE SO IT LOOKS LIKE I'M
GOING TO STAND BY IT BUT A LOT
OF MY FRIENDS HAVE NOT HAD THE
SAME FATE AND MANY OF THEM ARE
HAVING TO STAY LONGER.
THANKFULLY I WAS ABLE TO ACCESS
SOME RECESSION AND IT LOOKS LIKE
THAT I'M GRADUATING IN THE
SPRING --
ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE NEED
TO EXPAND CAL GRANTS THE SUMMER
IS BECAUSE THIS ISSUE INTERSECTS
WITH SO MANY OF THE OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT WE SEE --
I HAVEN'T ESPECIALLY AS IN ROMAN
INCREASES AT THE UC AND OF
STUDENTS ARE HAVING TO STAY
LONGER AYE SENIORS AS MORE
COMING IN AS FRESHMEN WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO SEE WORSENING
HOUSING AND SECURITY --
LARGER CLASSES THE SMALLEST ONE
THAT I'VE BEEN IN UP UNTIL THIS
QUARTER WAS A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
PEOPLE -- SO
I DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO MY
PROFESSOR IS --
AND WE'RE GOING TO SEE IT
CONTINUED Là SEE WHAT IT MIGHT
OR TO TO PASS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
UGH AFTER LETTERS LETTERS MY
NAME IS COMING OFF AND WENT TO
COURT ON THE CHAIR OF THE COLOR
FOR BETTY SEE.
NOW I'VE SORT OF POINT OUT WHAT
I HOPE IS A TYPO IN THIS AGENDA
DOCUMENT ON PAGE NINE SECOND
PARAGRAPH --
BOLD SAYS DESPITE STATE AND
SEGMENT FOCUS ON QUICK ATTACH A
DEGREE STATE AID DOES ADEQUATELY
COVER SOME SCHOOL COSTS.
OTHER IS NOT A PROBLEM WITH THIS
IS BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IN THE
UC SINCE ONLY RECEIVED PELL
GRANTS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND INSTITUTIONAL
GRANTS FROM FROM THE INSTITUTION
AND THE ONLY THEY CAN ACCESS THE
STATE AID IS THAT THEY DON'T USE
IT DURING THE REGULAR ACADEMIC --
SO THIS DOESN'T MAKE SENSE AND
IN ADDITION TO THAT WE KNOW THAT
WHEN STUDENTS DO GET THOSE TO
GRANT IT'S STILL NOT ENOUGH TO
COVER TUITION AND CAMPUS BASED
FEES.
SO AT THIS PROGRAM HE WAS RIGHT
TALK ABOUT THE COST OF HOUSING
THE COST OF FOOD WITH A COST OF
TEXTBOOKS SO THAT'S WHY I'M HERE
JUST IN MY SUPPORT FOR ITS
BEFORE.
SIXTY ONE AS WELL AS ALSO URGE
YOU TO LOWER BARRIERS THAT
STUDENTS. TO ACT OF CONGRESS
THAT STUDENTS MORE STUDENTS CAN
HAVE ACCESS TO THE COP GRANT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HAVE A
LOVELY DAY.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEGISLATORS.
HI MY NAME IS ALEXANDER AT LANCE
IN ABOUT A THIRD YEAR AT UC
SANTA BARBARA SITTING HISTORY
PUBLIC POLICY --
AND ALSO SERVE AS A LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR OUR CAMPUS --
I LIKE MANY STUDENTS WORK MANY
JOBS IN A POSITION TO MY CLASSES
I CURRENTLY AM IN FOR JOBS TO
PART TIME INTO FULL TIME TO NOT
ONLY COVER MY COSTS OF
ENROLLMENT BUT ALSO TO SEND HOME
MONEY.
EVERY MONTH AS MY FAMILY REALLY
DEPENDS ON THE SENDING A CHECK
EVERY MONTH --
SO ME LIKE MANY OTHER STUDENTS
CURRENTLY AND CONTINUOUSLY
INVEST IN OUR EDUCATION REALLY
IT IS HEARTENING TO KNOW THAT
THE UC SYSTEM HAS STOPPED
FUNDING OUR STUDENTS AND HAS
SPENT AT FIFTEEN THOUSAND LASSEN
THEY HAVE ON US FORTY YEARS AGO.
SO I'M HERE SUPPORTING AS BEFORE
SIXTY ONE AS A SUMMER CAL GRANT
WOULD REALLY MAKE A DENT INTO.
OUR TIME AT THE U. SEASON REALLY
HELP TO ALLEVIATE A LOT OF THOSE
COSTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS TOM STILL I'M
AFFORD YOUR FROM UC SANTA
BARBARA.
THE AVERAGE UC STUDENT GRADUATES
WITH OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
MYSELF I'LL GRADUATE WITH ABOUT
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IS THE
ONLY TIME IT IS A BAD THING TO
BE ABOVE AVERAGE IN THE UC
SYSTEM.
BUT IN ORDER TO FIX THIS PROBLEM
WE NEED IT TO EXPAND AID INTO
THE SUMMER.
AND THAT IS WHY I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT SB FOUR SIXTY ONE SO
THAT WE CAN GIVE STUDENTS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE CLASSES OVER
THE SUMMER.
AND ELIMINATE AND REDUCE THEIR
AMOUNT OF STUDENT AT THAT THEY
TAKE ON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HIGH --
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND FOR STICKING AROUND
TO LISTEN TO ALL OF US I'M I'M
KATIE CATION I AM AM SENIOR AT
YOU SEE SENATORS.
OMINOUS CITY POLITICS --
I'M HERE TO STATE MY SUPPORT --
FOR SB --
FOR SIXTY ONE SUMMER CALTRAIN
MORE FOLKS --
SUMMER CLASSES ARE A GREAT WAY
TO GRADUATE EARLY TO PICK UP
UNITS THAT PEOPLE AREN'T ABLE --
TO PICK UP DURING THE SCHOOL
YEAR BECAUSE OF IMPACTION AND
BECAUSE OF OVER IN ROMAN OTHER
UNIVERSITIES --
I'VE SEEN MY FRIENDS WORK MORE
THAN FULL TIME OVER THE SUMMER
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE --
TO SCRAPE BY GOING TO SUMMER
CLASSES --
AND THAT'S ON TOP OF CLASSES AND
THAT'S JUST NOT LIKE A PROPER
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT FOR ANY
OF US --
PLEASE HELP US TO FILL THE
PROMISE OF AFFORDABLE HIGH
QUALITY PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE PLACING OF
WILL BUT CHAMBER DINO A MY NAME
IS JAMES BALDWIN I'M A SENIOR
LEGAL STUDIES MAJOR AT UC SANTA
CRUZ.
I'M ALSO A LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR STUDENT GOVERNMENT AND I
SERVE AS A BOARD MEMBER FOR THE
UC STUDENT STUDENTS ASSOCIATION.
I'M HERE TO VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR
SB.
FOUR SIXTY ONE WITH CALIFORNIA
EXPECTING TO FACE A DEFICIT OF
OVER MILLION SKILLED WORKERS
RAISING STUDENT GRADUATION AND
RETENTION RATES ARE IMPERATIVE
TO CLOSE THIS GAP.
SINCE IN THE SHIP'S SUCH AS
EXTENDING CAL GRANT SUMMER
SESSIONS WILL ALLOW MORE
STUDENTS TO ATTAIN THEIR
EDUCATIONS AND BEGIN TO
CONTRIBUTE TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY SOON.
PLEASE CONSIDER SUPPORTING THIS
BILL AS WELL AS SIMILAR MEASURES
SUCH AS SB TWO NINETY ONE THANK
YOU TIME THANK YOU.
HELLO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND LISTENING TO WHAT WE
HAVE TO SAY --
MY NAME IS PARKER STROHMAIER I'M
A THIRD YEAR STUDENT AT UC SANTA
CRUZ AND I JUST WANT TO STRESS
THE IMPORTANCE OF EXPANDING OUR
CAL GRANT PROGRAMS TO REALLY
REFLECT THE TOTAL COST OF
STUDENT --
EDUCATION I KNOW THAT OVER THE
SUMMER I'M I WAS LOOKING FOR OFF
CAMPUS HOUSING IN THE SANTA CRUZ
AREA WHICH IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR
ME TO DO.
AND AND I'M NOT THE ONLY STUDENT
THAT HAS TROUBLE AND IS AT RISK
OF BEING HOMELESS I KNOW PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN HOMELESS IN NEW
OUR COUCH SURFING I KNOW PEOPLE
WHO ARE FOOD INSECURE.
AND HAVING THESE EXPANDED CAL
GRANTS --
WILL REALLY HELP --
STUDENTS AND NOT AREA AND
EXPANDING THEM TO THE SUMMER --
WILL ALSO INCREASE OUR
GRADUATION RATES AND HELP THE
STUDENTS GET INTO THE WORK FORCE
GET JOBS --
SO THAT HOPEFULLY THE CHECKS
THAT SO MANY STUDENTS HAVE TO
SEND HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES CAN
BE A LITTLE BIT BAKER ONCE THEY
GRADUATE.
THANK YOU.
I'M GONNA STOP FOR A MINUTE AN
**** TO THE STUDENTS BECAUSE I
THINK WE'RE ALL STUDENTS IN LINE
NOW YES.
ANYONE WHO'S NOT A STUDENT.
NOT A STUDENT WHO ARE YOU.
YEAH YEAH AND THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOME WITH YOU
PROJECT THE KIND OF STATE REASON
POLICY ANY OKAY OKAY --
RIGHT.
WE WE OF NOW INTO ABOUT FORTY
FIVE FORTY EIGHT MINUTES OF A
PUBLIC --
TESTIMONY AND THEY'RE GONNA NEED
THE ROOM HERE IT PRETTY SOON AND
I KNOW THAT STUDENTS CAME FROM
FAR -- FROM
A FAR DISTANCE YOU KNOW TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE BUT AS YOU
CAN SEE.
I'M THE ONLY ONE LEFT OF THE
LEGISLATORS HERE --
AND IS A SUGGESTION AND I HOPE
THAT YOU MAY TAKE IT.
THAT IF WE MIGHT MOVE OUTSIDE
WHEN WOULD LIKE TO ADJOURN THE
MEETING.
AND JUST STEP OUTSIDE AND KINDLY
HERE FROM A FEW OF YOU.
OUTSIDE THE THE THE THIS THIS --
ROOM AMENABLE TO EVERYONE YOU
KNOW I I I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT YOU COME UP HERE.
AND AND I THINK YOUR VOICES NEED
TO BE HEARD --
BUT I THINK THERE'S ABOUT TWENTY
SEVEN STUDENTS STILL IN LINE.
AND AND AND I'M REALLY.
KIND OF AN HOUR LATE ALREADY --
TO THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS THAT
THAT WE ATTEND EVERYDAY SO WOULD
THAT BE ALRIGHT WITH EVERYONE.
FIRE DURING A MANAGER IN THIS
MEETING WE'RE GONNA MOVE OUTSIDE.
AND AND AND HOPE WE CAN JUST --
COULD CONVERSE FOR MAYBE JUST A
COUPLE OF MINUTES THAT ARE RIGHT
WITH ALL WITH ALL LET'S DO THAT
[inaudible]
WE'RE DURING